Mlu lu lu lu lu lu lu
Hallo
Hallo, funktioniert alles?
Omega lul
Maxonline, what?!
Richtiges Dance Game
Ich poste das glaube ich nochmal auf Twitter
Ich war ewig never on
Ja wenn jetzt meine Foz- äh Foschau noch richtig funktionieren würde, hätte das
natürlich was
Sagt mir mal, wie Abmischung ist Hintergrundsound und mein Gelaber und so
Laut OBS ist das ganz okay.
Da, ich poste das jetzt erstmal auf Twitter.
Perfekt so.
Jawohl.
Wunderbar.
Also, was wir heute machen übrigens, ähm, ob ich den Chat unten eingeblendet lasse, müssen wir nochmal gucken gleich.
Also, was wir heute machen, ich meine, im Prinzip steht es ja schon im Titel, ne?
Hast du schon die K95?
Ja, habe ich.
Das wollte ich euch eigentlich gleich jetzt mal...
Ich wollte euch eigentlich erstmal, bevor wir anfangen, was zu meiner neuen Tastatur erzählen.
Aber jetzt muss meine Vorschau erstmal richtig funktionieren.
Die backt übelst rum.
Ich habe angeblich null Zuschauer.
Ich kann meinen Chat nicht richtig lesen.
Das liegt aber jetzt nicht an OBS, das liegt aber am zweiten Rechner.
Nee, da komme ich rumspann.
Bestimmt das Windows-Update.
Das 100% das Windows-Update.
Weil ich habe an dem Rechner nichts gemacht.
Der war jetzt einfach zwei Monate...
Der war halt aus, seit ich nicht mehr gestreamt habe, der zweite.
Und jetzt?
Aber vor irgendwie...
Letzte Woche habe ich irgendwie mal ein Windows-Update gemacht.
Und seitdem...
Seitdem...
Da, spackt der jetzt rum.
Habt ihr schon das neue Windows-Update gemacht?
Das Beste ist ja, ne?
Das ist ja das April-Update.
Was jetzt quasi im...
Ne?
Nicht im April kam.
Lull.
So.
Also, was wir heute machen ist...
Wir müssen noch was kleines programmieren morgen für die...
Oder beziehungsweise für die E3-Strems, die in den nächsten Tagen kommen.
Weil ich werde das Ganze auch, wie gesagt, verändern.
Fängt morgen an mit EA.
Ich werde das Ganze hier auch wieder streamen.
Und wir können das da ein bisschen lustig machen.
Über den ganzen Scheiß, der so gelabert wird.
Zur Tastatur sage ich gleich was.
Wir müssen nämlich noch was kleines programmieren.
Aber erstmal was zu meiner neuen Tastatur.
Das haben wir nämlich auch ein paar per Twitter gefragt.
Und zwar...
Ich habe mir zwei neue Tastaturen gekauft.
Und zwar, Achtung.
Einmal die hier.
Von Corsair.
Corsair.
Und dann noch einmal eine Ducky 1-2 Skyline.
Das eine ist so eine super übertrieben fancy RGB...
Hast du nicht gesehen? Tastatur?
Das ist die, die ich hier auch gerade habe.
Das erste, was ich gemacht habe, ist da oben auf den Knopf gedrückt.
Auf den hier, auf den Knopf.
Und habe...
Ne, auf den da.
Und habe erstmal RGB ausgeschaltet.
Das erste, was passiert ist.
Erstmal RGB ausgeschaltet.
Also die habe ich hier gerade am Start.
Und man hört es ja auch schon, das ist mechanische Getippe.
Und dann habe ich mir noch, weil ich es einfach mal vergleichen will,
habe ich mir noch die hier bestellt.
Das ist auch eine mechanische Tastatur.
Die sind preislich gar nicht so unterschiedlich.
Die Corsair Tastatur kostet irgendwie 80 Euro mehr.
Was man muss...
Ohne Scheiß, ne.
Guckt euch mal den Preis von diesem Ding an.
Die sind noch nicht mal ganz dicht, oder?
190 Euro.
Für eine Tastatur.
Ist die vergoldet.
Oder was?
Ich meine, für eine Tastatur, das ist schon ganz schön beknackt, oder?
Uptime, ja.
20 Sekunden oder so.
Ja, also es ist total bescheuert.
Aber, ich habe es jetzt so gemacht.
Ich habe mir die hier jetzt.
Also die, im Prinzip, finde ich die hier vom Layout und so.
Ich finde die viel angenehmer.
Das sieht halt aus wie so eine 0815.
Also optisch, ne.
Dieses Ding sieht aus wie so eine 0815 Billig-Tastatur.
Das ist auch nicht so viel.
Das wäre 80 Euro billiger als die.
Na, 60 Euro billiger als die andere.
Aber, vom Layout her finde ich das viel angenehmer als das Ding.
Das Problem ist nämlich so ein bisschen.
Hier sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut.
Das ist halt.
Das sieht man auch gut.
Ja, wir programmieren gleich was, dass man hier sowas einblenden kann als Overlay.
Hoffentlich klappt das.
Ich bin ja nicht so der WPF-Held.
So, wenn man das mal so vergleicht, ne.
Das da zu dem da.
Man, das ist natürlich viel abgespaceter hier, das Zeug von Corsa.
Aber, ich komme mit dem Layout hier viel besser klar.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen laut jetzt?
Nö, das passt eigentlich.
So, und ich habe es jetzt so gemacht.
Ich habe mir die auf die Arbeit mitgenommen zum testen.
Die habe ich hier daheim.
Ich habe das vor allem so gemacht, weil die hat halt Makro-Tasten hier nebendran.
Wobei ich halt die Software nicht installiert habe, ne.
Aber, da kommen wir gleich zu.
Was ich an der Tastatur nicht gut finde, was mir überhaupt nicht gefällt, sind die kleinen Windows-Tasten.
Natürlich will man jetzt noch selber als Gamer so.
Dazu braucht man Windows-Tasten.
Das ist overrated, jebated, activated, outdated.
Braucht man nicht.
Aber, ich brauche das, weil ich verwende die Windows-Taste zum Desktop-Switchen.
Also entweder hier, so Windows, Windows-Desktop.
Oder halt auch auf, wenn ich bei Linux gestartet habe, da verwende ich halt Windows-Taste und dann 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 für zum Desktop-Durchschalten.
Und wenn die Windows-Taste so furz klein hier ist, dann treffe ich die manchmal nicht.
Was auch doof ist.
Dass die Makro-Tasten hier sind.
Ich meine, okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo man die sonst hinmachen sollte.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Vielleicht an die Seite oder so.
Das Problem ist, wenn man nicht hinguckt, ja.
Und wenn man nicht der krass trainierte Zehn-Finger-Blindschreiber ist, der sich hier an diesen kleinen Nippeln auf den Tasten orientiert.
Dann hat man das Problem, dass man halt instinktiv mit dem kleinen Finger den Rand der Tastatur sucht, wenn man Control drücken will.
Und ich drücke so oft Makro-Taste.
Makro-Taste 6, obwohl ich eigentlich Control drücken will.
Weil ich sage, Rand-Tastatur Control.
So, und dann stimmt halt der Rest nicht.
Dann ist dann A auf einmal Caps Lock und das passt nicht.
Pisst es bei euch auch?
Ne, es hat aber gepisst.
Bin gestern nass geworden auf dem Rückweg von der Arbeit.
Heute Morgen nass geworden auf dem Hinweg von der Arbeit.
Auf dem Rückweg heute glücklicherweise nicht.
So, aber an sich ist diese Tastatur wirklich gut.
Da kann man nichts zu sagen.
Das Ding ist natürlich komplett over...
...priced.
Ja, das ist viel zu teuer.
Also viel zu teuer.
Aber es ist gut.
Einen Vorteil hat das Ding hier auch.
Und ich werde wahrscheinlich auch nochmal beide Tastaturen vergleichen.
Und so dann mal halb mir erzählen in irgendeinem Video, was ich dazu denke.
Ja PC, lustig, das habe ich mir auch überlegt.
Ich mache einfach Control auf die Makro-Taste.
Das Problem ist, wenn ich Control auf die Makro-Taste mache, meistens drückst du ja Control zum ducken oder sowas.
Und dann drückst du Control.
Und dann suchst du die Tastatur.
Und dann suchst du instinktiv WASD.
Und dann bist du dann, anstatt auf WASD, bist du auf Q, Caps Lock, D und A.
Das ergibt...
Dann machst du ja noch mehr kaputt, wie die falsche Control-Taste drücken.
Aber die Tastatur ist schon nice.
Und was ich wirklich gut daran finde, ist, dass die keinen Rahmen so richtig hat.
Also ihr seht ja, die Tasten, die stecken quasi direkt auf dem Metalluntergrund drauf.
Und das heißt, selbst wenn man vom Rechner ist, was ich mir jetzt schon die letzten Jahre abgewöhnt habe und letzter Zeit irgendwie wieder angewöhne.
Ähm...
Wenn man vom Rechner was futtert oder sei es auch nur was Kleines oder irgendwas macht.
Oder sei es öfter Sachen auspackt oder so.
Also sprich, wo es Krümel und Fussel und sonst was gibt.
Dann fallen die hier nicht rein.
Das hast du hier natürlich schon.
Das hier ist so eine ganz klassische Tastatur mit...
Also vom Gehäuse her.
Da fallen halt die Krümel rein.
Wobei es halt bei den Switchen, bei diesen Cherry...
Wir müssen dann auch gleich mal anfangen zu programmieren, sonst wird das ja nix.
Bei diesen Switchen...
Da ist nicht so viel wie bei ner Rubber Dome Tastatur, wo sich das irgendwie drunter klemmen kann.
Aber genug.
Also ich geh mal davon aus, die Tastatur wird schneller innen drin dreckig, wie die Tastatur.
So war das jetzt so anzugleichen.
Also wie gesagt, aktuell habe ich die.
Man hört es ja auch am Tippen, glaube ich, ein bisschen im Hintergrund.
Muss mal kurz gucken, wie der...
Geht eigentlich.
Ich meine, ich hau jetzt auch ganz schön drauf.
So.
Ähm...
Muss mal kurz gucken.
Also falls ich was überlege, schreibt es einfach nochmal.
Schreibt Ed Wubblers davor.
Little Samsung schreibt, Schmutz sammelt sich einiges bei der Razer.
Dance Game.
Razer.
Ne, ökonomische Tastatur komme ich damit klar.
Übrigens, weil mich die Leute immer gefragt...
Ich zeig euch jetzt mal, was ich für ne Tastatur vorher hatte.
Passt mal auf.
Moment.
Ähm...
Microsoft Office...
Übrigens, ich...
Ich geb mir mittlerweile gar keine Mühe, mal richtig zu schreiben.
Google Auto corrected das ja eh.
Also, ich hatte bisher immer ein Microsoft Office Keyboard 1.0a.
Passt mal auf, ey.
Passt mal auf.
Das Ding.
Ne, das da hatte ich bisher immer.
Das...
So, das ist ne Tastatur.
Ich hab's jetzt hier nicht stehen.
Sonst könnte ich mal hinten drauf gucken, wie Bauja oder so.
Die liegt hier hinten auf dem Sofa.
So.
Und...
Haben wir die vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen größer?
Genau das Ding.
So.
Und das Geile ist...
Ich mein, die Tastatur ist super, ja?
Also, die war super.
Das ist zwar ne Rubber Dome Tastatur, aber...
Die hatte schon zwar so eine der ersten Tastatur mit Funktionstasten und so nem Rad hier neben und so.
Damals war das super fancy.
Und jetzt passt mal auf, von wann das Ding ist.
Ähm...
Sieht man das hier?
Ja.
Also, guck mal.
Ende 2005 schreibt hier irgendein Typ im Chip-Forum, Treiber gesucht.
Das heißt, Ende 2005 hat er für diese Tastatur schon irgendwie nicht mehr offensichtlich sein Zeug gefunden.
Also, ich glaub, die Tastatur, die ich hab, die ist irgendwie von 2002 oder irgendwie sowas gewesen.
Also, sprich, die war ihr Geld aber sowas von wert.
Wenn man sich überlegt, 15 Jahre die gleiche Tastatur.
Und es war ja an der bis jetzt nichts kaputt.
Ich hab da zigmal was reingeschüttet oder sonst was.
Und das einzige, was jetzt kaputt gegangen ist, ist die Arrow Down Taste.
Das ist alles.
Mir ist nicht kaputt gegangen.
In 17 Jahren Tastatur.
Also, das ist richtig Pogas, würde ich sagen.
Das ist massiver Pogas, ist das schon.
So, und jetzt hab ich mir halt nochmal wieder was...
Ich mein, wenn die auch nur annähernd so lange hält, ne?
Die Corsair Tastatur.
Wenn die nur annähernd so lange hält, dann ist die ihre 180 Euro oder sowas da scheißkostet.
Wert.
Ich mein, gehen wir mal gucken, was es kostet.
Was kostet die auf Amazon zurzeit?
Amazon...
Äh...
Ja, genau.
195.
Ich glaub, ich hab's ein Ticken günstiger, als ich's bestellt hab.
So, overrated.
Aber die hier gefällt mir insgesamt vom Layout her viel besser.
Die hat ne bisschen nervige Makro-Programmierfunktion.
Aber die hat auch hochwertigere Tasten.
Die Corsair hat so ne ganz normale...
Ganz normale...
So Plastik obendrauf.
Wisst ihr?
So glattes...
Glattes Plastik.
Außer hier auf der Leertaste und auf den Makro-Tasten.
So glattes Plastik.
Und...
Die Tastatur neigen ja dazu...
Egal wie sehr man sich die Finger wascht.
Ja, ein bisschen Fett hast du immer an den Fingern.
Ganz automatisch.
Die werden dann...
Die werden dann so...
So glänzend oben auf den Tasten.
Und das hast du hier gar nicht.
Die haben hier so ne...
Die haben hier quasi noch teurere Tasten drinne.
Und...
Es ist leider nix dabei hier mit hochgenauer Auflösung, dass man das sieht.
Wir haben hier größer als...
Bam!
20 Megapixel.
Oh fuck, das gibt's echt.
The fuck?
Ok, jetzt gucken wir uns mal die Hi-Res Tastatur an.
Von Bach...
Von...
Da ist Virus...
Virus ist eingefangen hier.
Oder auch nicht.
Ja, man...
Man sieht's...
Alter, was sind das für Seiten hier, wo man hier rauskommt?
Man sieht's nicht richtig.
Aber die hat so ne Beschichtung, die ist ganz ganz leicht rau.
So, aber jetzt müssen wir mal anfangen.
Ich werde euch mal kurz erklären, was wir heute programmieren müssen.
Weil...
Morgen ist E3 EA Stream.
Morgen 20 Uhr.
Hier.
Auf Twitch.
Die irgendwie einen hosten.
Der dann wahrscheinlich random auf einmal auf der Bühne erscheint und ich nicht weiß, wer es ist.
So, und wir gucken uns ja wie gesagt die nächsten paar Tagen die Streams an, die zu normalen Zeiten sind.
Ich glaube Ubisoft war 3 Uhr nachts oder Sony war 3 Uhr nachts.
Irgendeiner war 3 Uhr nachts.
Das werde ich mir wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich nicht geben.
Ähm...
Cbaro hat was tolles programmiert.
Das hast du gemacht.
Ja.
Und...
Man weiß...
Man hat halt noch keine Ahnung, was bei EA so dran kommt.
Und wir gucken uns das Ganze zusammen an.
Und können...
Müssen da natürlich auch ein bisschen ablästern über das Ganze.
Weil wahrscheinlich wieder total viel Bullshit dabei sein wird.
Deswegen müssen wir heute...
Im Stream.
Wir müssen ein EA E3 2008 Bullshit Bingo Sheet erstellen.
Ganz wichtig.
Das brauchen wir.
Da müssen wir uns gleich mal ein bisschen überlegen, was man dafür nehmen könnte.
Ja.
Also eine Sache, die auf jeden Fall morgen passieren wird bei EA ist.
Es wird wieder irgendein Auto über die Bühne fahren.
Und es hat keiner eine Ahnung warum.
Das waren nämlich die letzten E3 Streams von EA auch immer so.
Da ist einfach...
Da ist ein Auto über die Bühne gefahren.
Und ich war...
Was...
Warum fährt das Auto jetzt da?
Was hat das damit zu tun?
Ja.
Und dann kam da noch irgendein Typ, der ausgestiegen ist von BMW oder so.
Der erzählt hat, wie geil das Auto ist.
Irgendwann kam dann das Neue in den Post.
Alles war total bescheuert.
Und dann...
Es kommt auch garantiert wieder irgendein random...
Äh...
Random YouTube Star auf die Bühne, wo ich mich dann wieder frage, wer ist das überhaupt?
Ich kenne die ja alle mittlerweile nicht mehr.
So.
Und dafür brauchen wir, um das Ganze ein bisschen aufzulockern, eine Möglichkeit...
Ähm...
Sinnlose Memes einzublenden auf Knopfdruck.
Und wir können den ganzen Stream heute abkürzen.
Wenn ihr ein Programm kennt, mit dem ich auf Knopfdruck...
Also quasi zum Beispiel ich drücke Strg L oder sowas.
Und es zeigt mir quasi einen PNG Overlay über...
Über allem an.
Hat sich meine Maus gerade irgendwie DPI runtergedepiet?
Fühlt sich irgendwie so an.
Er ist auf...
8...
800.
Passt eigentlich.
Warum leuchtet denn meine Maus denn?
Ich habe das Leuchten von meiner Maus da ausgestellt.
Logitech.
Lull.
So.
Und ähm...
Das brauche ich.
Also ein Programm, das auf Knopfdruck mir transparente PNGs auf dem Bildschirm anzeigt.
Ich weiß, dass ich das im OBS machen kann.
Ähm...
Aber in OBS sehe ich es ja nicht.
Da seht es ja nur ihr.
Das ist die Viren-Seite von vorhin.
Äh...
Scary Lecky.
In den Bullshit-Bingo kann alles rein.
Sowas von Random YouTuber erscheint auf der Bühne.
Ähm...
Auto fährt über die Bühne.
Alles.
Ja.
Und irgendwie Buzzwords oder irgendwie sowas.
Da musst du...
Wir müssen es nicht so genau nehmen.
So.
Ja und Fullscreen-Briefing auf dem zweiten Bildschirm ist auch doof.
Weil ich will es ja sehen.
Hier direkt.
Und ich habe auch keinen Bock auf den zweiten Bildschirm zu gucken.
Weil ich bin...
Ich gucke mir ja den Stream an.
Ich will dann quasi einfach nur mal, wenn irgendwas dummes passiert im Stream, will ich einfach mal eine Taste drücken.
Und...
Keine Ahnung.
Fünf mal hinter eine Lull einblenden oder so.
RIP.
Leute, ich sage euch.
Ich war wirklich traurig an dem Tag.
Als sie gepostet haben, dass TotalBiscuit gestorben ist.
Das hat mich wirklich mitgenommen.
Wusstet ihr, der Typ ist fast nicht auf dem Tag.
Aber plus minus ein paar Monate ist er genau so alt gewesen wie ich.
Er sieht mir sogar...
Beziehungsweise, was heißt er sieht mir?
Ich sehe ihm sogar ein bisschen ähnlich.
Und es war wirklich...
Ich habe...
Also, das kann es nicht sein.
Das hat mich wirklich mitgenommen.
Es gab in den letzten Jahren eh...
Internet Hulk hat mich auch mitgenommen.
Ich meine, das sind Leute, ich kenne sie nicht persönlich.
Ja?
Ich kenne Leute, die waren deutlich jünger oder gleich alt wie ich.
Internet Hulk, jetzt TotalBiscuit.
Es ist...
Es verrecken alle jungen Leute.
Das ist doch scheiße, oder?
So.
Und sowas will ich hier einfach mal in den Streams dann einblenden können.
Per Overlay.
Und eins weiß ich jetzt schon.
Windows Forms kann es nicht.
Katze, was ist?
Mau.
Meine Katze guckt gerade hinter meinen Rechner und...
Ah, ne.
Es werden Kabel eingefangen.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Das können wir machen.
So.
Und ich weiß jetzt schon, mit Windows Forms wird das Ganze nix.
Weil Windows Forms hat es nicht so mit...
Falls es jetzt raschelt, ist normal.
Ich versuche gerade mein Headset zu entwirren.
Windows Forms hat es nicht so mit Transparenz.
Deswegen müssen wir das wohlgetrunken mit WPF machen.
Und ich habe von WPF eigentlich überhaupt keine Ahnung.
Aber das kriegen wir schon.
Das kriegen wir schon gebacken.
Da war das erstmal ein neues Projekt.
Und das wird was ganz kleines.
Das wird vielleicht 100, 150 Zeilen oder so.
Einfach nur Hotkey.
Da muss ich mir noch irgendeine Hotkey Library raussuchen.
Weil das machen wir nämlich selbst.
Weiß nicht wie das geht unter Windows.
Das ist geil.
Geh win.
Weil das, weil du Pussycam geschrieben hast, zeigt mir das der Twitch Automoderator jetzt
an, ob ich das nicht löschen will.
Geil.
Sowas in der Art.
Äh.
Wart mal.
Ich guck, ich guck mir das mal an, was er geschrieben, was er, was er gepostet hat.
Äh.
Okay, wann kommt hier?
Ja, so um, so umgef, so ungefähr.
Bloß, dass ich es halt auch selbst sehen will.
Und auf Knopfdruck einen ausplannen.
Ja, ja, ungefähr sowas.
Genau sowas.
So, WPF Projekt.
Das nennen wir mal, wie nennen wir das?
Meme.
Äh.
Leute, ich brauche noch einen guten Namen für das Ding.
Meme.
Gbater.
Das ist doch übelst ein Kackname, so kannst du es nicht nennen.
Meme.
Overlay.
Wir nennen es mal ein bisschen sachlich, das Ganze, ja.
Meme Board.
Meme Board finde ich cool.
Meme Board ist gut.
Das gefällt mir.
Katze, was ist denn?
Mau.
Was ist denn?
Ja.
Die geht voll ab neben mir gerade.
Ich kann jetzt nicht.
Ich gebe dir gleich ein paar Leckerlis, dass du Ruhe gibst.
Ne, erzähl mal ein bisschen.
Wow.
Was ist denn das für ein Schriftcode?
Oh fuck.
Hast du deine Katzencam noch?
Nein, im Stream nicht.
Okay.
Äh.
Ja, Meme Board finde ich.
Meme.
Board finde ich gut.
Das machen wir so.
Meme Board heißt das Ding.
Boah.
Das WPF Zeug ist immer so übertrieben überladen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Du hast hier Code Fenster.
Hallo?
Code Verzeihung.
Code Fenster ist quasi ein Achtel vom Bildschirm oder so.
Okay.
Wie wäre es mit einer 27-Grad-Drehung beim Einfingern?
Also ich habe von WPF schon nicht viel Ahnung, wenn ich da noch Animationen machen soll.
Also wir machen eine Animation.
Wir machen Drehen oder sowas.
Weil Drehen ist gut, habe ich mir überlegt, wenn man sich hier, wenn man beispielsweise
hier lullt, ne.
Wenn man hier Lachen hat.
Und dann dreht es sich nach links und ich kann es immer wieder starten.
Dann sieht es so aus, als würde er lachen.
Wisst ihr?
Es dreht sich so nach links.
So.
Hahaha.
Ihr seht es ja gleich.
Okay.
Also.
Wie fangen wir denn hier jetzt am besten an?
Kann man das machen?
Nein.
Scheiße.
Hier unten nicht.
Mal zumachen.
Hide.
Nein.
Weg.
Brauche ich nicht.
Wer braucht Compilerwarnung?
Komplett overrated.
So.
Ähm.
Mein.
Also habe ich.
Gibt.
Ist zufällig irgendjemand da, dass ich mit WPF auskenne?
Das könnte voll die bösste Idee werden.
Ah.
Oh.
Lull 3D.
Boah.
Fuck.
Kann WPF GIFs?
Das müssen wir ausprobieren.
Moment.
Leute.
Das müssen wir ausprobieren.
Lull 3D GIF.
Das muss ich jetzt mal testen.
Ob das das kann.
Save Image.
Wir machen uns auf dem Desktop mal einen neuen Ordner.
Irgendwie Folder.
Äh.
Wieso?
Lull 3D.
Äh.
Hat er das jetzt?
Ist das jetzt ein GIF?
GIF.
Mal gucken ob WPF das kann.
Das wäre geil.
Da könnte man sogar animiertes.
Äh.
Das probieren wir uns mal aus.
Moment.
Äh.
äh.
Image.
Oh mein WPF Zeug Source.
So und jetzt müssen wir irgendwie diesen komisch.
Warum?
Warum hat Windows eigentlich so eine Kackfade?
Gucken.
Mal gucken ob WPF GIFs kann.
Ich hab ja so meine Zweifel dass das geht.
Ok.
Anzeigen tut das schonmal.
Aber.
Er dreht's nicht.
Das würd mich aber echt mal interessieren.
WPF.
WPF Animated.
Ob das geht?
Hat Max früher nicht immer Chillstep gehatet?
Ich habe auch mal Haftbefehl gehatet.
Jetzt höre ich das sogar manchmal.
How do I get animated GIF-Work in WPF?
Okay, es gibt irgendeine Library für uns.
Das ist gut, das können wir nehmen.
Aber erstmal machen wir was mit normalen Bildern.
Danach können wir immer noch animierte GIFs einblenden.
Okay, wir brauchen jetzt erstmal ein paar Bilder zum Testen.
Also was, lasst mal überlegen Leute.
Was braucht man für quasi unverzichtbare Memes für E3-Livestreams?
Also ohne Lull geht es schon mal nicht.
Da sind wir uns einig, oder?
Ohne Lull ist es nicht möglich.
Ich hätte es gerne transparent.
Okay.
Also ohne Lull geht es schon mal auf keinen Fall.
Ähm, was braucht man sonst noch?
Wonka S, brauche ich auf jeden Fall.
Geht auch nicht ohne.
Haben wir den hier auch irgendwo transparent?
Also Transparenz brauchen wir auf jeden Fall im Bild.
Das können wir jetzt nicht alle selbst basteln.
Ist er transparent?
Ja, nice.
Äh, Safe Image.
Wonka S.
Dance Game, Hyper System.
Oh, Resident Sleeper brauchen wir natürlich.
Ja, unbedingt.
Gibt es den irgendwie hoch aufgelöst?
Anele, ne Anele brauchen wir nicht.
Gebated.
Den könnten wir gebrauchen.
Also erstmal brauchen wir hier...
Haben wir Resident Sleeper mal irgendwie in ein bisschen höherer Auflösung?
Den brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Okay, ähm...
Wir nehmen jetzt mal drei Bilder zum Testen.
Ach ja.
Wie wir auch brauchen.
Wen wir unbedingt brauchen noch ist hier.
Äh, Confused.
Ne, der da.
Wie heißt er denn?
Ja genau, Confused.
Den brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Das geht sonst nicht.
Transparenz.
Gibt es den Transparent irgendwo?
Okay, das ist ein bisschen klein das Bild.
Okay, ähm...
Wir fangen jetzt erstmal an.
Ich mein, oh, Donation.
The fuck?
Danke.
Danke für die Donation.
Ähm...
Wenn ich jetzt noch sehen...
Sebaro, 20 Euro Dankeschön.
Ob das Spenden noch funktioniert?
Klar funktioniert das.
Klar funktioniert.
Funktioniert?
Vielleicht...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es bei euch funktioniert.
Also...
Ich wollte jetzt...
Ich hätte jetzt normalerweise...
Könnte ich ja meinen Prime-Sub sehr laut machen.
Aber ich habe ja keinen...
Ich bin ja kein Partner auf Twitch.
Gibt es keinen Prime-Sellout.
So.
Okay, wie fangen wir denn jetzt am besten an?
Ich wollte es mal...
Ich habe viel zu viel geschwätzt.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal kurz in mich gehen.
So.
Ähm...
Wir setzen jetzt erstmal das Ding auf irgendwie was...
Wo ich weiß, dass es funktioniert.
So.
Okay.
Ähm...
Und jetzt müssen wir das Fenster...
Müssen wir jetzt transparent machen.
Weil sonst sieht es ja scheiße aus.
Wir müssen das Fenster ausblenden und wir müssen das Fenster transparenter machen.
Easy clap.
Ja, das können wir alles einbauen.
Das...
Wir müssen jetzt ja erstmal das Ding basteln, mit dem wir es überhaupt anzeigen können.
Okay.
Ähm...
Also.
Okay, jetzt kommen meine krassen WPF-Skills.
Äh...
Show Taskbar oder sowas gibt es.
False.
Wollen wir nicht.
Wobei, das lassen wir nochmal drin.
Vielleicht müssen wir das Ding irgendwie beenden über die Taskbar.
Ähm...
Window Mode gibt es glaube ich irgendwie.
Windows Style...
Window...
None wollen wir.
Weil...
Wir müssen das Ding durch den Strom herum anzeigen.
Dann wollen wir irgendwas mit Transparency...
Allow Transparency True.
So.
Ähm...
Weil wir wollen ja, dass der Hintergrund transparent ist von dem Bild.
Was das eigentlich ist.
Was sagt...
Ich mein, wenn ich das hier einblende ist das ja total bescheuert.
Das ist ein weiße Box.
Jetzt ist nur die Frage...
Wie kriegt man jetzt das Fenster transparent?
Gibt es da sowas wie Back...
Background?
Background.
Aha.
Oh, das funktioniert.
Nice. Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Das ist doch schon mal was.
Jetzt haben wir hier unsere Meme-Overlays schon mal.
Wir können es zwar weder bewegen,
noch rotieren, noch sonst was, aber wir können es schon mal anzeigen.
So, wir haben auch noch keine Shortcuts, wo man das Ganze
ausblenden kann.
Ja, Patrick, ich krieg bei
XML auch immer Anfälle.
Ja, Poggers brauchen wir aber auch wirklich.
Poggers Transparent.
Poggers.
Gibt es das auch in groß?
Vielleicht findet ja einer von euch
Poggers
in ordentlicher Auflösung.
Könnt ihr das ja mal im Chat schreiben.
So.
Jetzt müssen wir natürlich gucken, dass wir
die Bilder noch irgendwie wechseln können.
Das kann ja nicht allzu schwer sein.
Okay, also wir haben jetzt transparentes Bild.
Dann machen wir das mal so.
Wir machen statische Größe. Scheiß drauf.
Wir machen einfach das Fenster.
Das Fenster ist 1000x1000 groß.
Und das Bild ist, keine Ahnung,
900x900 groß, weil
wenn wir das drehen, dann brauchen wir
noch ein bisschen Rand drumherum,
dass es nicht klippt.
Ich muss mal gerade mal was gucken, Leute.
Ich, dass ich das jetzt übersehen habe.
Meinung zur Übernahme von
GitHub
durch Microsoft.
Ähm.
Ich bin mir da ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz sicher.
Was ich davon halten soll.
Weil ich meine, Microsoft hat schon
sauviel ihrer Projekte auf GitHub.
Die sind mittlerweile sogar der größte,
glaube ich zumindest, größte Open Source
Contributor.
Das hätte man, hätte das mal einer
zu Ballmer-Zeiten gesagt, ja.
Ballmer hat irgendwie
die Stühle nach den Leuten geworfen.
Damals, ja.
Laut Berichten.
Ähm. Microsoft macht in letzter Zeit
gar nicht so viel blöde Sachen.
Aber ich weiß,
keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so das Problem.
GitHub wird an sich weiter funktionieren.
Die Frage ist, was sie in Zukunft damit machen.
Ich hatte ja auch ein bisschen Bedenken bei der Twitch-Übernahme
von Amazon,
dass die ganz komische Dinger machen.
Sie machen ein paar komische Dinger, aber alles in allem
ist Twitch die letzten,
wann haben sie es übernommen? Eineinhalb Jahre oder so.
Finde ich, ist kontinuierlich
immer besser geworden.
GitHub ist übrigens auf Ruby on Rails
Basis, wen es interessiert.
Zumindest waren sie das mal.
So, ähm.
Zum Beispiel einblenden.
Nu.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Mal ein bisschen vorwärts kommen.
Ich habe immer absolut Schneckentempo drauf.
Lässt man sich hier den Code anzeigen?
Ah, ne, da ist er schon.
Code.
Ähm, Schneckentempo drauf, wenn ich
programmieren, ähm,
programmiere im, im Stream.
Ah ja, ganz wichtig.
Wir müssen, wir probieren jetzt,
wir müssen da noch, noch eine Rotation
oder so irgendwie reinbasteln.
So.
Also, was brauchen wir denn da jetzt?
Also, wir müssen erst einmal einstellen,
dass das Fenster immer,
immer oben ist.
Immer vor allen anderen Fenstern,
weil sonst sieht man es ja nicht.
Was, was ich da für ein Tool programmier,
das, das wird etwas Kleines,
wo ich, ähm, irgendwelche Meme-Bilder
als Overlay einblenden kann auf, äh, Knopfdruck.
Ich habe nichts gefunden.
Ich hätte mich, hätte mich auch gewundert,
dass es da nichts gibt.
Aber irgendwie gibt es da nichts.
So.
Deswegen müssen wir das selbst machen.
Du hast ein Poggers-Bild gefunden.
Ne, das ist kein Poggers-Bild.
Das ist ein Fields-Batman.
Da muss man schon korrekt sein.
Yoshi, das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Das, das können wir, das Bild,
das Bild von Yoshi finde ich gut
für Awesome New, äh,
Player-First-Experience.
So, wir müssen jetzt aber erst einmal das Ding hier,
so weit basteln.
Okay, also, was ich machen will, ist, ähm,
ich will es verschieben können.
Ich will es auf jeden Fall verschieben können,
weil, wobei, will ich es, will ich es verschieben können?
Ja, ich will es verschieben können.
Ich will es verschieben können.
Aber vorher,
ne, ich will es maximiert haben,
dass es immer in der Mitte ist.
Oder will ich es verschieben können?
Ich, ich will es verschieben können.
Also, das heißt, wir müssen jetzt erst einmal hier sagen, irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
hier gibt es doch bestimmt auch so etwas wie Maus-Klick.
Maus-Down, ja, Maus-Down.
Right.
Maus-Left-Button-Down.
Das wollen wir haben.
Und dann, das habe ich vorher schon mal auch,
man kann einfach sagen, Track-Move.
Das habe ich mir vorher auf Stack-Overflow
rausgesucht, nicht, dass ich das gewusst hätte, oder so.
Und jetzt können wir
nämlich das Ding schon mal schieben.
Schon mal ganz praktisch.
Ups.
Diese geile Windows-Shake-Funktion.
Weiß jemand, wie man die ausstellen kann?
Ähm, okay. Ja, jetzt haben wir das Ding,
das ganze Ding schon mal ermoven.
Jetzt würde ich sagen,
machen wir, dass das Bild
rotiert.
Und zwar,
Rotation starten wir
bei einem rechten Button-Klick
und beenden sie bei einem rechten Button-Klick.
Hallo, Consti294.
So, wie macht man
jetzt, jetzt, oh,
jetzt kommen halt, dass ich eigentlich keine Ahnung
von WPF habe.
Also, Animation macht man irgendwie so.
Das weiß ich. Man kann,
das weiß ich jetzt.
Ich habe jetzt echt den Virus hier jetzt wahrscheinlich.
Hallo?
Spackt das Ding rum, ja.
Ähm, okay. Also,
nee, Quatsch.
Also, man kann Animation irgendwie
Storyboard, boah, fuck, wie geht denn das
WPF? Ähm,
irgendwie mit Storyboard
geht das. Animieren
eine Eigenschaft mit Hilfe eines Storyboards.
Genau sowas. Oh, die Microsoft-Beispiele,
wisst ihr immer, erschlagen von.
Ja, sowas hier will ich.
Sowas hier. Sowas hier.
Sowas hier will ich
haben. Storyboard,
äh, Fehler. Achso,
nee, das muss in irgendeinen, das muss in irgendeinen
Resource-Block.
Also, ihr könnt
mich zu WPF auch nicht allzu viel fragen.
Ich habe
da bisher noch nicht viel mitgemacht.
Aber, so.
Äh, Storyboard, da können wir jetzt sagen, was
animiert werden soll. Und wir wollen,
oh, eine Anime, äh, eine
Donation.
Ich guck gleich.
Drei Euro, vom Sprat,
the Beast. Eigentlich nur für die drei Euro.
0,3D.
Was ist das für eine Sprache, dat Leben?
Das ist, ähm, das ist XAML.
Das ist irgendwie so ein Microsoft
äh, Hirngespinst
XML-Dialekt.
Und das ist C-Sharp.
Kann man nicht, ich mach mal ein bisschen größer, ne?
Machen wir nicht, ich mach mal ein bisschen größer.
Schön fett, das Ganze. So, Storyboard.
Und dann muss man irgendwie so, ne, ne Key muss,
oh fuck, wie ging denn der Scheiß?
Zum Glück habe ich hier so einen Mini-Spickzettel
gemacht, wo ich mal nachgucken kann.
Wie ging das denn mit, äh,
mit Storyboard unter, unter XAML?
Hier, XKey.
XKey.
Irgendwelche, irgendwelche XAML-Profis am Start.
Äh, so, und das Ding
das nennen wir jetzt, keine Ahnung, Image
Rotation
Storyboard.
Dann muss man noch angeben, was
man rotieren will.
Target Name.
Im, ne.
Ich muss das erstmal benennen.
Image.
So.
Und nun kann ich damit theoretisch,
theoretisch das Ding
animieren, aber ich brauch,
ich brauch was anderes, ich brauch, ähm,
Storyboard Target Name, das hab ich schon.
Ich brauch
jetzt noch, was er, genau,
was er animieren soll, das brauchen wir,
das Ding krempelt, brauchen wir, Katze, was ist?
Ich brauch hier irgendwie
sowas, also,
soweit ich das im Kopf hab, ist das so.
Ähm,
ich hab hier jetzt ein Bild,
ich hab ihm gesagt, was ich für ein Bild einblenden
will, und jetzt kann ich ihm sagen,
welche dieser Eigenschaften, also sowas hier wie
Höhe, Weite, Winkel und sowas,
ich quasi in welcher Zeit, ähm,
quasi linear
geändert haben will.
So, das muss man nur mal die richtige Sonntags rauskriegen.
Wieso nimmst du nicht einfach
WinForms, weil
das mit WinForms nicht funktioniert?
Rhetorische Pause,
WinForms und Transparenz, beziehungsweise
Transparenz auf Window Level
ist scheiße. Es funktioniert,
es funktioniert, aber
du hast nur Probleme damit, zum Beispiel, dass
ähm, hier diese
Anti-Aliaste Render
haben dann halt ne scheiß Farbe und so, das ist
das ist Müll. Oh, der Patrick mit der
Donation, jetzt hab ich's gar nicht gelesen, weil das Ganze so
schnell ging. Soll ich mal mal nachgucken?
Shake to hide
ausschalten in the registry value,
ah, das ist das, das man, guck mal,
das ist, das ist der übliche Microsoft Wahnsinn,
ja? Ich mein, diese Funktion hier,
dass man ein Fenster, ein Fenster
schüttelt und dass alle anderen Fenster minimiert
werden, das ist ja ganz nett
gedacht, aber
es, man könnte
ja in weiser Voraussicht,
ja, da kommt
auch Nadella oder wie er heißt
auf die Idee, dass es
vielleicht nicht jedem gefällt.
Also warum gibt's nicht einfach in den Windows
Settings ne Option, um den Scheiß auszuschalten?
Das ist so
typische Microsoft Kacke.
Das nervt
mich immer.
Okay, lass mich mal kurz konzentrieren.
Wie geht denn das Scheiß jetzt?
Also ich will
mein Image will ich Werte ändern
und zwar von
0 bis zu
360, weil ich mein, ich will's ja
im Kreis drehen und zwar im
Abstand von, sagen wir mal, 2 Sekunden.
Das bedeutet, dass wenn ich
jetzt, so Storyboard
Target-Property ist in dem Fall dann
Image, oh fuck
stimmt das? Ich muss mal nachgucken.
Ich hab mir nämlich so, ich hab mir
die wichtigsten Sachen, so Spickzettel aufgeschrieben.
Weil ich das, weil ich mir
das bei XAML und so nicht merken kann.
Das da brauch ich.
Gott ist das kompliziert. Oh,
XML.
So, genau.
Ich sag, ich will, ich will die
den Winkel will ich rotaten
in der Abstand von
2 Sekunden, ja ok.
Ich kopier mir das einfach, was ich hier
vorher schon mal gemacht hab. Easy, da weiß ich, dass das geht.
Oh, bam.
Jetzt schreckt.
So, jetzt sollte das
Ganze zumindest noch kompilieren und wie ich
letztens wieder von einem unserer Azubis gelernt hab,
wenn es kompiliert, dann funktioniert's.
Gut, jetzt
rechter Maus Button
wenn ich den
rechten Maus Button drücke,
dann will ich, dass das
Bild rotiert.
Gucken, ob wir das, ob wir
das gebacken kriegen.
Ok, also das heißt, wir müssen uns
jetzt erstmal aus den, aus den, aus den
Resources irgendwie
das Storyboard holen. Übrigens, also falls
einer da ist, der sich mit WP auskennt und ich mach
das falsch, könnt ihr mir, könnt ihr mir das gerne schreiben.
Da nicht so großartig viel
geplant von. So, das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt
Resources.
Resources und dann den
Namen vom, von, von meiner
Animation.
Hoffentlich klappt das.
So, und dann
kann man hier irgendwie sagen
Start, Beginn.
Ach ne, ich muss das noch casten aufs
Storyboard.
Ist natürlich nicht importieren, den ganzen
Scheiß noch importieren.
So, und jetzt kann ich sagen, Storyboard
Beginn.
Und wenn ich's jetzt richtig gemacht hab,
dann dreht sich jetzt das Bild, wenn ich rechts
drauf drücke.
Dreht sich aber nicht.
Dreht sich das nicht. Was hab ich, was hab
ich denn falsch gemacht?
Hab ich irgendwas, irgendwas,
irgendwas ist doch hier verkehrt.
Ich glaube, wir pasten mir das einfach mal,
was ich vorher schon mal ausprobiert hab.
Es rotiert nicht.
Aber es movt, das ist schon mal
gut. Errors gibt's
nicht. Ey, dieses, dieses ganze WPF-Krempel,
ey.
Der Eax, der Eax ist auch
da. Ah, bist wieder
daheim. Ah, ich weiß,
was ich vergessen hab. Ich weiß, was ich
vergessen hab. Ich muss ihm, ich muss
ihm den Startwinkel sagen.
Bei diesem Image.
Wo er anfangen soll.
Und es funktioniert's nicht.
Passt mal auf, jetzt geht's. Bam. Wow.
Boah. Okay.
Vielleicht,
vielleicht noch nicht so ganz,
wie ich mir das vorgestellt hab.
Okay, das funktioniert noch nicht so ganz,
wie ich mir das vorgestellt hab, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber es dreht sich
schon mal.
Hahaha.
Omega
0. Okay.
Ich hab, ich weiß sogar, woran es liegt,
dass es nicht funktioniert. Und zwar,
ähm, der nimmt standardmäßig
die linke obere Ecke
zum Rotieren.
Also wisst, wisst ihr, wie ich mein?
Wenn ich, wenn ich, wenn der rotiert, ne?
Also der startet bei einem Winkel von 0.
Also sprich so. Und dann
sagt er ihm hier in der Animaz,
was macht meine Katze denn?
Katze, was machst du denn?
Katze, was machst du da?
Was gibt denn das, wenn's fertig ist?
Was ist?
Hahaha. Lol.
Ähm.
Okay. Und ich muss
ihm sagen, richtig
Patrick, genau, ich muss ihm sagen, wo die,
wo der Punkt ist, um den er
rotieren soll.
Und das geht,
ne.
Und das
geht folgendermaßen. Gut, dass ich mir
das vorher schon mal ein bisschen,
bisschen gecheatet hab,
bisschen vorher was gebastelt hab.
Ähm.
RenderTransformOrigin. Weil ganz im Ernst,
Leute, wer kommt denn auf sowas, ja?
Das musst du wissen, oder du hast verloren.
Und jetzt kann man ihm
sagen, dass er prozentual
in der Mitte starten soll.
Und nachdem's XAML Microsoft Dialekt
ist, kann man die Nullen weglassen. Oder muss man
sogar die Nullen weglassen. Ich weiß nicht, wer
sich das bei Microsoft ausgedacht hat.
Das entzieht sich vollkommen meinem Ver-
Guckt! Bäm! Es rotiert um
die Mitte. Kleiner Scheiß.
Aber es funktioniert.
Und es reset- Guck mal, deswegen meinte ich,
es ist lustig, wenn's links rum rotiert. Da kann man
nämlich, kann ich das so einplanen, da kann ich sagen,
wenn man dann lacht, kann man dann so machen. Das sieht so aus,
man lacht dann auch ein bisschen mehr dabei.
So. Okay, also so die
grundlegenden Sachen funktionieren.
Ich fand's vorher besser.
Ja, man könnte es ja theoretisch
sogar je nach Bild machen.
Okay. Weiter.
Ich würd mal sagen, mehr brauchen wir
eigentlich kein XML basteln.
Genug Augenkrebs. Wir machen
jetzt, wir machen jetzt zwar hier im Code weiter.
Der wahre,
der wahre WPF,
WP sonstwas Pro wird natürlich alles hier
gesammelt irgendwie machen. So.
Das heißt,
wir können das Ding jetzt per Rechtsklick
starten
zu rotieren. Leider per Linksklick noch nicht richtig.
Oder per weiterem
Klick irgendwie noch nicht richtig stoppen.
Und wir können's verschieben. Und wenn man's verschiebt,
ruckelt's.
Zwei FPS, lol.
Also lil quasi.
Aber das funktioniert schonmal. Wir gucken mal, wie das mit einem anderen
Bild aussieht. Wir haben ja hier noch,
wir haben ja hier noch Confuse haben wir noch am Start.
Gucken wir mal. Wir machen ein paar
Zeilenumbrüche rein, dass man das Ganze noch
erkennt.
Confused. Okay, das
funktioniert auch. Aber das ist ein doofes,
das ist eine blöde Variante
von dem Meme. Das, da muss, äh,
da muss, da müssen wir noch was anderes finden,
klein. Okay.
Weiter geht's. Ähm,
nachdem ich dieses Storyboard garantiert noch öfters
brauche, machen wir uns das mal hier als
als Klassenvariable irgendwie oben hin.
Storyboard.
Wir kürzen das einfach mal mit SB ab.
Get. Benutzen wir mal
jetzt die Sharp 7 Feature. Übrigens,
wie gesagt, Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab, sagt Bescheid.
Ups, hab ich
irgendwas vergessen?
Was, was meckert
da?
Compilerfehler? Uäh, ja, ich hab
irgendwo hab ich Syntax, äh,
Fehler gef... Ah, hier.
Da.
Hä? Moment.
Wo?
Wo hab ich was übersehen?
Public
Storyboard. Ach,
Quatsch, man braucht das Get nicht mehr. Man braucht das Get nicht
mehr. Stimmt. Da geht das auch.
So geht das.
Nee.
Wie ging der Scheiß
nochmal? Ach, Moment,
jetzt caste ich da hinten das. Das ist halt auch beknackt.
Siehste? Ja, jetzt geht's.
Jaja, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt funktioniert's.
Alles, alles gut.
Alles gut. Ja, wenn man
Mist schreibt, schreibt man Mist.
Äh, der Get-Code
muss um Get-Block
sein. Nee, das ist
neue Special, die Sharp 7, äh,
die Sharp 7 Feature.
Das darf man nicht so schreiben.
Das ist die kurze Variante.
Okay.
Es funktioniert wahrscheinlich immer noch alles,
oder? Ja. So.
Das heißt, als nächstes kümmern wir uns
mal um, ich würde
sagen, Rotation starten
und Rotation stoppen.
Ähm, machen wir das, machen wir das mal
private.
Also.
Rotation starten, stoppen. Das heißt, wir müssen uns
auf jeden Fall merken, ob das Ding rotiert oder nicht.
Macht, macht's einen E3-Stream.
Ja, morgen, wenn's losgeht. Mit EA geht's los.
Bonjour. Äh, also,
äh, wir merken uns jetzt so was
wie, ähm, is
rotating.
Wie ist denn,
warte mal, wie ist jetzt die, äh,
die Microsoft,
wie sagt Microsoft nochmal, dass man das schreiben muss?
So, ne? Is rotating.
Glaub ich wollen die, dass man das schreibt.
Ist natürlich false.
Was sonst? Wobei das defaultmäßig auch schon
false ist.
Okay.
Jetzt, das heißt, wir merken uns jetzt, ob wir schon mal geklickt haben
und es rotiert und wenn es, und wenn es
rotiert, dann ist der nächste Klick mit der
rechten Maustaste ein Stop.
Das ist eigentlich relativ simpel. Das heißt, wir
gucken jetzt, if
rotating,
dann sagen wir
rotating stop
und vorher sagen, äh, sagen wir ihm,
dass er aufhören soll zu
rotaten. Das ist eigentlich relativ
simpel. So, und dann,
wenn es nicht rotatet, sagen wir
ihm, er soll,
er soll beginnen
und er soll
sich merken, dass es rotatet.
Gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Also rechte Maustaste, also sollte
jetzt einmal starten und stoppen.
Okay, das geht.
Starten, stoppen, starten, stoppen. Man kann immer noch
so dieses, irgendwie so ne blöde Lachanimation
machen.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Jetzt machen, wir machen nochmal was, dass ich das
nicht immer verschieben muss. Wir sagen,
irgendwie,
Windows Style?
Style?
Ich hab kein, Style?
Maximal, oh fuck, ich weiß nicht,
wie das funktioniert.
Wie, wie kann man dem sagen, dass er Fenster
maximieren soll? Window, irgendwas,
es muss was, es muss was mit Windows sein.
Jetzt haben wir den Windows Date, ha?
Windows Date, Windows Date maximized.
Sound scheint mir gerade
bisschen laut zu sein. Nö, passt.
Ist gut.
So, das heißt, jetzt ist es auch immer schön zentriert
in der Mitte. So muss ich das nicht jedes Mal
zentrieren. Sehr schön.
Ich bin aber echt gespannt, was die morgen
auch bei, äh, bei EA zeigen.
Und vor allem,
wie viel, wie viel heiße Luft
ist. Wenn ich, wenn ich mir
überlege, der Vergleich,
ne, das, das
Reveal vom, von Black Ops 4
zum Reveal von Battlefield 5.
Letztendlich glaube ich, dass
mir, wenn ich's mir holen
werde, wahrscheinlich Battlefield 5 deutlich mehr
Spaß machen wird. Es sei denn, der, irgendwie der
Battle-Royale-Modus vom neuen COD wird mich umhauen
oder so. Äh, aber die Präsentation
fand ich vom, von Black Ops 4
so viel angenehmer zu gucken, als von
Battlefield 5. Das könnt ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen.
Das war so ein Gelaber.
Das war
so ein dummes Geschwätze.
Die ganze Zeit.
Most, was, äh,
Realistic War Simulation.
Ja, klar, weil Battlefield,
weil, weil Leute, die Battlefield spielen,
auch echten Krieg wollen. Das ist total bescheuert.
Ah, was schreibt, was
schreibt der Yoshi? Für Customization
und so und schon möchte ich noch Folgendes einreichen.
Animationsvorstand von rechten Rand, bis man alles
sieht, reinfahren lassen, dann wieder
zurückfahren. Hehe.
Können wir machen. Ich muss jetzt aber
erst mal das Ein- und Ausplätten hinkriegen.
Also, so basic ist ja alles gut.
Wir können was einplätten sollen. Jetzt müssen wir nur noch
hinkriegen, dass das Ganze wechselt.
Ähm,
das heißt, wir müssen jetzt
Hotkeys definieren. So,
nachdem ich nicht weiß, wie das unter Windows geht,
und auch ehrlich gesagt,
das jetzt nicht rauskriegen will, noch
auf den letzten Drücker,
gucken wir mal, was es so für
Hotkey-Libraries gibt.
Gibt's nämlich bestimmt welche.
Ja, Hotkeys.
Gucken wir mal, was es so gibt.
Also, man kann
vieles Schlechtes über Windows
und Microsoft sagen,
aber eins muss man ihnen
lassen. Von allen
Entwicklungsumgebungen, Visual Studio
ist mit Abstand,
mit Abstand die Beste.
Es gibt nix, was da auch nur
ansatzweise rankommt.
Für keine Sprache,
meiner Ansicht nach.
Auch wenn ich sonst
normalerweise auch vor allem auf der Arbeit
quasi gar nicht unter Windows unterwegs bin,
aber Visual Studio ist wirklich top.
Da kann man nix sagen.
Da kann Eclipse einpacken,
was ja, das kriegste, kriegt man
Anfälle.
Da kann, ähm, auch das,
meiner Meinung nach, das ganze Jetbrain-Zeug einpacken.
Man kann eigentlich alles einpacken.
Das ist einfach das Beste.
Wenn man, am besten
ist, wenn man, wenn man, wobei früher
hat ReSharper das halt übelst langsam gemacht,
am besten ist, wenn man noch
ein paar Jetbrain-Geschichten dazu installiert, aber
ich find insgesamt, das
Komplettpaket ist das bei Visual Studio mit Abstand
das Beste. So, Global Hotkeys.
Das klingt doch gut, sowas wollen wir haben.
A small C-Sharp Library, which allows
binding and unbinding of Global Hotkeys.
Even when
the application is not focus activated.
Genau das wollen wir haben. Gucken wir uns mal an,
was die für Beispiele auf der GitHub-Seite
haben. Naja, 10 Sterne ist nicht so der
Wahnsinn, aber ist aktuell.
Das ist erstmal das Wichtigste. Das kann ich euch nur als
Tipp geben, wenn man Libraries sucht,
nehmt welche, die aktuell sind.
Weil wenn es irgendwelche Probleme
gibt und das andere Ding oder irgendwas wissen
wollt oder im Zweifelsfall, äh,
irgendwie was findet, was kaputt ist.
Wenn es das, wenn ihr irgendwas habt,
was 2014 das letzte Mal aktualisiert
wurde, habt ihr gelitten.
Da könntet ihr es zwar patchen, wenn man es
kann, ja, je nachdem was es
für eine Sprache ist, wie komplex das Ganze
ist, aber du wirst es nie irgendwo
reinkriegen, offiziell, weil halt letztes
Update 2014, da sucht euch immer
irgendwas aktuelles, wenn es nicht gerade anders
geht. So, jetzt brauchen wir mal ein paar
Beispiele, wie man hier Hotkeys definiert.
Hotkey
Constructor, Hotkey Modifier Keys.
Ja, kopieren wir uns doch mal das
Beispiel. Kopieren
wir uns mal das Beispiel und das Ganze
machen wir im Form Loaded
Event, falls es sowas in
WPF gibt.
Loaded.
Loaded wird
automatisch aufgerufen, sobald das Ding
vollständig gestartet ist.
So, importieren.
Habe
importiert.
So, formatieren wir das mal
anständig.
Äh, das machen wir definitiv
nicht so, wie der hier das macht.
Das ist
der Old School Way, das macht man
immer so.
Sondern, man sagt jetzt,
Parameter ist mir wurscht,
Lambda, und zwar
rufen wir da eine Funktion auf,
die
uns die
Bilder wechselt.
Wobei, wir lassen mal kurz
das Beispiel und gucken, ob das
mit der Message Box funktioniert, was er hier
gemacht hat.
Wir gucken, ob das mit der Message Box funktioniert.
Also, wenn das mit dem Hotkey
registrieren funktioniert...
Das sind ein bisschen viele Klammern, oder?
Moment.
Klammer zu.
Ja.
Okay.
Hä? Das ist doch das offizielle Beispiel, was ich
von ihm kopiert habe.
Warum geht denn denn
nicht mal das offizielle Beispiel?
Das ist ja, das ist doof.
Wobei doch, das Beispiel geht, ich habe es einfach nur
kaputt, oder?
Ach. Oh, Mann.
Ich habe es nicht importiert.
Ich habe gedacht, Visual Studio
macht das Richtige, standardmäßig.
Aber ich habe es ja nicht mal
installiert, bin ich bescheuert.
Warum, warum
kann ich...
Warum kann ich denn hier nichts installieren?
Hä?
Moment.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt, Leute.
HiBeloTV.
Warum kann ich denn hier nichts
installieren?
Hallo?
Ah.
Ja.
Wer soll da auch drauf kommen, dass ich für das aktuelle
Projekt, an dem ich gerade arbeite, Sachen installieren will?
Warum ist das denn nicht
default? Egal, jetzt passt
alles gut. Install.
Ja. Fetzen.
Randy. Genauso ist es.
Visual Studio ist das beste,
es ist das beste, was es gibt.
IDE ist das beste, was es gibt.
BDO Notification
Cool, irgendwann, wenn ich mal wieder BDO spiele.
Aber das ist fertig.
So, jetzt funktioniert es wahrscheinlich auch,
was ich hier mache.
Ja, jetzt klappt das Ganze.
Okay.
Machen wir das mal ordentlich.
Dass man hier was erkennt.
Zack, zack, zack,
zack, zack.
Okay.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das mit der Message Box funktioniert.
Wir machen mal einen
simplen Shortcut.
Ctrl
L. Das ist glaube ich
noch nicht belegt. Oder zumindest nicht global.
Also, wenn ich jetzt Ctrl L drücke,
sollte eine Message Box
aufgehen. Bam, passt.
Und die sollte auch aufgehen, wenn ich nicht in dem Programm
drinnen bin.
Was nicht funktioniert. Wahrscheinlich, weil
die Taskbar irgendwie Ctrl L
gecrept hat.
Hä?
Ach, ne. Weil die schon
auf ist. Okay, passt. Funktioniert.
Also, das mit den Hotkeys klappt.
Ist schon mal schön.
Und Ctrl L für Lull
ist doch auch gut. Okay, wir machen
das jetzt hier natürlich ein bisschen moderner. Und zwar
sagen wir hier uns
wir wollen
ne
wir wollen ne
Methode aufrufen, die uns
halt unsere Meme-Bilder durchswitcht.
Also, machen wir sowas wie
Change Meme.
Irgendwie sowas. Und dazu brauchen wir natürlich
vorher
ne Liste mit Memes, die wir so
haben. So.
Das heißt, was werden
wir denn da für Dinge einfügen? Lull.
MonkaS.
Confused.
Ähm.
PogChamp.
Poggers. Also, es bringt
nichts, wenn ich so viel mache. Ich muss die ja während dem Livestream
auch starten können. Omega Lull.
So, ist jetzt erstmal egal.
Das ist nur mal ein Beispiel. So.
Ich muss
mich auch an die neue Tastatur gewöhnen.
So. IsChangedMeme.
So, der kriegt
nen Enum übergeben.
Und dann sagen wir ihm,
leg mir das mal an.
Sollte er das nicht automatisch machen?
Hallo?
Also, ich kann das jetzt von Hand anlegen,
aber ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, du kannst mir da was
anlegen, automatisch.
Ja, hier private. Oh.
Privat.
Pestidee, die es gibt.
Ja, jetzt macht euch nur drüber lustig.
Es ist
die beste Idee, die es gibt.
SyntaxError?
What?
Moment vor hab ich mich jetzt hier vertippt.
Da kommt natürlich kein Typ davor.
Ja.
Der Fett ist auf
Zack hier. Da ist Zack ich.
Der schreibt das immer fast zum gleichen Zeitpunkt,
wo ich das gucke. Im Chat hat er schon was
geschrieben. Ähm. So.
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen? Wahrscheinlich stimmt
der Typ hier vorne nicht.
Does not take arguments.
Ja gut. Der übergibt
mir höchstwahrscheinlich den Key.
Aber.
Das ist mir eigentlich egal.
So, machen wir mal hier.
L ist 0.
Key interessiert mich nicht.
Okay. Das funktioniert.
Kompiliert. Muss funktionieren.
Ist der Livestream
heute oder ist das Vorbereitung?
Ähm. Der Livestream
ist morgen 20 Uhr.
Heute basteln wir bloß ein Tool,
dass wir dann passende Bilder einblenden
können im Livestream.
Weil sowas irgendwie nicht gibt.
Ich lade es dann auch auf GitHub hoch.
Ähm. Benutzt du Visual Studio Code?
Wenn nein, warum nicht? Ja, benutze ich.
Allerdings nicht für C Sharp.
Visual Studio Code benutze ich für...
Für was benutze ich denn eigentlich?
Für Rust habe ich es mal benutzt.
An sich finde ich es gut, aber ich habe wenig Anwendungszwecke.
Ich auf der Arbeit verwende ich eigentlich hauptsächlich Vim.
Weil halt Konsole und dann Editor
in der Konsole haben ist halt sehr praktisch.
Ähm. Vor allem wenn du auf einem Server drauf bist,
dann hast du halt nicht viel GUI.
Äh. Gar keine GUI.
Visual Studio Code.
Also unter Linux für C Sharp
ist das auch praktisch. Besser als
Monodevelop. Ähm.
Für JavaScript ist es gut.
Für JavaScript und TypeScript. Dafür ist
Visual Studio richtig gut.
Okay. Von der Idee her
sollte der ganze Krempel jetzt eigentlich funktionieren.
Scheiß hier vorne. Brauchen wir nicht.
Wollen wir das nicht mal ordentlich
formatieren? Ne.
Ist ordentlich formatiert. So. Wir machen jetzt ein
Hotkey für
Ctrl L und...
Warum formatiert das nicht ordentlich?
Was ist das?
Das ist überhaupt nicht die beste Idee.
Warum formatiert das nicht ordentlich?
Habe ich irgendwo
irgendwas vergessen?
Ne. Ich habe nichts vergessen. Okay. Ähm.
So. Und dann. Wir machen jetzt mal
äh. L.
Ctrl L für Lull und Ctrl
keine Ahnung. M für MonkaS.
So. Das heißt. Ich kriege das
jetzt hier reingeschwissen. Da machen wir jetzt hier einen Switch rein.
Switch on.
Wir speichern uns das mal irgendwie.
Das speichern wir uns hier oben
in einer.
Das speichern wir uns in einer Variable.
Und zwar sowas wie
äh. Current
Meme oder sowas.
Irgendwie so.
Ja.
Ist eigentlich vollkommen wurscht mit was man da anfangen soll.
Ist egal.
So. Ähm.
So. Und dann sagen wir jetzt. Switch on.
So. Man kann ihm doch irgendwie
sagen, dass er alles hinzufügen soll.
Genau. Ähm.
Wir machen jetzt mal nur
Lull und MonkaS. Wir haben ja nicht definiert.
Okay. Das heißt
wenn
das jeweilige. Der jeweilige
Shortcut gedrückt wird. Dann
ändern wir einfach
die Datei die das Bild ans. Äh. Die Datei
ähm. Das Bild was angezeigt werden soll.
So. Das heißt
jetzt müssen wir irgendwie sagen.
Ja gut. Hier müssen wir jetzt
die Dateien angeben wo man.
Wo das Zeug liegt.
So. Das heißt hier.
This Image Source.
So. Und jetzt muss ich nachgucken.
Weil in Windows Forms war das noch total einfach.
Ja. Filename. Sonst war es Image.
Ist überhaupt kein Ding.
In WPF haben sie sich gedacht. Wir machen das ganze
super kompliziert. Und zwar muss man jetzt sagen.
New Bitmap Image.
Und das hat auch die Nix
irgendwie from file oder sowas.
Ne. Also man kann jetzt glaube ich hier nicht sagen.
Ähm.
Wir nehmen jetzt hier. Äh.
Lull.
Ich glaube zumindest nicht dass das geht.
Also wir nehmen jetzt
hier nicht sowas. Oh Mann. Ich
treffe auf der neuen Tastatur noch nicht die Tasten.
Das geht hier nämlich nicht.
Oder?
Geht das doch?
Ach. Wisst ihr wenn man das richtig
macht.
Ne. Das geht natürlich nicht.
Weil Cannot Convert String to URI. Wer hätte das
gedacht. Deswegen
muss man jetzt sowas hier draus machen.
Vielleicht geht das auch irgendwie einfacher. Weiß nicht.
So. Muss ich von Hand das sagen.
Äh. Sergeant Mixer.
Ich glaube das ist wurscht.
Ich glaube Windows Dateinamen sind nicht case
sensitive. Also ich glaube
dass
Monka S PNG
das gleiche ist wie
Monka S
PNG.
Was hast du für eine Tastatur?
Ich habe gerade die hier.
Am Start.
So. Okay.
Ist das jetzt von der Idee her richtig was ich gemacht habe.
Wenn Lull gedrückt wird. Also Steuerung L.
Dann wollen wir Image Source auf
Total Blizzkit setzen.
Wenn
Control M
für Monka S gedrückt wird. Dann
wollen wir es auf
Monka S setzen.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ob ich das richtig gemacht habe.
M L. Bäm. Funktioniert.
So.
Wunderbar. Also
im Prinzip ist das ja eigentlich fast alles was
wir wollen. Wir wollen im Stream
quasi sagen können. Bild einblenden.
Irgendein doofes Meme anzeigen.
Das Umschalten wieder ausblenden können.
Das wieder ausblenden können müssen wir jetzt noch machen.
Und das wars dann im Prinzip schon.
Also wie gesagt. So mit den. Wir haben dann 150
Zeilen oder so. Das reicht.
Und wir müssen halt
noch Bilder herunterladen und
das alles einfügen.
Oh. Resident Sleeper. Den brauche ich auf jeden Fall noch.
Aber ihr
seht schon. Man kann gar nicht so viel
nehmen. Und ihr seht auch. Ich mache es
überhaupt nicht konfigurierbar. Ne.
Das kann auch keine Gif Emotes. Leider nicht.
Haben wir am Anfang ausprobiert.
Ihr seht auch. Ich mache es ja null konfigurierbar. Also es gibt
keinen Dialog oder keine Config Datei wo man das
irgendwie ändern könnte oder so. Das ist rein
gerade noch für mich
zum Zeug
anzeigen im Stream.
Aber man sieht ja schon. Je nachdem wieviel ich
hier einfüge. Mir gehen halt irgendwann die Shortcuts aus
die ich mir merken kann. Also ich kann mir vielleicht 7, 8
Shortcuts merken wenn sie einleuchten sind.
So wie Strg L für 0. Aber dann
hört es auf. Oder ich mache es auf die Makro
Tasten. Dann müsste ich mir irgendwie die
Makro Tasten merken. Da habe ich aber auch plus 6
Stück.
Gif Emotes gucken wir dann mal ob wir das hinkriegen.
Ansonsten hätten wir 0 3D gemacht.
Hahaha.
Okay. Ähm. Das können wir mal in eine
Zeile machen.
Oder so.
Eigentlich ist es egal wie. Gibt es in Visual Studio
sowas das man Zeilen zusammen
führen kann und quasi
alle Widespaces dazwischen löscht?
Gibt es da irgendwie einen Shortcut für?
Oh den brauchen
wir natürlich auch noch.
Den brauchen wir auch noch. Da müssen wir doch noch irgendwie gucken wie
wir animierte Gifs hinkriegen.
Ähm. Melolix
fragt. Eine sehr dumme Frage. Kannst du
nicht einfach eine Szene von OBS erstellen?
Mit den jeweiligen Memes. Ist das denn nicht
dasselbe? Denke ich mal.
Ne es ist nicht dasselbe. Das kann ich machen. Du kannst im OBS
ja sogar Shortcuts irgendwo. Irgendwo kann man
Shortcuts definieren. Für Anzeigen
von Elementen. Also das würde prinzipiell
genau das machen was man will.
Aber dann sehe ich es nicht.
So und jetzt überlegt euch mal. Ich
blende jetzt hier. Keine Ahnung. Ich hätte
Shortcuts im OBS. Und ich blende jetzt einfach mal 0
ein. Und ich sehe das
nicht. Und ich vergesse es wieder auszublenden.
Dann habt ihr eine halbe Stunde 0.
Hahaha. Am Start. Wisst ihr?
Und ich sehe es halt nicht.
Oh ja klar. Ich kann mir
einen zweiten Monitor hinstellen. Habe ich ja hier
am zweiten Bildschirm. Wo ich es dann sehe.
Aber ich will ja eigentlich Livestream gucken.
Zwischen ein paar sinnlosen Memes einblenden und dann
wieder das zu machen.
Und es ist halt auch nicht schwierig. Es ist ja mehr oder weniger schon
fast fertig der ganze Kram hier.
Wir müssen jetzt ein paar Memes runterladen. Reinhauen.
Ich muss jetzt noch. Jetzt müssen wir noch programmieren dass das
Ähm.
Dass ich es wieder ausblenden kann.
Das war es. So. Wir setzen
hier unten jetzt nochmal.
Current Meme setzen wir auf.
Das was hier übergeben wurde.
Ähm. Ich muss da noch sowas wie
Minimieren oder so reinmachen. Dass ich
es wieder ausblenden kann. Ok. Gucken wir mal.
Ähm.
Machen wir das ganze Ding jetzt mal fertig.
Also ich brauche hier sowas wie
Ähm. Also ich
will.
Wie mache ich denn das jetzt am besten?
Wie blende ich denn das ganze wieder aus?
Ich würde sagen indem ich einfach das Meme
was angezeigt wird.
Nochmal den Shortcut drücke.
Dann blende das aus.
Und wenn nicht würde ich einfach so
Toggle halt.
Einmal drücken einblenden.
Zweites mal drücken ausblenden.
Kannst du den Stream nicht durch
dein OBS Fenster gucken? Doch das würde funktionieren.
Aber das ist mir zu
zu Noob Style.
Das will ich nicht.
Außerdem ist es doch mal ein guter Anlass mal wieder
Programmierstream zu machen oder?
So. Ähm.
Das heißt ich muss jetzt erstmal gucken.
Ist oder?
Okay. Also wir gucken jetzt mal.
Ist das Fenster
maximiert?
Wenn das
Fenster maximiert ist.
Habe ich das jetzt falsch gerade?
Ah ja es ist Windows State.
Warum haben die das auch so
gleich gerade? Windows State.
Wenn es maximiert ist.
Und.
Das Current Meme
gleich dem ist.
Wenn ich einen Shortcut für gedrückt habe.
Dann
will ich es ausblenden.
Dann sagen wir mal Windows State gleich
Minimized.
Gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert
jetzt schon mal.
Ne das lassen wir erstmal weg.
Weil das funktioniert erstmal so nicht.
Das funktioniert. Okay das Minimieren klappt.
Schon mal gut.
Ne. Ne. Ne Nilsa.
Ne. Ne. Ne.
Einen eigenen Lull Effekt kann ich in WPF nicht
bauen.
So ohne weiteres.
Okay es minimiert das ganze.
So das heißt wenn das dann
minimiert ist dann ist gut.
Dann wollen wir aufhören.
Dann machen wir nichts.
Wenn der State
quasi nicht maximized
ist. Dann
switchen
wir zum jeweilig gedrückten Meme
und
blenden
das ganze ein.
Das müsste
das müsste eigentlich
das müsste es eigentlich schon sein.
Gucken.
Ja funktioniert.
Und das ist eigentlich alles was ich haben will.
Das ist alles was ich haben will.
Mehr will ich nicht haben.
Wenn ich rechts klicke wird
wird
im Kreis gelullt.
Oder aber im Kreis gemonkaest.
Das ist alles. Mehr will ich nicht haben.
Wir sind mehr oder weniger schon fertig.
Ne MrFryguy das geht nicht.
Der kann auch keine Gifs.
Und ich weiß auch nicht ob ich ihm noch beibringe Gifs anzuzeigen.
Also jetzt müssen wir im Prinzip
nur noch Memes runterladen.
Und unter dem richtigen Namen
speichern und es funktioniert.
Hab ich
irgendwas vergessen?
Wir könnten das drehen.
Wir könnten das drehen auch stoppen.
Ja das machen wir. Wir stoppen das drehen.
Wir stoppen das drehen.
Ja.
Wir stoppen das drehen immer beim Memeswitch.
Also das heißt
wenn ich jetzt
lull anfange
zu drehen und switch dann auf monkaest
dann hat es dann aufzudrehen. Ja das ist ganz praktisch.
Sonst habe ich einmal drehen an und dann
ja ja so ist besser.
Magst du die Memes wirklich so riesig drüber ballen?
Ja ja ich habe mir das so gedacht. Im Prinzip
wir gucken uns den Stream an
So.
Wir gucken uns den Stream an
und wenn dann was lustiges passiert mache ich halt irgendwie so.
Dann mache ich wieder aus.
Wisst ihr das ist nicht so das ich den die ganze Zeit anlasse.
Wenn er jetzt
irgendwie
Wenn er erzählt das sie so sorry sind
wegen Battlefront 2 oder
das sie die besten Fans haben und
immer auf ihre Fans hören und die most dedicated
Fanbase und sowas. Dann mache ich halt
So
fertig weiter gehts. Irgendwie sowas.
Und
mehr solls ja auch nicht machen.
Omega 0 geht noch nicht.
Das können wir aber jetzt machen.
Dann müssen wir aber erstmal ein transparentes
Bild befinden.
Ist nicht transparent.
Transparent.
Das ist
Es gibt kein
Omega 0.
Es gibt kein transparentes Omega 0.
Und jetzt?
Was mache ich jetzt?
Leute ich brauche ein transparentes Omega 0.
Frei
Ne
Wobei
Ich kann
Ich habe keinen Bock jetzt.
Bildbearbeitungskram
zu machen.
Muss der Omega 0 auch geben als schon
freigestelltes Bild.
Kann doch nicht sein.
Gucken wir mal.
Ne wie ging
Ich glaube hier gab es die Emotes
in besserer Quali.
Schauen wir mal.
Ja
Komm laden wir es von hier runter.
Ich meine das ist zwar nicht schön.
Ist das überhaupt durchsichtig?
Ja müsste.
Na hoffentlich ist das durchsichtig.
Ne ist nicht durchsichtig.
Ja dann können wir das auch nicht verwenden.
Das ist die Durchsicht.
Ja wenn es
nicht transparent ist, ist es doof.
Ah nice nice.
Wisst ihr hat schon einen Link geschickt.
Das brauchen wir.
Omega 0
Gibt es das nicht auch nochmal 4?
So und das ist transparent.
Sehr schön.
Das ist auch ein PNG.
Dann bauen wir das noch schnell ein.
Das heißt.
Ich muss jetzt gucken, dass ich
keine Shortcuts verwende
die ich halt so brauche.
Also machen wir hier mal Shortcuts
O. Ich muss bisher irgendwie
merken können den Kram.
Also Ctrl O wird jetzt
Omega 0.
Das heißt wir machen hier Case
Memes
Omega 0.
Und dann kopieren wir den Krempel.
Warum hat Visual Studio
eigentlich noch keine Dateifahrt
Autovervollständigung?
Ah ja.
Break.
Funktioniert. Das Bild ist aber ein bisschen
schlecht aufgelöst.
Im Vergleich zu
Naja.
Kriegen wir das nicht noch ein bisschen höher aufgelöst?
Meme Tool.
Was soll das sein?
Kannst du auf Shortcuts Meme Bilder einblenden.
Transparent.
Und du kannst sie drehen.
Wobei das eher ein sinnloses Gimmick ist.
Egal. Reicht.
Ich weiß nicht. Das sieht schon scheiße aus.
Von der Quali her.
Brauchen wir denn
Frage an euch.
Brauchen wir denn 0 und Omega 0?
Braucht man das?
Ist das notwendig, dass man beides braucht?
Ja. Na gut.
Das war klar.
Klar.
Ups.
Leute. Beispiele.
Dass ich das morgen im Stream checke.
Wann verwende ich 0?
Und wann verwende ich dann
Omega 0?
Denkt mal an EA Pressekonferenz
und denkt euch mal ein Beispiel aus.
Wann nehme ich 0? Wann nehme ich Omega 0?
Am besten auch noch 0.
0 ist eh größer 0.
Da gibt es nichts zu meckern.
Die Tastatur. Ich drücke immer die falschen
Knöpfe.
Es funktioniert.
Wenn ich den Stream zweimal hintereinander drücke,
blendet das wieder aus.
So soll das sein.
Epileptische Anfälle.
Epilepsie-Warnung. Achtung.
Ist instant Omega 0?
Ist Kappa am Start?
Ob man Kappa braucht bei der
EA Pressekonferenz oder bei Streams
weiß ich nicht.
Da weiß ich so den Anlass nicht
so richtig dazu.
Also wen wir auf jeden Fall
natürlich noch brauchen ist
erst noch mal ein ordentliches Bild
hier von
ihm hier.
Confused.
Wir wollen kein GIF.
Wir wollen Transparent.
Okay, das ist Transparent, aber ein bisschen klein,
oder?
Das sieht kacke aus.
Das ist aber schon mal besser.
Das ist schon mal besser als das andere.
Okay, wir benennen es erst mal um.
So, dann fügen wir
das Ganze ein.
Äh.
Confused mache ich Steuerung, weiß nicht, Steuerung W
oder so für WTF.
Ich muss das ja merken können.
So.
Die Auflösung ist mega schlecht, ey.
Stimmt, Steuerung W
macht das Tab zu. Ne, das kann ich nicht mehr machen.
Wenn ich da Mist drücke.
Wobei das Schöne ist, ich habe ja globale
Hotkeys. Das heißt, solange das Programm läuft
kriegt mein
Browser die
Hotkeys ja gar nicht. Das heißt, ich kann auch nichts
Falsches drücken.
Aber genau dafür ist es da. Mehr soll das Ganze
überhaupt nicht machen. Das funktioniert schon
wunderbar. Ich will einfach auf
Knopfdruck
einblenden können hier. Und auf Knopfdruck wieder
ausblenden. Das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier
L, M, W,
O
und mit O wieder ausblenden.
Oder mit W wieder ausblenden.
Das klappt doch gut.
Ich brauch das Ganze aber in ein bisschen bessere Auflösung.
Eben hat jemand geschrieben, man kann mir hier das Omega-Lull
in bessere Auflösung schicken.
Ah, hier. Omega-Lull
höhere Auflösung. Nice. Sehr schön.
Sehr schön. Dann kriegen wir jetzt erstmal hier
ein ordentliches Omega-Lull.
Das ist auch transparent.
Warum speichert
der Browser das jetzt komplett woanders?
Ne. Das ist aber nicht
transparent.
Das ist nicht transparent.
Ich brauch das transparent.
Ich brauch das transparent. Sonst
klappt das ja nicht.
Hab ich nicht gesagt, always on top
bei dem Programm?
Hab ich nicht gesagt? Das soll immer
topmost sein? Ach, was auch immer.
Ah, gut.
Da machen wir hier noch nen
Activate oder irgendwie sowas drunter,
dass da auch auf jeden Fall
auf jeden Fall im Vordergrund ist.
Ja, Patrick, dafür hab ich den
extra Streaming-Account. Da kann ich auch
nix leaken.
Omega-Lull transparent.
Perfekt.
Gucken wir, ob's geht.
Ja, so ist das viel besser.
So ist das doch viel besser.
Ja, aber Lull und Omega-Lull, das Schöne ist,
dass L und O auch so direkt
beieinander liegen.
Ne, ist nicht die gleiche Quali.
Das Rot ist nicht so verpixelt.
Okay, Resident Sleeper
brauchen wir aber auf jeden Fall.
Oder irgendwie ein Sleeper
Meme
da.
Weil das ist bei EA
wird das ganz, ganz akut Resident Sleeper
werden. Ich glaub den brauchen wir
bei EA nicht. Ihn brauchen wir auf jeden Fall
noch. Und wenn MonkaS
nicht reicht, brauchen wir noch
ne zweite Variante von.
Ne, brauchen wir
nicht. Ich muss mir die Shortcuts
ja merken können. Aber wann ich
streame? Ja, ab morgen Abend.
Ab 20 Uhr oder? Ja, kurz vor 20 Uhr.
Soll ich hier den Confused
ausschneiden? Ja, das wär
nicht schlecht. Also wenn ich den, wenn
wir den Confused noch
in bisschen höhere Auflösung
kriegen, hätte das schon seinen Charme.
Wenn du das mit den GIFs...
Ja, mit den GIFs, ich weiß nicht.
Gucken wir mal, wie das geht.
Ich brauch aber erstmal hier nochmal hier unseren
Resident Sleeper in Transparent.
Und
einen davon brauchen wir eigentlich auch noch.
Ich überleg mir morgen
noch, was ich noch genau für Memes nehme.
Ja, ob ich die...
Yoshi, ob ich die noch reinnehme,
muss ich mal gucken, weil...
Also das eine finde ich richtig passend.
Weku Chat
Weku Command
Brew
Okay, ich wollte ja mal gucken
WPF GIF
Was gibt's denn da für Sachen?
WPF Animated GIF im Einsatz
Okay.
Library
Simple Library Display Animated GIFs
Also falls, falls wir das hinkriegen
mit Animated GIFs,
dann brauchen wir
auf jeden Fall
noch Lull 3D.
Und dann muss, und entweder
muss dann Lull oder Omega Lull
raus, weil 3x Lull brauchen wir auch nicht.
So, wie funktioniert denn der Kram hier?
Simple Library Display Animated
GIF...
Wisst ihr Leute,
ich bin ja Fan von GIF.
Aber es gibt ja welche, die müssen das
alles so richtig geil ausspringen,
sondern GIF.
So Java und GIF.
Und JIT.
Da krieg ich immer
Ausschläge von.
Animated GIF.
Also ich finde, das klingt
jetzt nicht schwierig.
Das klingt nicht schwierig zu verwenden.
Mal gucken, ob es das hier bei Nougat gibt.
Paketmanager
Wie heißt
der Krempel?
WPF Animated
GIF
Das versuchen wir noch einzubauen.
WPF
Animated GIFs
GIF
Hahaha
Woodface. Ja.
Der muss eigentlich auch noch rein.
Das wird ein bisschen viel irgendwie.
Das wird langsam
ein bisschen viel, ey.
Weil ihr einen...
Ne, den brauchen wir eigentlich auch noch.
Gucken wir mal. Ich muss mir da morgen nochmal in Ruhe Gedanken drüber machen,
was ich jetzt genau für Memes reinnehme.
WPF Animated
GIF.
Das ist richtig,
Wambo. Aber
nachdem...
Mit Big Brain ist ja bei mir nix mehr.
Bin ja zu alt schon.
Ich kann mir keine 15 Shortcuts merken
und die dann in der Sekunde auch das richtige drücken.
Doch, ich kann
das, wenn ihr wollt.
Also wenn ihr wollt, kann ich das Tool bei GitHub hochladen.
Da kann es jeder verwenden.
Aber es hat halt
null Optionen.
Also es gibt keine Config-Datei
oder irgendwas.
Das heißt, wenn man das anpassen will,
sogar den Pfad, wo das Bild liegt,
dann muss man erstmal Source Code editieren
und kompilieren. Dann kann man es verwenden.
RaceOW
Ja, quasi.
Quasi IronAids
kopieren.
WPF Animated GIF.
Hauptsache geil ausgesprochen.
So, also
wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Einfach
so hier.
Okay.
Probieren wir. Machen wir.
Case
Memes. Was haben wir denn hier?
Lull3D brauchen wir da noch.
Lull3D
Case
Dann, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken,
wie wir das hier einbauen.
Laden wir dem jetzt einfach mal den Beispiel-Code
von dem Typ.
Lull3D
ImageBehaviour
Einbinden
Was ist Image in dem Fall?
Wahrscheinlich das WPF Element.
Ne.
Was ist Image in dem Fall?
Also
Image müsste in dem Fall auch einfach
Übrigens
das muss ich umbenennen.
Das kann ich nicht Image nennen, weil das andere schon Image heißt.
Dann heißt es halt Image.
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Reicht es nicht,
wenn du den Pfad vom Bild änderst in der Source?
Ne, weil für GIF muss ich das ja
durch die Library hier jagen, dass die das macht.
Deswegen muss ich da sonst
Bei den oberen siehst du ja, bei den oberen ändere ich
ja einfach nur den Pfad zur Datei.
MeloLeaks meint
ich soll mein NumPad benutzen für die Hotkeys.
Das finde ich ist eine gute Idee.
Problem ist dann, dann kann ich mir nicht merken
was 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 genau ist.
Und wenn ich erst auf den Zettel gucken muss,
dann ist ja der Witz schon wieder vorbei.
Achso.
Ja, Flogstix, klar, das reicht.
Also wenn man Visual Studio hat
ist kein Ding, kannst du machen.
Kannst du einfach Pfad ändern
und kannst verwenden.
Vielleicht erweitern wir das auch noch.
Ich habe eigentlich die ganze Zeit über 150
oder um die 150 Zuschauer.
Ich habe nie so viele Zuschauer.
Den besten Witz der Woche
Den besten Witz der Woche habe ich heute gesehen
und hat mir der DB Navigator auf Twitter
äh nicht auf Twitter
auf mein Handy geschickt, dass er Zugverspätung hat
ohne
mir anzuzeigen was.
Das war komplett ein Software Fail wieder von der Bahn.
Ich habe das Bild leider nur
auf dem Handy drauf.
Aber die haben es voll verkackt.
Achso, ja und dann der
größte Witz war die Apple Pressekonferenz.
Der Typ hat gesagt,
die sind ja voll aufgedreht dabei.
Was hat er erzählt?
Deep Technology Accelerated Workflow
Da kann irgendwie schon
so richtig so Rap-Gott-mäßig
kann da schon mal einer was drauf machen.
Deep Accelerated Workflow
Also da kannst du voll was drauf machen.
Da müsste man vielleicht mal Haftbefehle geben.
Dass er dann da irgendwie
was draus bastelt.
So die
Aslak-Version
So, was wollte ich denn jetzt eigentlich machen?
Achja, ich wollte gucken, ob das
Jif funktioniert.
Und zwar
brauchen wir da einen neuen
Hotkey für.
Wir brauchen mal den W-Hotkey.
Das war für 0.3D. Mal gucken, ob das jetzt
Ich wäre überrascht, wenn es einfach so funktioniert.
Nein.
Das kackt ab.
Äh, Except. Ich sehe meine
Exception nicht.
Was habe ich für eine Exception?
File
File not found?
Warum
Achso, weil es kein PNG ist, sondern ein Jif.
Habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
Bam!
In your face, Dult!
Funktioniert instant!
Das ist mal eine gute Library.
Beispielcode, Ding
installiert, copy-pasted
Funktioniert.
Poggers!
Oh, ich kann es nicht mehr ausschalten.
Ja, weil
das muss ich noch einbauen.
Ich kann das Bild nicht mehr switchen,
nachdem ich es einmal aktiviert habe.
Aber es funktioniert.
Das heißt, ich muss
das dann wieder rausschmeißen.
Wie lösche ich denn das jetzt wieder?
Habt ihr da irgendeine Idee?
Also hier setze ich jetzt ja
quasi als
das Bild hier
für meine Imagebox.
Und hier setze ich es auch,
aber hier setze ich es nicht über Source.
Wie kann ich das denn jetzt wieder löschen?
Wie mache ich das jetzt wieder weg?
Kann ich, kann ich irgendwie
sagen, Image behelfe, irgendwie
so remove oder so?
Hallo Cheesy
Pro36, wie mache ich das
wieder weg? Einfach
0, ne, das funktioniert nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich das wieder weg,
wie mache ich das wieder weg?
Animated Jif.
Auskennen Fuchs, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das, das, das probieren wir mal.
Wir machen das jetzt, wir machen das
einfach, das glaube ich aber nicht, dass das so funktioniert.
Ah, gucken wir mal.
Wir machen das jetzt einfach mal hier drunter, dann sollte er
dir einfach kein Bild mehr anzeigen.
Hmm.
Das könnte tatsächlich funktionieren.
Ah, Quatsch, Confused
geht ja nicht, äh.
Funktioniert! Krass, der Auskennen Fuchs,
der kennt sich echt aus. Der weiß,
der weiß Bescheid.
Einfach nullen. Das ist, das ist
absolut C Sharp untypisch, dass man
irgendwas nullen muss dafür, dass es wieder,
das muss man nirgendswo sonst
machen. Das ist voll gegen den,
so den Geister der, der
Sprache irgendwie, dass man dann Dinger nullen muss,
die dann Magic dazu führen, dass andere
Dinger wieder funktionieren.
Das ist total
bescheuert. Aber
ich bin froh, dass es funktioniert.
Deep
Technology Accelerated Workflow
war das. Ist Visual Studio
for free? Ja, die Community Edition,
das was ich hier verwende, ist komplett for free.
Ich würde sagen, wir sind fertig.
Was passiert
denn eigentlich, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren, da
crasht es bestimmt oder irgendwas. Was passiert denn
eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt sage, er soll es drehen?
Fuck!
Mind blown!
Expanding brain!
Jetzt ist vorbei!
Das ist,
ich hab ja eingebaut, dass wenn man rechts
klickt, dass er das Bild dreht.
Und das in Kombination mit dem ist halt
schon geil.
Das ist Lull 4D!
Hyper Lull 3D ist das.
Das wäre fast
ein eigenes Channel Emote wert, oder?
Lull 4D.
Vor allem, da wird es dir echt schlecht bei, ne?
Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor, man
macht das doch irgendwie...
Das sah jetzt komplett aus.
Hyper Lull gibt es schon.
Und ich muss sagen, für die ganzen Followers,
da muss man nachgucken. Wer ist denn jetzt alles am Start?
Ähm...
Ich würde sagen, programmiertechnisch macht
es genau das, was ich haben will. Ich lade mir morgen
noch ein paar Memes runter und dann überlege
ich mir ein paar Shortcuts, dann funktioniert das schon.
Gibt es noch irgendeine Funktion, die man da unbedingt
einbauen muss?
Habt ihr noch irgendeine Idee?
Ich meine, ich bin auch noch ein bisschen wach.
Ist kein Ding.
Können wir noch irgendwas basteln?
Wir müssen uns auch noch Bullshit Bingo
für EA ausdenken.
Okay, Follows. Jede Menge Follows.
Wen dürfen wir
dann im Stream begrüßen?
Das finde ich doof. Irgendwie sieht man immer nur
die letzten 10, 15 Follows hier.
Also, wir dürfen neu im Stream
begrüßen den Mr.
Harrobo1.
Den Mr. Harrobo1.
Warum steht er zweimal drinne?
Weil er mich gehostet hat mit einem Viewer.
Scheiße.
PogChamp.
Poggers.
2 Alpha Zero
Lucatin
Urinschorle
Da, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich,
dass es
2 Kotz-Emojis gibt,
mittlerweile.
Ist euch das bewusst?
Es gibt den Emoji vorm Kotzen
und den Emoji beim Kotzen.
Deswegen habe ich eigentlich darauf gehofft,
dass es mit dem neuen Unicode-Standard
noch was dazwischen gibt.
Ja, ich meine, es gibt Smiley quasi
Also vorm Kotzen und Smiley beim Kotzen.
Man könnte dann auch machen, Emoji nach dem Kotzen oder so.
Der ist dann blau und liegt drinnen oder sowas.
Aber nein, haben sie nicht gemacht.
Beatport, mega geil wäre eine Settings-Page.
Also ich werde garantiert keine UI-Konfiguration hier irgendwie für basteln.
Aber was man vielleicht machen könnte ist, dass man eine Config-Datei angibt.
Dass man eine Config-Datei angibt, was es für Bilder gibt.
Und dass er einfach die Dateinamen dann quasi nimmt.
Oder dass man in der Config-Datei quasi Shortcut plus Dateinamen angibt oder sowas.
Hat Max eigentlich einen Discord-Server? Ja, aber ich habe den immer noch nicht öffentlich gemacht.
Was, du kannst mit Windows-Taste plus Punkt eine Emoji übersammeln? Wusste ich nicht.
Geht nicht.
Fake News.
Ja, Beatport, die gehen gerade alle ab.
Aber ich habe GitLab auf der Arbeit.
Drei Jahre oder so hatten wir eine GitLab-Installation.
Es war in Ordnung.
Aber so wahnsinnig, dass ich jetzt sagen würde, ich muss das da unbedingt.
Also GitHub ist mir als Plattform viel lieber als GitLab.
Einfach weil, das ist halt wie bei vielen Sachen.
So, hey, eine I.
Es sind alle bei GitLab.
Das heißt, du hast die meisten Projekte bei GitLab, die meisten Contributors, die meisten Leute, die sich das angucken.
Schrottler, das habe ich noch nicht weitergebastelt, das Feature-Tool.
Ne, also bei mir geht Windows-Taste und Punkt geht bei mir nicht.
Ich schwöre, Alter, geht nicht.
Ehrenmann, geht nicht.
Vielleicht geht es nur in Visual Studio nicht.
Guck mal in Firefox, vielleicht geht es da.
Ne, geht auch nicht.
Geht nicht.
Vielleicht kann man sich hier eine Emoji-Übersicht.
Geht natürlich auch nicht.
Das wäre ja auch mal was, dass man im Startmenü was findet, was man sucht.
RGB-Integration.
Die Idee ist gar nicht schlecht.
Ich habe mir schon überlegt, ob ich nicht, dass ich mir besser merken kann.
RGB auf der Tastatur einstelle, quasi in der Farbe der Memes.
Also, dass ich dann sagen würde, okay, den Shortcut für MonkaS mache ich grün.
Den für Omega-Lull mache ich rot.
So in der Richtung, dass ich es einfacher finde.
Und ich habe es auf Englisch.
Ist alles auf Englisch.
Mein Windows ist auf Englisch.
Und ich habe, also, Windows-Version habe ich auf dem Rechner das vor dem Redstone-Update.
Weil er das irgendwie auf diesem lustigerweise, also ich habe alle Sicherheits-Updates und sonst was.
Auf diesem wollte er es noch nicht machen, aber auf dem anderen hat er es schon gemacht.
Im Startmenü steht überhaupt nichts auf Deutsch.
Create, Play, Explore.
Dass er das hier auf Deutsch schreibt.
Da sieht man halt mal, was das für eine komische Mischung ist, die Microsoft da zusammengefuddelt hat.
Ich probiere jetzt mal auf meinem zweiten Rechner Windows Punkt.
Funktioniert auch nicht.
Muss man dafür Cortana anhaben oder irgendwas?
Weil ich habe alles ausgestellt, was es so gibt.
Ach, das Emoji-Menü ist eine Funktion von 1803?
Ja, so eine advancede Funktion kann man natürlich auch selbstverständlich.
Nee, das ist klar.
Es hätte mir, sorry Leute, es hätte mir klar...
Klar sein müssen, dass ein Emoji-Menü auf Shortcut natürlich nur unter dem aktuellsten, brandneuesten Windows-Update funktioniert.
Ist klar.
So was, so was, so eine Bleeding Edge-Technologie kann man einfach nicht vorher machen.
Jo, wann geht der E3-Stream los?
Morgen 20 Uhr.
Ja, ich scroll jetzt nochmal kurz durch, weil ich irgendwie, habe ich was überlesen?
Oh, Confused 800x800.
Ja, das ist nice, das ist nice.
Oh, das ist sehr nice, der gefällt mir.
Das gefällt mir, wartet mal kurz, gleich bin ich am Start.
Ja, der ist gut, den müssen wir noch einbauen.
Den müssen wir noch einbauen.
Confused.
Sehr schön.
Und Confused braucht noch einen...
Gibt es einfach auch nur drei als Key?
Da machen wir nämlich Confused, wird dann wieder W.
Jawoll, der ist, das ist doch viel besser von der Auflösung her.
Ah, das ist schön freigestellt.
Damit kann man was anfangen.
Wenigstens mal eine ordentliche Auflösung.
Ich habe, ich habe von dem, nirgendswo eine ordentliche Auflösung gefunden.
Und wir, das einzige, was wir jetzt noch brauchen, ist ein bisschen hochauflösenderen, transparenten Resident Sleeper.
Dann haben wir alles.
Eine Umfrage, welche Memes noch reingehören.
Naja, wie gesagt, ich bin, also die Anzahl reicht.
Das, das ist schon viel zu viel.
Das kann ich mir nicht alles merken.
Ach, das funktioniert nur auf dem englischen Tasten-Dayout.
Ernsthaft jetzt?
Ne.
Funktioniert auch nicht.
Ach ne, das ist German Keyboard.
Was ist das für eine komische...
Warum habe ich diese Option überhaupt?
Wie stelle ich jetzt, wie stelle...
Diese neuen Windows-Optionen, wo stelle ich denn jetzt hier Keyboard, Keyboard, äh...
Ich, Leute, da seht ihr mal, so weit ist es schon.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man das Tastatur-Layout umstellt.
Ich weiß es schlicht nicht.
Nicht unergreifend nett.
Wie sich Max permanent unterschwellig über Windows aufregt.
Ich reg mich ja nicht mal unterschwellig über Windows auf.
Ne, der Resident Sleeper sieht ziemlich kaputt aus.
Den können wir nicht nehmen.
Wissen Sie, ich hätte es ja mal für Keyboard-Layout sucht oder so.
Dann findet man was, aber ne.
Nach Layout gibt es auch nicht.
Wie?
Okay, das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Wie stellt man unter Windows das Tastatur-Layout um?
Type Settings.
Nein.
Okay.
Also, ich muss mal kurz in mich gehen.
Also, ich bin jemand, der absolut keine Ahnung vom Computer hat.
So, absolut null.
Ich bin in der Lage, das Setting-Menü aufzumachen.
Und jetzt will ich mein Tastatur-Layout umstellen.
Time and Language würde ich dann wahrscheinlich gehen.
Oder Devices.
Devices.
Gucken wir erstmal Devices.
Typing.
Da würde ich wahrscheinlich als erstes gucken.
Und wir hoffen, so ist es falsch.
Okay.
Danach würde ich gucken, Time and Language.
Region and Language.
Wo kann man das Tastatur-Layout umstellen?
Was haben die, was denkt man sich denn bei so einem...
Was, auf Sprache klicken?
Ernsthaft?
Nee, Speech Language.
Nee, nee.
Wieso benutzt du auch Windows 10?
Das ist einfach.
Weil das ist das einzige Betriebssystem, wo Spiele ordentlich drauf laufen.
Für alles andere.
Ernsthaft?
Da habe ich im Zweifelsfall meine Linux Pro M.
Add Language.
Aber ich muss doch Language nicht adden.
Ich habe doch schon Englisch.
Und ich will auch kein Language Pack.
Ich will einfach nur...
Einfach nur das Keyboard-Layout umstellen.
Das ist die alte Systemsteuerung.
Da geht das aber auch nicht mehr.
Add a Keyboard.
Also, nachdem ich schon mal die quasi weltweit führende Sprache ENDE habe,
also quasi, was auch immer das sein soll,
Englisch, Deutsch,
habe ich keine Keyboards da drin.
Okay, dann...
Ändern wir mal ein Keyboard.
Ah!
Und dann wollte ich schon immer mal Englisch India haben,
weil Englisch anders da gibt es nicht.
Auch gut.
Englisch India.
Ja.
Okay.
Englisch India.
Die Emoji-Menü geht immer noch nicht.
Okay.
Ach, Remove geht auch nicht.
Microsoft, was ist das denn?
Und warum gibt es hier kein Englisch-Englisch?
Na gut, das ist mein...
Das verstehe ich.
Das braucht ein Microsoft-Support-Mitarbeiter.
Das geht nicht anders.
Tastenkombination in einem Textfeld ausführen.
Okay.
Also hier oben drin.
Ah!
Ja, das muss man...
Das muss natürlich auch einer dabei sagen,
dass das nur in einem Textfeld...
Das sind solche Sachen.
Mittlerweile muss ich sagen,
Windows hat sich ja wirklich gemacht.
Das kannst du ja nicht mal mit dem Schund von früher vergleichen.
Aber Microsoft hat einfach von Oberflächendesign
absolut keine Ahnung.
Und nicht nur keine Ahnung,
sie ändern auch keine Ahnung.
Laufend.
Sodass du heute unter Windows
aus vier bis fünf Gelenken,
fünf Generationen,
die jeweils damals gängige
Microsoft-UI-Philosophie hast.
Also sprich, du hast fünf Generationen,
keine Ahnung,
aber immer wieder anders keine Ahnung.
Und dann hast du solche Mischungen
wie dieses Menü hier,
die alte Systemsteuerung,
ganz alte Dialoge
wie den Geräte-Manager und sowas.
Was ist das denn?
Ja, gut.
Und was mache ich jetzt mit den Emojis
im Suche-Fenster?
Es passiert doch nicht mal was,
wenn man die anklickt.
Moment, man darf die nicht anklicken.
Hä?
Hä? Okay, fuck, fuck.
Wer hat denn deiner Meinung nach Ahnung
von Oberflächendesign?
Tja, also
ich würde sagen Twitter.
Twitter auf jeden Fall.
Amazon?
Also von irgendwelchen Deluxe-Sachen
kann ich jetzt nicht wirklich anfangen,
weil die meisten Sachen, die ich verwende,
kann man nicht so wirklich als Oberfläche,
also ich meine Terminal mit Zeug drinnen,
das ist jetzt nicht so das,
was sich die meisten Leute
an grafischer Oberfläche vorstellen.
Oder E3 als Window-Manager
hat ja auch nicht wirklich viel Oberfläche.
Also Twitter und Amazon
würde ich auf jeden Fall sagen.
Amazon allein schon rein
ja quasi praktisch orientiert.
Die müssen,
wenn die Oberfläche auf Amazon scheiße wäre,
würde die Leute nichts kaufen
und nichts finden.
Amazon gibt sich enorm viel Mühe,
dass die Leute beim Bestellvorgang,
ja in den,
in den Settings,
wenn es dann darum geht,
dass man sich irgendwie seine History anzeigen lassen kann
oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen,
wird es auch bei Amazon übelst wirr.
Also die normale Amazon-Shop-Oberfläche,
da haben die so viel
Gehirngeschwalz reingesteckt,
dass da auch keiner auf die Idee kommt,
den Bestellvorgang abzubrechen.
Das merkst du.
Wie findest du Steams Oberflächendesign?
Ja, finde ich gut.
Steam finde ich nicht schlecht.
Steam ist okay.
Man merkt,
man merkt Steam an,
dass es ein bisschen älter ist
und man merkt Steam an,
dass es eigentlich auch nur ein Browser ist.
Das alles hier ist ein Browser.
Alles.
Es ist ein Chrome im Endeffekt.
Aber ich finde es nicht schlecht.
Das Ingame-Overlay ist auch ein Chrome.
Das Einzige, was halt kein Chrome ist,
ist wahrscheinlich FPS-Anzeigen und sowas.
Ich finde es nicht schlecht.
Ich finde es nicht schlecht,
das ist nicht schlecht.
Also, wenn man sich bei Steam dran gewöhnt hat,
was ich bei Steam gut finde,
ist, dass es relativ einheitlich ist.
Zumindest für die Standardsachen.
Zum Beispiel,
wenn ich jetzt auf das Game gehe,
weiß ich, es gibt auf der rechten Seite
einen Link zum Diskussionsforum.
Und wenn ich im Diskussionsforum bin,
bin ich quasi direkt
auf dieser Content-Seite dafür
und hab da irgendwelche Guides und sonst was.
Das ist schon nicht schlecht.
Ja, Twitter auch.
twitter twitter finde ich hat seit jahren eigentlich eines der besten
webseiten die aus wesentlich reduziert ist und einfach macht was sie soll und
twitter hat es bisher geschafft trotz ui updates das immer als quasi die leute
nicht vor nicht vor den kopf zu stoßen sowie das snapchat zum beispiel gemacht
hat das habt ihr wahrscheinlich mitgekriegt
für wenn ich verwende kein snapchat aber das haben wahrscheinlich denke ich
war die meisten mitgekriegt die haben ein update gemacht was quasi der
snapchat chef mehr oder weniger im alleingang durchgedrückt hat und danach
haben glaube ich drei millionen leute oder so eine petition unterzeichnet noch
mehr waren massiv viele leute ja nicht nur die acht waren viel mehr und jetzt
haben sie das alte ui am start soll das mal überlegen was was gibt es denn noch
für gute
für gute oberflächen wo ich sagen würde also jetzt nicht nur von einzelprogramm
sondern wo ich sagen würde die sind wirklich die sind wirklich gut
durchdacht weil einzelprogramme fallen wir dann zwar ein aber discord ja ja
discord discord finde ich discord ist auch gut discord ist gut ja discord ja
finde ich auch ist gut aber ja wo wir gerade ja jetzt fallen wir noch mehr an
links hier das finde ich auch super media center
das ist zwar in den settings her teilweise ein bisschen verwirrend aber
wenn man sich einen ordentlichen skin für nimmt kann das jeder bedienen
das hat auch eine gute oberfläche uein
doch wo ich sagen ja das hier was auch geiles ohne super oberfläche
das sei der grund warum ich mir gekauft hätte wissen ich bin ja nicht so der
bildbearbeitung mensch
Nein, wir wollen jetzt keine neue Version haben, aber Affinity Designer und Affinity Photo oder wie das andere heißt, ich hatte das hier noch nie gestartet, ist ein super Programm. Das ist klar, ja. Da kann sogar ich mit Thumbnails machen. Und es ist saumäßig schnell.
Seid euer, ist klar.
Das meiste auf Android finde ich auch nicht gut gemacht. Das meiste auf iOS, finde ich, geht eigentlich. Das ist wenigstens einheitlich. Das ist nicht unbedingt schöner. Ja, Visual Studio Code ist auch Elektron, ja.
Android finde ich an sich grausam. Ich meine, ich habe zwar viele Android-Geräte, aber das User-Interface, das finde ich schrecklich, was sie sich da ausgedacht haben.
Das fängt schon an mit Wischen von unten, Wischen von oben.
Hersteller, die das dann
teilweise merken, so Asus customizt
die Dinger ganz komisch.
Dass man
in WLAN-Settings nicht sieht, was das WLAN
für eine...
Es gibt viele Sachen,
es sind oftmals so Kleinigkeiten, wo ich mir denke,
warum ist das so?
Oder, dass die YouTube-App,
ich meine, wir haben das ja 2018,
ja, jeder
hinterwäldler
Media-Player, also den
schlechtesten, billigsten,
zusammengeschustesten Media-Player,
den du findest für ein Smartphone,
kann im Hintergrund was
abspielen. Aber,
dreimal dürft ihr raten,
was kann, welche App kann
im Hintergrund nichts abspielen?
Oh, welche App kann
nichts im Hintergrund abspielen?
So der Marktführer, quasi in diesem
Bereich, wer kann das nicht?
Genau, YouTube kann das nicht.
Und wenn man sich fragt, warum?
Klar, ich weiß, warum sie... Also, man kann
sagen, ja, das ist weil YouTube red, und mit YouTube
red kann sie das. Aber,
man kann auch nur eine Basisfunktion im Hintergrund
abspielen, Leute.
Dafür,
dafür Geld zu verlangen,
das kann man, das ist nicht
dreist, das ist eigentlich nicht
von dieser Welt im Kopf, irgendwie.
Ich meine,
wie schlecht muss ein Service sein,
dass man quasi
das Verkaufsargument bringt,
ähm,
ja, du kannst im Hintergrund abspielen.
Das heißt, ist der Service
so beschissen, dass YouTube red,
nichts zu bieten hat, außer,
dass man offiziell die Sachen im Hintergrund
abspielen kann.
Ist das so schlecht, der Service, oder was?
Was, welches Bildbearbeitungsprogramm hast du
gerade gezeigt? Das ist Affinity Designer.
Das ist gut.
Ja, das, ähm,
wo wir bei gutem UI sind, bei Twitch
kann man sich drüber streiten.
Also, Twitch,
im Browser,
muss ich sagen, finde ich es nicht schlecht.
Also, es ist,
es ist fokussiert auf den Inhalt.
Du findest die Sachen eigentlich relativ schnell.
Kann man sich, also bei Twitch
kannst du dich im Browser nicht beschweren.
Ähm,
sie haben manche Sachen verschlimmbessert,
ja, dass sie jetzt hier dieses Dropdown
gemacht haben seit einer Weile, anstatt
die Communities oben drin stehen zu haben, okay.
Was sie Twitch, was sie bei Twitch
überhaupt nicht hingekriegt haben, ist die neue
Smartphone-App.
Und, äh,
Android hast du glücklicherweise ein paar Alternativen.
Anstatt die offizielle
Twitch-App.
Unter iOS hast du nix.
Da musst du mit der Kack-Twitch-App leben.
Die Twitch-App ist Kacke.
Twitch im Browser finde ich gut.
Lass mal überlegen, was gibt's noch für Programme,
die gut sind?
OBS ist hässlich, aber OBS
finde ich vom Ansatz her auch gut.
Also, OBS ist
wirklich kein schönes Programm.
Ich mein, man muss OBS auch
zugutehalten, das ist Multi-Plattform.
Es ist, die Oberfläche ist glaube ich
in Qt 5 programmiert.
Also von OBS.
Ähm, aber die
Optionen sind in der Regel da, wo man sie
vermutet und es ist super simpel zu verwenden.
Es hat schon seinen Grund, warum kein
Mensch mehr XSplit oder
Wirecast oder wie das andere Zeug hieß
verwendet. Es verwenden eigentlich alle
OBS. Das hat seinen Grund.
Ähm, und
das ist auch gut so.
VLC, na, VLC finde ich
hat, VLC hat keine gute Oberfläche.
VLC
hab ich noch nicht, VLC noch mal installiert.
Äh, VLC ist wir.
Ähm, VLC
weiß ich nicht, wo du was, was finden musst.
Spotify, ja,
geht so. Spotify
finde ich jetzt
weder sonderlich gut noch sonderlich schlecht.
Das macht, was es soll.
Wie gesagt, Schießnudel Amazon
finde ich hat auch eine gute Oberfläche.
Was soll mein Programm eigentlich machen?
Mein Programm ist schon fertig.
Das zeigt transparente,
transparente Memes an.
Und kann per Shortcut
umgeschaltet werden auf unterschiedliche
Memes.
Und äh,
wieder ein- und ausblenden.
Und kann
die Sache rotieren.
Ach ja, und was ich ganz vergessen
habe zu zeigen, es kann sogar
GIFs abspielen.
Und noch viel krasser,
GIFs rotaten.
Und das,
und das Ganze auf Knopfdruck.
Also sprich, man hat quasi einen Overlay
mit, das müssen ja keine Memes sein,
das können irgendwelche Bilder sein, die du hinterlegst.
Du kannst hier quasi Shortcuts definieren,
Steuerung M ist MonkaS, Steuerung L
ist Lull, und wenn du jetzt gleich
wieder drückst, blendet das ein- und aus.
Also quasi so, so, so, so,
das ist das Memboard.
Also wenn man quasi streamt und irgendwie
was sieht, was einblenden will und irgendwie
grad mal sagt Lull, dann drückt man einfach den
Shortcut und
es ist da.
Wo es komischerweise kein Windows
Programm für gibt. Ich hab keins gefunden.
Und wisst ihr, was das Beste ist?
Das braucht, glaub ich mal, keine,
keine 10 MB Speicher,
das Ding. Hätte ich das, hätten wir,
hätten wir das Ganze jetzt gemacht mit
Elektron, dann hätten wir jetzt wahrscheinlich erstmal
250 MB RAM belegt und
die Leute hätten sich 180 MB runterladen
müssen dafür.
Hau es auf Git und wir machen das schön. Mach ich.
Mach ich. Wir laden das in GitHub hoch.
Mach ich morgen früh. Bin ja nicht
mehr eingeloggt.
Mach ich morgen früh. Ich lad das auf GitHub
hoch. Wie gesagt, es hat halt
0 Config Möglichkeiten, aber Pull Requests
nehme ich immer an.
Merge Requests. Nein, Pull
Pull Requests, wir sind ja auf GitHub.
Äh, wie würde man das jetzt machen,
wenn man will, dass die Memes
in die Echse gepackt werden? Also, wie es
mit WPF geht, bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Wahrscheinlich
geht's immer noch so. Du
kannst unter, unter Windows Forms kannst du's
in die Ressourcen, in die Resources hauen.
Und an Resources load
das, das Ding aufrufen, das geht.
Ich geh mal davon aus, dass wird hier immer noch
funktionieren. Ansonsten müsste ich
mal überlegen, ansonsten kann man das bestimmt irgendwie
reinpacken.
Da will ich mal. Haus auf GitHub,
ich mach in Java Porn. Da bist du sicher,
dass du das antun willst, ja.
Nameless King, was,
kannst du einem
Mechatronik schon enthelfen, wie Klassen in C++
funktionieren, mit Konstruktorvererbung
und so weiter. Interessiert
dich die Theorie
dahinter? Also sprich,
wozu braucht man
einen Konstruktor? Ähm,
und
das ist quasi so
objektorientierte Sache, Theorie,
Methoden, Klassen, Vererbung und solche
Sachen. Oder interessiert dich wirklich
einfach nur, wie's in
C++ geht? Weil,
äh, wie's in C++ geht,
das ist wahrscheinlich besser,
wenn du dir irgendein Tutorial anguckst.
Da ist dann nämlich auch erklärt, was an welcher
Stelle passiert. Von der Theorie her kann ich da ein bisschen
was zu erzählen. Das ist ja
in den meisten objektorientierten Sprachen ziemlich
ähnlich. Äh, Fetzen,
äh, Randy, das ist, da ist aber nur
dieses, die, die Uralt-Version
von, von meinem Screenshot-Tool
drinne, äh,
in Github.
Ich glaube, da ist sogar noch der
komische,
der Typ, der, der Typecast
drinne, den wir da aus Spaß reingemacht haben.
Wartet mal, muss ich mal gucken.
Ach nee, das ist die, ist das die DirectX
Version sogar schon?
Nee, das ist nicht die DirectX Version,
oder ist das?
Nee, das ist nicht die DirectX Version.
Nee. Wir haben, wir haben
schon längst weitergemacht.
Eine Weile. Wo hab ich denn hier
diesen ekligen Cast drinne?
Irgendwo.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Das ist schon längst,
kannst du
vergessen. An dem Tool machen
wir dem Status gar nicht mehr weiter.
Wir haben jetzt schon viel, wir sind ja schon viel weiter damit.
Das hab ich bloß nicht hochgeladen danach.
Warum ist eigentlich,
klappt das nicht im Vordergrund
dazu bringen?
So, ich muss jetzt mal gucken, ob der Nameless King was geschrieben hat.
Theorie wäre
nicht schlecht. Hab das
mit dem Konstruktor nicht so verstanden. Es gibt
ja einen Standardkonstruktor und einen, den man
schreiben muss. Wo liegt da der Unterschied?
Naja, der, also, jetzt mal von den
C++ spezifischen
Sonderfällen, die es bestimmt gibt.
C++ kannst du eh alles machen, wie du willst.
Abgesehen,
Standardkonstruktor ist implizit, der macht
halt nix.
Der ist halt, ne,
der ruft die Basisklasse auf
und falls in der Basisklasse was drin ist,
dann wird das ausgeführt, aber ansonsten macht er nix.
Also, wenn ich jetzt,
machen wir mal, wir machen mal ein neues Konsolenprojekt.
Kann ich, kann ich mal ein bisschen
Objektorientierung, was zu erzählen?
Eine Konsolen, nein, ich will
keine Konsolen-App.net Core.
Also, wenn
ich jetzt hier einfach ne neue Klasse anleg,
Klasse, Stream, irgendwas,
ähm, dann geht das.
Die funktioniert und ich kann
die auch anlegen. Und dann,
damit ich die Klasse quasi instanzieren kann,
wie das in der Objektorientierung
heißt, ähm,
also quasi, Stream gleich,
ups, Stream gleich
new, alter, mit der neuen Tastatur, ey.
new,
ich hab noch die indische
Tastatur drauf.
Damit ich sowas hier machen kann,
new stream,
braucht die Klasse nen Konstruktor.
Standardmäßig hat die einen,
der ist allerdings nicht notwendig,
explizit auszuschreiben, nämlich den
leeren.
Der leere macht nix.
Zumindest nichts zusätzlich.
Außer das
Notwendigste, was es irgendwie geht,
was du brauchst, dass du eben die Klasse
anlegen kannst, beziehungsweise die Instanz
anlegen kannst. Wenn du jetzt
ne Klasse hast, die von Stream erbt,
dann musst
du natürlich, beziehungsweise dann wird
standardmäßig der Konstruktor
aufgerufen von der Klasse, von der du geerbt hast.
Und wenn der irgendeinen Parameter braucht,
dann musst du den auch bei der
Klasse, von der du geerbt hast, angeben,
weil den musst du ja beim Base-Konstruktor übergeben.
Aber du brauchst keinen.
So, aber du kannst natürlich einen definieren,
wenn du was zusätzliches
machen willst. Entweder
nimmst du halt nen leeren und kannst hier drin
dann Zeugs anlegen, was weiß ich,
vielleicht musst du irgendwelche Bilder laden,
oder musst irgendwas aufräumen, oder irgendwelche
anderen Sachen, was auch immer,
was du halt machen musst.
Dazu kannst du natürlich auch n Konstruktor
machen, der irgendwelche
Parameter
erfordert. So, und
sobald du ne Klasse hast, die Parameter erfordert,
musst du natürlich n Konstruktor anlegen
und den Parameterlosen
wegmachen, dass man quasi
gezwungen ist,
den zu verwenden.
Es kann ja sein, dass deine Klasse zwingend
einen
Namen braucht.
Ohne, ohne
den sie nicht funktionieren kann.
Es gibt allerdings noch ein paar alternative
Arten zum Konstruktor.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Ansätze, wie man
Klassen instanziert.
Java-Leute stehen zum Beispiel
unglaublich oft Factories.
Letztendlich wird dann auch ein Konstruktor von aufgerufen,
ja klar, aber
ist die Frage, wie man das macht.
Achso, ja, und
dann, da bin ich mir nicht sicher,
wie das bei C++ ist,
ähm,
also, in C Sharp geht das nicht.
Du kannst, du kannst
C Sharp
glaube ich nicht,
ähm,
denjenigen, der deine Klasse verwendet,
beziehungsweise von deiner Klasse erbt,
den kannst du glaube ich nicht zwingen,
den Konstruktor zu
overloaden oder zu überschreiben.
Das ergibt auch eigentlich
keinen Sinn, weil der zu deiner Klasse gehört.
Da musst du halt einen eigenen machen.
Ob das in C++ geht, kein Schimmer.
Würde mich nicht wundern.
C++ geht alles. Würde ich aber nicht machen.
Also man kann
eine virtuelle Klasse machen und sagen
quasi, welche Methode derjenige, der davon
erbt, überschreiben muss.
Oder eine abstrakte Klasse,
welche er überschreiben muss.
Ähm,
zeig mal deine C++-Skills.
Ich hab den Cute Creator nicht drauf.
Hab ich nur auf meinem anderen Account.
Ist C++ schwerer
als JavaScript?
Das kann man
schlecht beantworten.
C++
ist auf jeden Fall gefährlicher
als JavaScript.
Also ich...
Das ist eine Frage, wenn man da drüber nachdenkt,
die ist gar nicht so einfach zu beantworten.
Weil C++ ist...
Wenn man sich wirklich darin auskennen will,
wo ich gar nicht mal behaupte,
dass ich das mache,
Klar, ich kann in C++ auch ein paar
GUIs basteln, Commandozeiten, das geht.
Aber wirklich auskennen
ist
quasi in C++ gar nicht möglich.
Das besteht aus so vielen Fallgruben
und so viel random Zeug,
wo du eigentlich denkst,
das kann doch so nicht sein,
dass es verdammt kompliziert ist.
Aber JavaScript hat genauso
viel Bullshit drinnen.
Und was bei JavaScript
eben noch dazu kommt, ist das
sich ständig ändernde
JavaScript-Ökosystem.
Also sprich, wenn du dir heute mal angeguckt hast
bei JavaScript,
welchen Paketmanager verwendest du,
ähm,
welchen Transpiler,
Transpiler, das ist auch so ein geiles
JavaScript, das gibt es nur da irgendwie.
Zumindest nur da wird es so übertrieben.
Welche irgendwie
Transpiletargets
und was auch immer du da nimmst für JavaScript,
wenn du dir das heute angeguckt hast,
kannst du davon ausgehen, in 5 Wochen ist das schon wieder
komplett neu alles.
Ich würde sagen, JavaScript und C++
sind beide unglaublich kompliziert,
wirklich gut zu sein drin,
aber auf komplett andere Art und Weise.
Is string by string
C sharp ein Typ?
Äh,
ja, also,
ich weiß jetzt nicht, was du meinst, also,
naja, ähm,
je nachdem wie man es sieht, also das ist ein Typ
und das ist auch gleichzeitig ein Objekt, also,
ja klar ist es ein Typ.
Java into K18.
Operator overloading
Fluch oder Segen hat jemand gefragt,
vorhin.
Ich finde Operator overloading
in begrenztem Maße okay.
Wenn man
es teilweise so übertreibt,
ich finde es zum Beispiel in C++,
ich finde es so beknackt,
dass irgendjemand auf die Idee gekommen ist,
teilweise, für manche Sachen
als Input
sowas zu verwenden. Warum?
Warum?
Wozu?
Wo ist das Problem zu schreiben,
print bla bla bla bla
ja, und wenn mir das nicht reicht,
plus bla bla bla bla.
Funktionsaufruf, jeder Depp erkennt,
dass es ein Funktionsaufruf ist,
aber nein, in C++
steht man ja auf sowas,
ja.
Komplett im Kontrast zu
allem anderen.
Weil sich der Typ, der das programmiert hat,
gedacht hat, oh, für Output wäre es
mal ganz nett, man verwendet einfach zwei Pfeile.
Ich weiß gar nicht, man kann wahrscheinlich
in C++ auch sowas machen, aber das habe ich noch nie gesehen,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ich weiß nicht, wer da auf diese Idee gekommen ist.
Nameless King sagt,
ach so, ich musste im Infopraktikum zwei
Constructors erstellen,
dem Standard
und einem der Parameter
bekommt die beiden das gleiche machen.
Wo ist der Sinn
von einem parametrisierten Constructor,
wenn er genau das gleiche macht, wie der ohne Parameter?
Wozu braucht man
den Parameter denn dann?
Was das
Meme-Tool am Ende können soll,
zeige ich dir, wir sind schon fertig.
Hast du schon mal was von der Unity Media
Vodafone-Übernahme gehört?
Ja, habe ich, klar,
die meisten werden wahrscheinlich schon was davon gehört haben.
Das Meme-Tool, was das kann,
das kann dir Memes
anzeigen.
Wenn du das startest,
dann kannst du hier unten, kannst du Shortcuts
definieren, zum Beispiel Strg-L
und Strg-L zeigt dir dann Aufwahl in
allen anderen Programmen transparent
an. Kann im Prinzip alles anzeigen,
was du einstellst. Ja, drückst du M,
zeigt dir hier mal ein KS an,
drückst du W, zeigt er dir hier
Confused an, drückst du
nochmal W, blendet das wieder aus. Das ist halt ganz
cool als Overlay, wenn du irgendwie was
streamst und sagst hier, ha, lol ist das
lustig, kannst du einmal ausblenden.
Da kannst du noch sinnlos rotieren,
du kannst noch
GIFs
anzeigen lassen und GIFs nochmal
zusätzlich sinnlos rotieren.
Das war's, mehr kannst du nicht.
So, was habe ich
ganz schön viel im Chat jetzt los auf einmal?
Ich glaube, wir wissen, ob
String ein primitiver Typ oder ein Objective
Typ ist. Das ist ein Objective Typ.
Das ist ein Alias.
String ist ein Alias,
also das String, was man
normalerweise verwendet für irgendwie
hier
so, ist ein Alias
auf String. Und Microsoft
sagt dazu, für Variablen
Zuweisung sollte man das hier, den
gealiasten Typ nehmen, für
Parameteraufrufe der String Klasse,
äh, nicht für Parameter, für Funktionsaufrufe
Methodenaufrufe der String Klasse,
sollte man das hier verwenden.
Sagt Microsoft und behauptet,
das ist lesbarer. Ich finde, da haben sie recht,
das ist lesbarer, aber so würde
das genauso funktionieren. Und so würde
das auch funktionieren.
Das ist ein Alias. String
ist ein Alias auf String
und das ist ein Objekt
oder eine Klasse.
Das ist das gleiche.
Es ist nicht so wie in Java,
dass du da primitive Sachen hast und nicht, also so
Magic primitive Sachen und nicht,
das ist besser gemacht.
Und meine Klimaanlage
kurz ausschalten.
Sieht kühl.
Das macht man nur bei
Streams.
Genau.
Dafür ist es da, für Streams, das
Memeboard.
Herr Black, der sagt, ein Kumpel von mir kann
C++ Code schreiben, der ist so
wie er, dass man den nicht versteht, wenn man
nicht weiß, was der Programm macht. Du kannst
in jeder Programmiersprache Code
schreiben, den keine Sau versteht.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
In C++ geht es
besonders einfach.
In Java geht das auch besonders
einfach. In JavaScript geht es noch
viel einfacher. Du kannst sogar in Python
kannst du. Und in Ruby besonders kannst du
Programmcode schreiben, den keine Sau versteht. In Perl
erst recht.
Du kannst aber auch C sauber
schreiben. Das geht.
Man muss sich halt ein bisschen am Riemen reißen
und nicht unbedingt, was
C-Programmiere ja gerne machen, ist,
ja,
C-Programmierer
machen ja sowas hier gerne.
Z
keine Ahnung, Z
Sowas machen. Das machen,
das waren C-Programmierer, das waren die
ultra gerne, dass du am Ende nicht weißt, was
was ist. So, als wüsstest du
Source Code, wüsstest du Bytes
sparen. Da stehen die irgendwie drauf.
Sag mal lieber
was dazu, dass Microsoft Github gekauft hat.
Da hab ich am Anfang schon was zu gesagt.
Also jetzt,
die Panik ist, denke ich,
unbegründet.
Da müssen wir sehen, was Microsoft da in Zukunft
mitmacht. Und dann können wir vielleicht
Panik bekommen. Aber jetzt einfach seine, seine
Projekte umzuziehen, wozu? Ich meine,
auf Github, die Leute haben Open Source
Projekte auf Github. Das heißt,
da gibt es nichts zu schützen in Form von, dass man
den Source Code nicht sehen darf
oder so. Ja klar, es gibt private Repos,
da kann man sich das überlegen. Aber für die
normale Open Source Projekte, wozu sollte man weggehen
von Github? Das ist, das ist Open Source.
Das ist, das ist schon da. Microsoft kann
das nicht mehr klauen oder so.
Ob das wirklich über alles anzeigt,
mach mal ein Spiel an. Ähm,
ne. Das zeigt,
das zeigt an
über, äh, Spiele
im, im, im Window-Modus
beziehungsweise Spiele im Fullscreen-Window,
äh, Spiele mit
exklusiv Fullscreen,
äh, wird garantiert nicht, kein Overlay
anzeigen. Ja,
ich lad den, ich lad das morgen früh auf Github
hoch. Kann jeder mit rumbasteln, wie er will.
Wer braucht Strings?
Character Arrays are superior.
Ja, Strings haben Methoden zur
Stringmanipulation, die haben Character Arrays nicht.
ScaryLeggy
sagt, er mag die Java-Magic.
Bist du krank?
Quälst du dich
irgendwie gerne?
Größer C++-Diskussion beendet.
Ich bin immer
der Ansicht, muss ich einfach
für das, was man machen will, das Richtige raussuchen.
Wenn's rein
nach mir geht, wie schön ich
die jeweilige Programmiersprache
finde und wie gern ich damit was mache,
muss ich tatsächlich sagen,
und ihr wisst, ihr habt's ja wahrscheinlich in diesem Stream mitgekriegt,
ich bin absolut kein Windows-Fan
und eigentlich auch kein großer Microsoft-Fan,
aber
C Sharp ist
mit Abschreibung meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache.
Beatport
das ist das Gleiche,
der fragt, warum Methodennamen in
C, C++ immer so seltsame Abkürzungen haben.
Das ist einmal historisch
bedingt, also sowas wie memcpi
und strlang anstatt
stringlang, so memcopy,
das ist einmal historisch bedingt, weil die halt so heißen.
Schon immer.
Und auf der anderen Seite, weil ich das Gefühl
hab, dass C, vor allem C++
äh, C++ und vor allem
C-Programmierer gerne
abkürzen.
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer, die hab ich noch nicht verstanden.
Äh,
xsterbehilfe sagt, ich hab immer massiv Probleme
mit dem sauber programmieren im Betrieb.
Sagt man, so ist das
sauber und in der Schule sagen sie was anderes.
Sauber ist, was lesbar ist,
für dich und
ähm,
für jemanden, der sich ein bisschen damit, also mit deinem Programm
beschäftigt, also ich finde,
sauber, sauber programmiert,
das heißt nicht, dass man automatisch das aufmacht
und instant versteht. Jedes Programm,
mit einer gewissen Komplexität,
muss man sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigen,
was es eigentlich genau macht.
Ja, also, man wird kein,
sogar das hier, ohne Scheiß, das ist nicht
sonderlich hübsch programmiert, ja, aber sogar das hier,
das ist relativ simpel, ja, sind 130 Zeilen,
sogar da, wenn das jemand das erste
Mal aufmacht, denkt er sich, hä?
Alter, was will der genau?
Äh,
ja, und dann kommt er dahinter.
Also, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen,
äh,
angucken muss ich das derjenige schon,
aber ich finde, sauber,
sauberer Quellcode,
ähm, braucht,
und ich, das ist was relativ
kontroverses, das weiß ich, da reden sich immer viele
drüber auf so, aber, ich finde,
sauberer Quellcode zeichnet
sich dadurch aus, dass man ihn gut
lesen kann, auch wenn er nicht viele Kommentare
hat.
Denn, viele Leute,
vor allem Azubis kriegen das in der
Schule beigebracht,
und wahrscheinlich lernt man das heute an der Uni
auch,
äh, oder an der Fachhochschule
oder sonst wo,
dass guter Code viele
Kommentare hat.
Und die Leute
fangen dann mit sowas hier an.
Machen wir mal.
Die Leute fangen dann
sowas hier an mit,
so,
aber irgendwas, so,
so, ganz, ganz tollen Code, und dann fangen
die Leute sowas hier an, äh,
let temp to one.
Nächstes
Kommentar ist dann,
check if temp
greater to.
Das sind Kommentare,
die braucht kein Mensch.
Das kriegst du
aber in der Schule oder an vielen Stellen so erklärt.
Dass diese Kommentare, wenn man da mal logisch
drüber nachdenkt, die bringen keinem
was.
Jeder, der auch nur eine Programmiersprache
kann, der liest diese paar Zeichen,
hier, und weiß,
du checkst, ob temp größer als 2
ist. Der muss nicht
lesen, check if temp greater als 2.
Ein gutes
Kommentar würde so
aussehen, dass da drinnen steht,
warum du checkst,
weshalb temp
größer als 2 ist.
Also so nach dem Motto,
da steht da nicht drinnen, check if temp
größer 2, sondern da steht drinnen,
ähm, wie überprüft,
äh, größer 2 bedeutet,
die
Hardware hat einen Fehler geworfen.
Was weiß ich, oder, oder, äh,
Error Code, Error Code
2 gleich keine Netzwerkverbindung.
Irgendwie sowas würde da drüber stehen, ja?
Dann weiß ich, okay,
ich, ich gucke einfach, ob das keinen Fehler
geworfen hat. Also,
warum gucke ich, ob temp
größer als 2 ist? Das ist das,
was in das Kommentar hier eigentlich rein müsste.
Nicht so ein Stuss, den eh jeder sieht.
Was muss man auch mal den Leuten
in, in, in der
Berufsschule, Berufsschule habe ich keine Hoffnung mehr dabei,
aber das müssten eigentlich mehr Leute, die
Leute ein bisschen coachen, ja, und ein bisschen,
ein bisschen zeigen, und ein bisschen,
wenn du, wenn du so Junior
bist, da, da,
mal ein bisschen versuchen, das den
Leuten näher zu bringen.
Wie gesagt, sauber programmieren braucht
eigentlich wenig Kommentare, dass man
die Logik versteht,
die Kommentare, die notwendig sind,
ähm, sollten sich da drauf konzentrieren,
warum man was macht, und warum
das notwendig ist.
Also, warum muss man das machen?
Das heißt, ich finde es auch viel wichtiger,
anstatt, dass man hier drinnen das genau erklärt,
sondern zum Beispiel, ähm,
warum,
warum gibt es, warum
gibt es diese Methode, warum macht man das?
Ähm, und da
schreibt man dann ordentlich was dazu rein.
Naja.
So, mal Chat gucken.
Wann kann man nicht endlich subben?
Tja, wenn ich Twitch mal
befrage, wie es aussieht. Oder ich doch
einfach den Affiliate-Haken drücke.
Was spielst du gerade so
für Games?
Tja, gucken wir doch mal. Recent.
Über Steam habe ich letztens gespielt
Tower of Time, deswegen, das ist ein RPG.
Pillars of Eternity 2, das ist auch ein RPG.
Mind Magic 3, das ist auch ein RPG.
Patel 1944, das haben wir
das letzte Mal im Stream gespielt.
Wolfenstein,
denke ich, ist schon ewig her. Über Steam nicht viel.
Ich spiele auch ein bisschen BDO
nebenbei. Ansonsten
eigentlich relativ wenig, zur Zeit.
So.
Ich muss jetzt auch mal Chat gucken. Ich habe relativ wenig
Chat jetzt hier über Blick gehabt.
Ähm.
Ah, du bist ein Java-Deffner.
Da wundert mich nichts mehr.
So welche haben wir aber auch auf der Arbeit.
Ich bin da schon gewöhnt.
Was ist denn SPS?
Ist das irgendwelche Microcontroller-Geschichte?
Ah.
Irgendwelches Industrie-
Automatisierungsteilchen oder sowas ist das.
Naja, gut.
Ich weiß ja nicht, mit was man das programmiert.
Aber
es wird wahrscheinlich...
Mit was programmiert man das heutzutage?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, mit irgendwelchen wahrscheinlich
Assembler-ähnlichen... Assembler-Zeug.
Aber mittlerweile wahrscheinlich auch schon mit
ein bisschen was höher leveligerem.
Oder mit C oder irgendeinem eigenen
Dialekt oder...
Was ist deine Meinung dazu, dass
inkrementieren von Bool in C++
17 aus dem Standard
entfernt wurde? Wie viele Programme wird das wohl...
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass
man Bool incrementen kann in C++.
Siehste...
Das sind so Dinger,
wo ich meine, C++ hat so viele
Fallstricke
und dementsprechend auch so viele
Kniffe und Hacks, wo man
Sachen schneller machen kann oder
besser machen kann oder wie auch immer, die man halt wissen muss.
Das ist...
Das hat so viele Anklassen drin. Warum sollte
man Bool incrementen können?
Was passiert denn, wenn ich einen Bool incremente?
Wird der dann aus True-False oder was?
Also wenn ich... Ich hab das...
Ich hab das in C-Sharp noch nie ausprobiert,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier sage...
Und ich sage jetzt B++... Geht das?
Ne, das geht nicht.
Dann würde ich auch erwarten, dass es nicht geht.
Plus plus... Also...
Was passiert denn in C++,
wenn man Bool incrementet? Kommt dann quasi aus
True-False und aus False-True oder...
Ach ja!
Das... Diese Sache mit False
und True und so. Wollte ich euch auch noch was zu zeigen,
was nämlich auch viele
immer gerne am Anfang machen,
weil sie denken, das ist...
Das ist ähm...
lesbarer.
Also mal angenommen, man hat hier jetzt so eine Variable,
so nach dem Motto äh...
hasError.
Mir fällt jetzt da gerade nichts anderes ein.
Die machen dann solche Dinger hier.
If hasError... Und da krieg ich immer...
Das tut schon weh, ja?
If error gleich gleich
true, ja?
Else...
Da machen wir was.
Es ist grausam. Und es geht noch
schlimmer. Es geht noch viel schlimmer.
Ähm...
Return true.
Sowas gibt's laufend.
Ach ja, alternativ... Alternativ...
Der Milchmann hat recht. Alternativ
kann man natürlich auch noch hasError...
Hehehe...
Ja, aber sowas gibt's laufend.
Der Zorro lernt gerade C-Sharp.
Das ist eine super Entscheidung.
C-Sharp ist zum Anfang auch toll.
Was, man kann Bool incrementen, aber nicht decrementen?
Okay. Aha.
Doch, gibt's.
Gibt's.
Normalerweise zeigt er...
zeigt er auch so Dinger hier an.
Aber anscheinend, der findet dann nicht, dass das schlimm ist.
Der denkt, das ist gut.
Es gibt doch mal...
Das hab ich irgendwo bei Microsoft in irgendeinem Talk gesehen.
Man kann irgendwie irgendwelches Linter-Zeug noch aktivieren.
Also, standardmäßig
haben die auch schon relativ viel drin.
Hier sagt er mir auch, dass kleingeschriebene
ähm... dass das irgendwie
löst gegen... gegen Benahmung und so.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich so dumm,
was ich hier geschrieben hab, dass Linte da noch nicht war.
So, und wie gesagt,
sowas sieht man hier auch... sieht man total oft.
Und vor allem in Kombination
dann noch mit nem If, das quasi
explizit checkt,
ob nen Bool gleich
gleich true ist, was... schau mal.
Ich... ich frag jetzt mal in die Runde.
Wir exposen jetzt auch kein
und flamen.
Ist allen klar, warum das hier
keine gute Idee ist, so zu schreiben?
Oder vielleicht hat sich jemand ja auch in letzter Zeit
selbst dabei erwischt, dass er sowas ähnliches
wie das hier geschrieben hat.
Und dann kann ich das nochmal kurz erklären, warum das...
warum man das quasi alles in einer Zeile
schreiben kann.
Ja, genau, Real Cracks. So sieht's aus.
Ja, ich weiß auch, wie das richtig ist.
Erklär mal bitte.
Genau, der Zorro lernt gerade, sie schabt.
Ist gut, kann ich das nochmal kurz ausführen.
Also, mehrere Sachen, die hier dran
komplett verkehrt sind.
Du hast ne Variable, hasError,
und die ist jetzt halt in dem Fall mal true.
Meistens kriegst du das ja als Parameter
von ner Funktion in der Methode
übergeben, aber hasError ist true.
So viel ist halt so.
Kann man nix dran ändern.
Ist in dem Fall so.
So, und jetzt guckst du,
ob quasi...
Also, jetzt musst du dir überlegen,
bei diesem Vergleich
hasError gleich gleich true,
was kommt denn da raus?
Da kommt
true raus.
Also sprich, da kommt der gleiche Wert raus,
der hier schon drinnen steht.
Das heißt, den Vergleich
kann man sich sparen.
Das ist das Erste.
Das braucht man nicht.
Es ist 1 zu 1, genau das Gleiche.
Logisch gesehen, es ist genau das Gleiche.
Wenn man sich's genau überlegt,
guckst du ja quasi,
ob true gleich gleich true ist.
Wenn man das so liest,
feststellt man, das ist ziemlicher Blödsinn.
Das kann man schon mal weglassen.
So, nachdem
hasError
beziehungsweise den bool
natürlich plus 2 Werte hat,
kannst du dir ein else if
auch schon mal komplett sparen,
sondern sagen, das ist ein else.
So, und jetzt ist der eigentliche Klackpunkt,
dass wir das eigentlich nur checken,
um zu gucken, was wir für eine Rückgabe,
also mit welchem Wert wir aus der Methode rausgehen.
Und das ist im Prinzip
das Gleiche wie beim if.
Ähm, du checkst hier,
ob es true ist,
um dann quasi,
anstatt die Variable direkt
zu nehmen, true zurückzugeben.
Das heißt, du könntest
den ganzen Scheiß ersetzen mit
hasError.
Und das macht exakt das Gleiche.
Also sprich, das hier
macht genau das Gleiche wie dieses
Geschwurbel hier vorher.
Aber trotzdem, sowas sieht man erstaunlich oft.
Gibt es, jetzt kommen aber
die Fragen hier.
Gibt es in C-Sharp
Identity
Equality?
Ich bin mir gar nicht so ganz sicher,
was du meinst. Meinst du sowas wie in JavaScript
das da? Ups.
Meinst du in JavaScript das hier?
Sowas,
sowas gibt es in C-Sharp nicht.
Gleich gleich in C-Sharp bedeutet,
es ist die gleiche Instanz
links und rechts. Oder aber,
es hat jemand equals
überschrieben. Dann kann es im Prinzip
das Mögliche sein.
Aber in der Regel bedeutet
es, links und rechts ist die gleiche
Instanz.
Außer bei structs, da ist es ein bisschen anders.
Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel
hier sowas mache wie
keine Ahnung, was können wir mal machen?
Das zeigt mir eigentlich autovervollständigungsmäßig
hier gar nichts an.
Was weiß ich, wenn ich hier irgendwie sage,
keine Ahnung, new
bitmap oder irgendwie sowas.
Irgendwas so.
Wenn ich das zweimal mache,
dann ist das natürlich
nicht gleich gleich das, weil das sind zwei unterschiedliche
Instanzen. Aber so komisches
Zeug wie gleich gleich, gleich gleich
und
was habe ich letztens gesehen in Groovy?
Ich glaube sowas hier,
das gibt es hier in C-Sharp glücklicherweise
nicht.
Ja Quinn, das habe ich am Anfang
aber auch gemacht, den Fehler. Er schreibt, er hat
quasi anstatt
das so zu schreiben,
das was wir eben als Beispiel
hatten, hat er quasi geschrieben
if not true
oder beziehungsweise hier dann
false oder sowas. Aber klar,
ich meine das kann man natürlich auch
mit einfach has not
error machen.
Aber das habe ich am Anfang
auch gemacht. Ich glaube das hat jeder am Anfang
ein paar mal verkehrt gemacht.
So, ich bin beim Chat unten angelangt.
Beatprote hat noch geschrieben,
dass er mal einen C-Entwickler gesehen hat,
der Java programmiert.
Also C-Programmierer, sie haben in der Regel eh schon
eine sehr
eigenartige Art und Weise, wie gesagt,
Variablen und alles mögliche zu benennen.
Das muss halt immer, das muss alles möglichst kurz sein.
So als würde es interessieren, ob dem
Sourcecode ein paar Byte mehr oder weniger stehen.
Aber ich kann es irgendwo verstehen.
Wenn man auf
Performance und RAM und alles guckt, dann
guckt man das wahrscheinlich auch in seinem Sourcecode.
Aber wenn so jemand dann Java programmieren muss,
wobei er da wahrscheinlich keinen Bock drauf gehabt hat.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen,
dass da nichts hübsches rausgekommen ist.
Äh,
der Matt fragt was Interessantes.
Mal ein wenig
off-topic. Warum benutzt du nicht
Linux als Hauptsystem mit GPU
Pass-Thru und warum
programmierst du nicht den Org?
Nun, der zweite Teil
ist natürlich, äh, debated.
Ähm,
warum benutzt du nicht
Linux als Hauptbetriebssystem mit
CPU Pass-Thru?
Also hauptsächlich, weil es unnötig kompliziert
ist. Das zweite ist,
weil es das Setup
kompliziert macht. Also,
wenn du, wenn du CPU Pass-Thru verwendest,
hast du ja deinen Host auf einem anderen
Grafikausgang, wie,
also kannst, du hast ja kein, du kannst
ja nicht schnell dazwischen umschalten.
Na, weil wenn du GPU Pass-Thru machst,
hast du ja quasi die Grafikkarte
in der VM und von der
VM an den Monitorausgang,
also über die Grafikkarte und dein Host
muss, muss ja über einen anderen laufen.
Geht ja gar nicht anders.
Das heißt, du brauchst auch wiederum letztendlich zwei
Monitore. Dann hast
du das Problem mit Eingabegeräten.
Wie kriegst
du deine Maus von der VM in Host
und zurück?
Das ist nicht so, dass es nicht geht.
Aber es
ist, macht's einfach unnötig kompliziert.
Ich find die,
ich find's umgedreht viel einfacher,
dass man ein Windows hat und
eine Linux-VM mit,
haben wir hier sogar im Stream zusammen
eingerichtet, die,
die Manjaro-VM.
Find ich viel einfacher.
Dazu kommt, dass Nvidia Grafikkartentreiber
mit durchgereichten CPUs massig
Probleme verursachen.
Weil Nvidia eingebaut hat, dass sie in,
dass sie quasi in,
dass die normale GeForce
Serie
nicht dafür gedacht ist,
quasi für
Virtualisierung. Deswegen haben sie in den Treiber eingebaut,
dass wenn sie erkennen, dass du in einem Hypervisor
läufst, dass der Grafikkartentreiber nicht geht in solche
Dinger. Also es macht's einfach
unnötig kompliziert.
Ja, und so Sachen hier wie Streamen
und
Vegas für Videobearbeitung und
also Audio-Video-Zeug ist halt
auch unter Linux nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Man muss, man muss auch immer sehen, wenn man
ein bisschen, wenn man mehrere Systeme hat
und auch schon ein bisschen mit mehreren Systemen
auseinandergesetzt hat, dann geht's dann
auch irgendwann gar nicht mehr darum, irgendwie
wo fanboyt man mehr oder so, sondern
irgendwann sagst du einfach nur
hey, ich nehm einfach das,
was für das, was ich jetzt
machen will, das angenehmste ist.
Und das ist halt
für das, was ich hier daheim mache,
auch wenn mir Windows auf den Sack geht, halt Windows.
Weißt du, wieso
keine Sau Hyper-V verwendet?
Also das letzte Mal, wo ich Hyper-V eingeguckt hab, ging
kein USB-Pass zu richtig.
Ähm...
Weiß ich, wie der Linux-Report ist.
Wahrscheinlich ganz gut mittlerweile.
Äh, Grafikbeschleunigung
in Hyper-V war auch grausam am Anfang.
Weiß nicht.
Hab ich noch nichts, noch nicht viel mitgemacht.
Ach, nee, das ist nicht
Linux als Host-System.
Nee, nee. Ich mein, ich hab ja immer
die, ich hab ja, wenn ich den Linux brauche, also sprich,
wenn ich jetzt irgendwelche dubiosen
Links kriege,
dann hab ich ja hier direkt meine
Linux-VM.
Jo. Wir haben viel länger
gebraucht, als ich gedacht hab, ne?
Ich mein, das ist nicht
wirklich kompliziert, was wir hier gebastelt haben.
Und wahrscheinlich hätt ich das ohne
streamen auch in der Hälfte der Zeit fertig gemacht.
Aber irgendwie macht's
trotzdem mehr Spaß, so ein Kram im Stream
zusammenzubasteln, als
quasi allein. Und das
allerwichtigste noch mal.
Jetzt Special Effect.
Kannst du nicht schon den
Source-Code hochladen?
Sind wir noch auf GitHub angemeldet?
Nee, sind wir nicht mehr.
Warte mal.
Ich guck mal.
Ich guck mal, ob ich
Ich guck mal, ob ich meine,
mein GitHub-Passwort finde gerade.
Dann leg ich nämlich
Dann leg ich nämlich mal ein Projekt an und kann
das pushen.
Ich kann grad nicht tippen in mir.
GitHub.
Ups, hab ich nicht gespeichert.
Boah, was hatte ich denn da für ein Passwort?
The fuck. Nee, kann ich
grad nicht hochladen. Muss ich erst mal gucken. Weiß ich aus dem Kopf
nicht. Was hatte ich denn für ein
GitHub-Passwort? Das war irgendwas Blödes.
Was hatte ich denn da?
Was hatte ich denn? Warte mal.
Sieht man irgendwo die E-Mail-Adresse,
die ich hier angegeben hab?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, dass
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo wir den
Wo wir das überhaupt hingeschmissen
haben. Source?
Ah.
Okay, das ist schon mal nicht das Richtige.
Warum ist Friesi nicht das Richtige?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung.
Muss ich mal morgen raussuchen.
Vor allem, weil
Virtualbox vor allem wäre...
Nutzt du keinen Passwortmanager?
Doch, da habe ich gerade reingeguckt. Da steht GitHub
nicht drinnen.
Ich gucke gerade mal auf Passwort Recovery, ob ich da auf
irgendeine E-Mail-Adresse
was kriege.
Habe ich das mit meinem Google?
Ach, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich lade es morgen hoch.
Ich finde es gerade nicht.
Kann man sich eigentlich keine Mails anzeigen lassen?
Die müssen doch hier dabei stehen.
An jedem Comet steht eine Mail drin.
Die müssen doch hier irgendwo unser Git-Repo haben.
Naja.
Welchen Passwortmanager
fände ich für unseren Ewigkeiten-
Keypass?
Du musst generell mal mehr programmieren.
Vielleicht sogar mal eine Engine angucken zusammen. Unity oder so.
Wäre geil.
Ich hatte bisher noch überhaupt
keinen Zug zum Spieleprogrammieren irgendwie.
Auch wenn ich
sonst...
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe einen YouTube-Channel gemacht, wo es um Gaming geht.
Aber irgendwie...
Programmiertechnisch hat es mich noch nie
zu Spielen hingezogen so richtig.
Aber vielleicht, wenn ich mal die krasse Game-Idee habe.
Vielleicht machen wir dann irgendwas.
Da muss ich mir das ja auch selbst angucken.
Vielleicht war mein GitHub
auch im anderen Browser angemeldet.
Hier kann das sein.
So, habe ich schon was vergessen zu lesen.
Ist ein
Macbook zum Programmieren wirklich
so geil, wie es einem immer verkauft wird?
Nö.
Das ist eine ganz einfache Antwort.
Mac ist ein
viel angenehmeres Betriebssystem,
um da drüber, zumindest
das meiste, um Sachen zu entwickeln.
Vor allem Web-Anwendungen oder sowas wie Windows.
Aber
rein das Macbook an sich macht es jetzt nicht aus.
Außerdem
kann man sich auch in Linux installieren.
Das nimmt sich für
Web-Entwicklung ein Schnicks.
Hast du das über die Bella Twitch TV
API gemacht?
Was genau?
Wann gibt es noch YouTube-Videos?
Das frage ich mich selbst.
Das ist
immer so eine Sache.
Ich sehe es ja, wenn ich nichts mache,
Abo zahlen, Views, alles im Arsch.
Fange ich an, was zu machen,
ist zwar die Statistik immer noch im Arsch,
aber ich sehe, dass sie nicht mehr so im Arsch ist,
wie ein paar Tage vorher.
Das heißt, es geht eigentlich relativ schnell
dann immer wieder
weiter, wieder rauf.
Es dauert dann aber drei Wochen oder so, bis sich das wieder ordentlich
erholt hat und es wirklich rauf geht.
Und dann habe ich meistens schon keinen Bock mehr.
Ich bräuchte einfach ein Game,
wo ich
permanent selbst
spielen will
und auch Theorie craften
und halt die ganze Zeit was zu erzählen.
Dann würde ich auch wieder viele Videos machen.
Ja, das ist eine
gute Idee. Das können wir erst mal gucken.
Ich bin mir
aber gar nicht mehr sicher, ob
ich das...
Ich glaube nämlich, das hatten wir.
Was ist es? Global...
E-Mail.name oder...
Ah ne, ich glaube User.
Nein, natürlich
nicht. Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher,
ob wir das über die Shell hier gemacht haben.
Haben wir das über die
Lelux-Fam gemacht?
Ich muss einfach nur ankündigen, dass du schwanger bist.
Wieso ist das zurzeit im Trend?
Werden alle YouTuber schwanger?
Wäre PoE nichts für dich? Doch!
Persifex halt ist geil.
Übelst geil.
Haben wir glaube ich auch schon
300 Stunden
oder so gespielt. Aber ist auch schon wieder
eine ganze Weile her.
Ja, ich weiß, Discord-Server wollte
ich schon lange machen.
Ich habe den ganzen Krempl hier ja mal
eingerichtet, aber
ich glaube, haben wir das letzte Mal nicht
irgendwas anderes verwendet?
Oder habe ich
irgendwie gelöscht mal alles? Kann das sein?
Ja, wir haben doch Scoop
und Gedöns doch zusammen hier installiert noch.
Ich glaube, ich habe das alles weggeschmissen
mal nach dem Stream.
Deswegen ist es dann immer da.
Ja, Discord-Server machen dauert 3 Sekunden.
Ich habe ja auch einen Discord-Server, aber der ist nicht öffentlich.
So, dann müssen wir irgendwie
rauskriegen, was
ich bei GitHub
für eine
Mail verwendet habe. Das müssen wir doch
rauskriegen. Kann doch nicht sein.
Das kriegen wir raus.
Ha!
Ich glaube, ich habe es.
Haha! Ich habe es!
Okay, Startup Project.
Repo-Name.
Ich habe es gefunden.
Ich habe das Passwort glücklicherweise in Firefox
auf einem anderen Rechner gespeichert.
So, hier ist das Ding.
Meme Board, oder?
Wir haben es
genannt.
Meme Board.
Wie gesagt, ich lade es jetzt 1 zu 1 so hoch,
wie wir es hier im Stream gebastelt haben.
Also, ohne
irgendwie GUI-Konfigurationsmöglichkeit.
Create
Repo.
Meme Board.
Da ist es.
Dann schmeißen wir das mal auf GitHub hoch.
Da kann man ja Chat einblenden.
Hauen wir das mal auf GitHub.
Könnt ihr euch alle angucken, wenn ihr wollt.
Warum funzt
Funzt Omegalull nicht mehr?
Ich habe das noch nie für den Channel hier aktiviert.
Ich habe ja auch keine kostenpflichtige Better Twitch TV
Geschichte. Ich kann ja bloß 3 Emotes oder sowas machen.
Nee,
Sibaro, alter Stream hilft nicht.
Aber die Seite ist super, die du gemacht hast.
Na, Sibaro hat eine Seite
gemacht, weil Twitch das ja nicht
speichert. Ich glaube es ist
Ruploads.tv
Da könnt ihr alle
alten Streams
angucken.
Ich glaube es fehlen bloß die ersten
paar. Sind alle Sachen
da.
Ah, Archiv muss man drauf gehen.
Guck, sind alle
meine Streams sind da, die ich bisher
gemacht habe.
Beim Sibaro.
Nee, es fehlen doch ein paar.
Es fehlen ein paar. Das erste ist
hier ist COD. Das erste ist
World War 2
Livestream. Da kamen schon einige davor.
Aber es ist zumindest
das einzige Archiv, was es gibt.
Was hat CMDR für Vorteile
gegenüber Hyper?
Schön dazu benutzen.
Kannst du praktische Shortcuts anlegen.
Da sind schon alle möglichen Tools
dabei. Hat eine History.
So, ähm.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal
das Repo adden.
So.
Status
git add
Ja, Punkt
VS und Packages
wollen wir eigentlich nicht
hinzufügen.
Machen wir mal git ignore.
Und dann schreibt man das, glaube ich,
einfach so rein.
Oder? Schreibt man, ich glaube, schreibt man einfach.
Ja.
Ah, man kann auch Sternchen dahinter machen.
Genau.
Ach, fuck. Ja, die
Dinger sollte ich
nicht adden.
Da ist ja das ganze
Compile Zeug und so drinnen.
Wisst ihr was?
Wir löschen nochmal
das git repo
und lassen Visual Studio
das Ding anlegen.
Dann macht er das
wenigstens richtig.
Doch, Visual Studio hat git support, aber
ich mag das nicht im GUI klicken.
So, aber jetzt hat's...
Jetzt hat Visual Studio wenigstens schon den ganzen
Krempel angelegt für mich.
Oder auch nicht.
Wart mal.
Löscht den Scheiß nochmal.
Ähm.
So, und jetzt darf
Visual Studio nochmal...
Oh, das hat's jetzt nicht gecheckt.
Jetzt muss man neu starten.
Ja, das sind doch so Windows-Geschichten.
Übrigens könnt ihr euch merken,
um ein git repo zu löschen,
löscht einfach den git Ordner.
Das löscht sonst nix.
Wir haben Visual Studio kaputt gemacht.
Der
hat glaube ich nicht gecheckt.
Ah doch, jetzt hat er's.
So, jetzt haben wir wahrscheinlich
auch ne ordentliche git ignore.
Ja, okay, alles gut.
git status,
git add,
alles dabei.
Ja.
Genau.
So, komm mit.
Mal gucken, aber...
Wir hatten den bis doch schon mal konfiguriert.
Ich hatte doch auch...
Ich muss jetzt mal nachgucken.
Ich hab doch in der Github auch mein...
Mein Key und so schon hinterlegt, oder?
Warte mal, muss ich mal gucken.
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Okay, dann brauch ich das Passwort mal.
Dann push ich den Krempel
jetzt nämlich noch und dann ist gut.
Saved Logins.
Github.
WTF, was hab ich denn da für ein Passwort genommen?
Ey.
Pff.
Das hatten wir doch alle schon konfiguriert.
Ich glaub, ich hab den Ordner einfach...
Einfach weggeschmissen, hm?
Oder wir hatten's nur repo-weise
gesetzt, das kann auch sein.
Hä?
Achso, das hab ich ja vorhin hinzugefügt,
nachdem ich's wieder gelöscht hab.
Omega lul.
Woll ich doch mal...
Gucken wir mal, ob er das jetzt überhaupt angelegt hat.
Github.
Oh, drei Stunden später.
Was'n das?
Geht vor Windows oder was?
Hat jetzt nen Login-GUI
oder was?
Uiuiui.
Weiß gar nicht, wie haben sie denn das gemacht?
Das müssen sie da irgendwie reingepatcht haben.
Lustig.
Äh.
Hoffentlich stimmt das hier.
Ha!
Fuck.
Oder auch nicht.
Ah, funktioniert.
So, das Zeug ist gepusht.
Wenn ihr das angucken will,
kann jetzt hier Github, Memeboard...
Hab ich vergessen zu committen.
Ja, klar.
Lul.
Alderlan.
So, jetzt ist da.
Da ist es.
Also, könnt ihr euch angucken, wenn ihr wollt.
Falls irgendeiner Pull-Requests
aufmachen möchte
und das irgendwie verbessern,
bis morgen kann er das gerne machen, ich guck mir das morgen früh an.
Aber wie gesagt,
es wäre für mich gedacht, dass ich in meinen Streams
eher
sinnlose
Memes einsplenden kann und spammen.
Was für ein Handy hast du
aktuell eigentlich?
Ich hab ein iPhone 6, immer noch.
Antivirenprogramme, Schlangenöl oder Wundermittel?
Dazu empfehle
ich dir
dieses
Viro... äh.
Dieses Video hier zu gucken.
Und falls du noch nicht
abonniert hast, mich auf YouTube zu abonnieren.
Da habe ich mich
20 Minuten über genau
das Thema ausgelassen.
Hast du mal WoW gespielt?
Ähm, ich hab WoW ganz am Anfang
mal ein bisschen gespielt mit dem MasterCover
zusammen.
Aber nicht weit, bis Level 40
oder so. Wir haben ja damals Dark gespielt
ohne Ende, so
tausende Stunden.
Und waren damals überzeugt,
dass das einfach das superior Game
ist.
Erstens habe ich so ein bisschen auf Nostalrius
gespielt vor einem Jahr oder vor zwei,
ist glaube ich schon wieder zwei Jahre her.
Aber der Server, der wurde ja dann
vor Blizzard dicht gemacht.
Weil das ein echt cooler Server
war. Für das, dass
die das alles selbst gemacht haben, wirklich, das war super.
Massig Spieler,
mehr wahrscheinlich als teilweise auf
Live da irgendwie auf dem Server sind.
Massig, also wirklich massiv
viele Spieler. Und sogar
die Leute relativ nett, was man bei den meisten
Free Shards ja nicht, äh,
gerade sagen kann.
Aus welchem Grund hast du Windows auf Englisch?
Ja!
Also, ich hab so ziemlich alles, was es gibt
auf Englisch.
Hauptsächlich aus dem Grund,
weil man schneller was
findet, wenn was nicht funktioniert.
Und das kann ich auch jedem nur
empfehlen, der ein bisschen
der Sache mächtig ist und man
muss, selbst wenn man überhaupt
kein Englisch kann,
es werden ja überall die gleichen Sachen
verwendet. Es ist überall
Highlighted View Settings, was auch immer.
Du musst dir 50 Sachen merken
und du findest dich zurecht auf
einem englischen Windows.
Und du hast den großen Vorteil, oder bei allem
eigentlich, wenn du was, wenn was nicht geht,
du kannst viel einfacher nach
einem Problem mit englischer Fehlermeldung
oder englischen Sachen suchen.
Ich suche auch mittlerweile, wenn ich
irgendwas nicht weiß, dann nur noch quasi
mit den englischen Begriffen drauf, weil du einfach
viel mehr und bessere Antworten drauf findest.
Ja gut,
ich muss jetzt ein paar spielen, weil die Originalsprache
in der Regel besser ist.
Du kannst ja in Windows einstellen, habe ich ja hier unten
auch, dass die Sprache Englisch ist, aber
das Keyboard Deutsch.
Das Tastaturlayout habe ich auch
auf Deutsch.
Da komme ich damit nicht klar.
Da brauchst du eine Tastatur, die halt nicht
die richtigen Aufdrucke hat und so.
Dann geht das.
Das hat auch den Vorteil, wenn man sich ein bisschen
damit auseinandersetzt,
ähm
man versteht halt auch alles andere auf Englisch.
Ich meine, ich bin jetzt nicht, also Englisch
reden flüssig kriege ich nicht hin.
Das merke ich immer auf der Gamescom
oder auf irgendwelchen anderen
Veranstaltungen, wo Englisch geredet wird.
Da brauche ich
meistens so ein, zwei Tage für, dann
geht es halbwegs, einfach weil
mir da so komplett die Praxis fehlt drin.
Deswegen stotter ich hier manchmal im
Stream auch rum, aber
verstehen tue ich eigentlich fast alles.
Also ich meine,
alles Normale. Also wenn jetzt da einer
mit Shakespeare oder sowas ankommt,
nein, das verstehe ich auch nicht, aber das ist wie bei uns
mit irgendwelchen Dichtern und Denkern,
die meisten
deutschen Native Speaker verstehen
das auch nicht.
Und die meisten, die Englisch als Muttersprache
haben, werden es auch nicht verstehen.
Max nutzt aber auch ziemlich vieles, was
nicht Open Source ist.
Also wenn es geht, benutze ich eigentlich
am liebsten Open Source Software,
wenn die halt konkurrenzfähig
ist und wenn es für den Bereich was
gibt, ja. Richtung Bildbearbeitung
habe ich halt auch
den Anspruch, dass es für mich einfach
zu bedienen sein muss. Schnell
und ordentlich
funktionieren muss und da gibt es Open Source
technisch nichts. Genauso Videobearbeitung.
Gibt halt vieles.
Ansonsten, Firefox ist
Open Source. Chromium
ist Open Source. Das ist ja nicht mal
ein Chrome, das ist ein Chromium.
Äh, ganze
Terminal, sonst was Zeug
hier ist Open Source.
Git ist Open Source. Gut,
Visual Studio ist nicht Open Source.
Aber Visual Studio ist
zumindest kostenlos mittlerweile.
Äh,
Windows
ist natürlich auch nicht Open Source, ja klar.
Audacity ist
Open Source. Also wenn
es irgendwie geht, verwende ich eigentlich Open Source
Programme. Keepass ist
Open Source. LibreOffice. Ich habe
LibreOffice installiert.
Das ist richtige Woodface.
Äh, Hyper
Screw. Ich habe
LibreOffice.
Thunderbird ist Open Source.
Guck mal hier. Also MacStore ist Open Source.
Bei mir besteht, mein Rechner ist zu 80. OBS ist
Open Source. Also mein Rechner besteht zu 80%
aus Open Source, wenn es nicht gerade Spiele sind, oder?
Candy Crush.
Klar, kannst du auf GitHub. Kannst du dir
angucken. Wo wir gerade bei
Office Programme sind.
Ich bin ein
Fan von
Moment. Wo ist LibreOffice?
Oh.
Ich bin kein Fan.
Weder von LibreOffice,
noch von Microsoft Office.
Übrigens wisst ihr, was das Geile ist?
Wenn man im Store versucht,
wenn man im Store versucht
Office zu kaufen, wahrscheinlich
geht's heute, ja.
Und ich sag jetzt im
Store so, ha, kaufen.
Passt mal auf.
Ach fuck, jetzt geht's.
Ich hab das gestern auch probiert, da ging
die Seite nicht. Aber ich find's schon bezeichnend,
dass man, dass man
im offiziellen Microsoft Store
auf kaufen für eines der
Aushängeschilder von Microsoft Software klickt
oder auf eine Webseite kommt
und nicht über den Store kaufen kann.
Der Store ist aber eh
ein Witz, ja. Also
ich mag weder LibreOffice,
noch mag ich Microsoft
Office oder auch
jede andere Office Software.
Ich bin der Ansicht, man braucht keinen Office.
Braucht keine Office Software.
Die einzige Daseinsberechtigung,
die Office Software hat, ist meiner Ansicht nach
Excel oder Tabellenkalkulation,
wenn man es denn unbedingt haben will.
Wenn man da
scharf drauf ist und Tabellen
kalkulieren möchte,
ja. Ich mein im Prinzip,
wenn man sich's genau überlegt ist, ist ja Excel
eigentlich quasi
ne Programmierumgebung für
Leute, die sagen, sie können nicht
programmieren.
Wobei sie es irgendwie doch können.
Aber Rest
braucht man nicht.
Man braucht kein Office.
Für nix.
Man braucht Outlook nicht,
weil's grad einer geschrieben hat.
Wozu braucht man Outlook?
Man braucht Word
definitiv nicht,
um ordentliche, hübsche
Texte mit
ordentlichem Layout zu basteln.
Man braucht Powerpoint auch garantiert nicht
für Präsentation.
Wie schreib ich Briefe?
In nem Texteditor schreib ich Briefe.
In nem Texteditor.
Dann gibt's die zweite Variante.
Entweder reicht's mir.
Reicht mir Basic Formatierungssachen.
Oder es soll wirklich
quasi
ganz besonders toll sein.
Kannst immer noch mit Latex oder Latex
machen. Ansonsten
nehmt euch nen Texteditor,
irgendeinen
Markdown-Renderer.
Ich nehm jetzt mal exemplarisch
hier mal, ansonsten mach ich das mit nem Texteditor
bei mir drauf. Und dann
schreibt ihr hier euer Markdown.
Und es kommt
genau so raus,
wie ihr das haben wollt im Endeffekt.
Da braucht man kein Word für.
Da kannst du
Bilder einfügen und alles.
Also ich hab jetzt so meinen
x-beliebigen Markdown-Editor genommen.
Ich schreibe 99% meiner Texte in Markdown.
Ich hab...
Ich mach WIM auf.
Schreib den Text rein.
Mach mit Markdown ein paar Formatierungen hin.
Hau das als
HTML oder PDF raus und fertig.
Man braucht kein Word.
Ich hab absolut keinen Anwendungszweck für Word.
Ja, Beatport, es geht ja
auch nicht um die Leute,
sondern es geht ja auch um mich.
Und ich brauch kein Office.
Ich kann auch nicht verstehen, warum man unbedingt
Word verwenden möchte zum Briefe schreiben.
Wer das machen will,
kann das machen. Aber ich bin überhaupt kein Fan
von Office-Produkten. Man braucht's einfach
nicht. Also wenn man
von mir aus geht, ich brauch das nicht.
Ja, die Briefe werden in
Plaintext geschrieben.
Die Briefe werden in Plaintext geschrieben
mit Markdown.
Sonntags.
Dann ist das gut.
Ich mein, guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist die Readme beispielsweise
oder Text
von dem Projekt,
wo wir vorhin verwendet haben für animierte GIFs
in WPF.
Das ist eine Markdown-Datei.
Es kann doch keiner sein,
dass das schlecht aussieht, oder?
Jetzt war
von den Code-Tags außen vor,
die die meisten Leute wahrscheinlich in ihrem Brief
nicht verwenden würden. Aber
das ist,
das sieht doch hübscher aus als jedes
Word-Dokument.
So, und wenn man sich die Datei anguckt,
ist es einfach
ganz normaler, billiger Text.
Bis halt auf die Code-Tags.
Markdown ist das Beste zum Texte schreiben.
Du hast überhaupt keine
Sachen, wo du dich
darauf konzentrieren musst.
Bei Word musst du dir dann permanent überlegen,
muss ich das markieren, muss ich das hier zentrieren,
muss ich sonst was machen.
Markdown schreibst du einfach deinen Text,
machst die Formatierung an die Stelle, wo du willst
und gut ist.
Ich mein, du brauchst ja auch nicht viel an Formatierung.
Was hab ich da angeklickt?
Das kann man alles wunderbar in Markdown schreiben.
Und das sieht doch nicht schlecht aus.
Guck mal, das Ding hier ist komplett in Markdown
geschrieben, die Readme vom Atomeditor.
So, und wenn man sich
anguckt, die Readme,
so, das ist
einfach simpler Text und an
Stellen, wo was formatiert werden soll,
wird halt einfach davor kurz
in Syntax geschrieben, was.
So nach dem Motto Überschrift,
zweite Überschrift,
ne Liste,
nen Link. Das ist doch viel einfacher
als Formatierungsgeschwubbel in Word.
Und vor allem,
du brauchst kein Word dazu, um es zu editieren
und zu lesen. Das ist einfach plain Text.
Man kann
das auch alles in Word machen, ja.
Aber ich brauch das net.
Und ich find's viel umständlicher in Word
zu machen. Und wenn man
jemand erklären kann, das Problem ist halt,
dass die Leute da schon immer
gewisse
so geprägt sind durch Erfahrungen, die sie vorher
gemacht haben, ja. Wie man
halt mit irgendwelchen GUI-Geschichten.
Wenn man jemand zeigen würde,
schreib deine
Überschrift und mach dieses Symbol
davor, dann wird sie fett.
Das versteht der genauso.
Das ist ja nicht, dass man da viel verstehen müsste für.
Mache ein aus,
mache, ja mal irgendwie
einen x-beliebigen Markdown-Editor.
Hallo, ich brauch nen Editor.
Ich mein,
das ist ja nicht schwierig.
Schreibe deine Überschrift,
mache ein,
eine
Raute davor, dann ist sie fett. Mal zwei
Rauten davor, dann sind die nicht mehr so fett. Mal drei Rauten davor, dann sind die nicht mehr so fett.
So, da kann man automatisch noch,
weiß nicht, ob der das kann,
Table of Content generieren, alles mögliche.
Da hast du dann oben drüber dann
die, die, ähm,
Inhaltsverzeichnis automatisch. Es gibt nichts
besseres.
Das kriegt sogar, das würde, das hätte meine
Oma hingekriegt. Hätte ich meiner
Oma gesagt, hier guck mal,
wenn du willst, dass deine Überschrift fett wird,
machst du dieses Zeichen davor,
dann hätte ich dieses Zeichen davor gemacht.
Dann hätte ich dir gesagt, hier willst du deine
Einkaufsliste schreiben, also
plupp, plupp eins,
plupp zwei, dann machst du ein Minus
davor. Das ist doch sogar voll intuitiv
irgendwie. Und dann kriegst du
eine Liste.
Das ist viel intuitiver eigentlich,
wenn man es mal genau überlegt, ist das viel intuitiver
wie Word aufzumachen,
das Ding zu markieren, hier oben
sich irgendwie rauszusuchen,
den Button für, wo mache ich
Liste,
weil es ist ja einfach, du kannst halt auch so
strukturieren, wie du willst.
Die Krönung ist dann noch Emacs mit Org-Mode.
Das ist für die ganz Verrückten dann.
Ja, hier ran ist ja nichts, weil gerade jemand geschrieben hat,
es ist unübersichtlich. Daran ist nichts unübersichtlich.
Weil, es kann nichts
unübersichtlich sein, es ist eins zu eins
den Text, den du
geschrieben hast, ohne was.
Ja, du machst halt
ein Zeichen hier davor und die
Liste ist intuitiv.
Es ist ja im Prinzip zu 99% dein Text.
Das heißt, wenn der unübersichtlich
ist, ist dein Text unübersichtlich.
Das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt, das
TypeScript
Bandreihen für Frau Achter...
Ne, habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Was ist deine Meinung zur Microsoft-Github-Geschichte?
Habe ich schon gesagt, ähm...
Ich sehe da keinen Grund zur Panik, ehrlich gesagt.
Mal gucken, was Microsoft
daraus macht. Twitch ist ja auch nicht
schlechter geworden, seit Amazon es übernommen hat.
Wer wird hier geflayt?
Was, wenn ich jetzt
eine nummerierte Liste haben will und ich
will zwischen
zwei Sachen ein neues Item einfügen,
habe ich Pech gehabt. Hä, wieso?
Kannst du einfach reinschreiben.
Oder rückst du das ein und hast einen Unterpunkt.
Das ist doch total
simpel. Ja.
Kriegst du hinaus.
Ist so. Wobei, das ist jetzt...
Ich habe den erstbesten Markdown-Editor genommen, den
ich gefunden habe.
Tabelle, Tabelle geht auch. Ich weiß nicht, ob das der Editor
hier kann. Tabelle geht auch.
Schön.
Äh, Tabelle geht auch. Ich muss mal kurz gucken,
wie das richtige Layout dazu ist.
Und vor allem, ob das der Editor
kann. Normalerweise schreibe
ich meinen Text im
WIM
und rendere es mir dann halt als Markdown raus.
Äh,
kann der das?
Ja, Tabelle.
Das Schöne ist halt, dass das...
Ja, Markdown wird auch auf Twitch verwendet.
Das Schöne ist halt, dass du
quasi eins zu eins den Kram
im Plaintext stehen
hast und es nur ein bisschen formatiert wird.
Klar, du kannst auch Bilder und Grafiken
einfügen.
Der Editor ist jetzt ein bisschen blöd.
Du hast halt hier überhaupt keine...
Hilfen irgendwie, ne?
Aber mir im WIM
hab ich so eingerichtet, dass ich mir noch so
Spickzettel einblenden kann, falls man doch mal
irgendwas nicht weiß. Äh...
Ich stell mal eins, dass ich einen funktionierenden
Link hab.
Und ist da eins drin?
Links und Images sind auch
relativ simpel.
Was der hier nicht kann oder
das Bild nicht da ist. Kann auch sein.
Moment.
Das ist auch das Falsche.
Ach ne, Reference da jetzt so rum.
Machst ein Bild rein.
Die... Doch!
Ich find die Tabelle ist intuitiver als in
Office, zumindest für kleine Sachen.
Ja, ich würd jetzt...
Ich schreib sogar meine Rechnung
in Markdown. Wobei das stimmt
nicht. Ich schreib meine Rechnung in Org Mode
in Emacs, aber ähm...
Das ist quasi... Das ist fast
Markdown. Das ist relativ ähnlich.
Da kann man
in der Tabelle dann auch das
direkt als Tabelle verwenden. Aber für
einfache Sachen ist das doch super.
Ich find das hier... Das ist
3000fach einfacher als
das in Word zu machen.
Ja, aber Tabellen sind sowas...
Wenn du da mehr als 3-4 Zeilen hast,
ist das in Markdown scheiße.
Das ist nicht... Das ist nicht schön.
Aber wenn man
einen ordentlichen Editor hat, der kann das auch für
ein... ähm...
einrücken und so. Das ist jetzt ja irgendein
Webding. Hab ich auch noch nicht verwendet
hier. Äh... BeatPro, das kommt halt
auf den Editor an, ob der das kann.
Ja? Das kommt... Das kommt auf den
Editor an, ob der das kann.
Letztendlich, das Entscheidende ist ja, dass es...
Das... Dein Editor
kann dir immer noch helfen, indem er erkennt,
ah, das ist eigentlich ne Liste. Ähm...
Aber das Entscheidende ist ja, dass
es nach wie vor Plaintext ist. Also du kannst
das überall editieren. Du kannst das auch
super irgendwie bei Dropbox ablegen oder so.
Du kannst das überall
mit allem öffnen. Auf jeder Plattform.
Natürlich hat... Das hat alles
auch seine Fallstricke.
Das ist jetzt nicht der
Weisheitsletzter Schluss.
Aber für einfache Sachen, was...
Und 99% der Sachen
sind halt simple...
simple Sachen. Ich mein, was enthält
denn das 0815-Dokument,
was du hauptsächlich schreibst, ja?
Das ist ein bisschen bla bla bla.
Das ist Adresse. Das ist ein bisschen
formelles bla bla bla. Sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren. Bla bla bla bla. Dann
kommen vielleicht mal 2-3 Zeilen mit Zahlen
drinne. Vielleicht kommt noch
irgendein Logo rein und dann kommt mit freundlichen Grüßen
fertig. Das war's.
Das... Das besteht aus 20
Zeilen oder so. Dafür ist das
für mich
um Längen einfacher als
irgendwelche... Als dein Word irgendwas
zu machen. In was du dann
speicherst...
Gar nicht. Als Text.
Du speicherst das als Text.
Also für dich. Zum...
Zum editieren.
Das, was derjenige kriegt...
Also, ne? Du meinst ja quasi, dass...
Für den du den Brief
schreibst,
dem entweder als HTML,
falls es eine Webseite ist,
oder als PDF.
Kann Markdown sowas wie Text alignen?
Das kommt auf den Editor an.
Markdown selbst ist ja quasi nur
ein bisschen Aufsatz auf
Plain Text.
Der zum Beispiel sagt, hey,
wenn eine Raute davor ist, dann soll das
als Überschrift implementiert werden.
Die Hilfen beim Editieren,
muss halt dein Editor oder dein Markdown plug-in
können.
Und nachdem jeder gescheite Texteditor
Text alignen kann,
geht das damit dann natürlich auch.
Kannst du das auch direkt in der
Mail schreiben?
Naja...
Es gibt für...
Es gibt glaube ich für Chrome
sogar ein Add-on.
Genau.
Es gibt sogar ein extra Add-on für Chrome.
Da kannst du quasi in jedem Text
Feld irgendwie Markdown schreiben und dann
rendern.
Aber in Mails würde ich das gar nicht so
schreiben. Wenn man wirklich noch Mails
schreibt, dann würde ich Mails
eigentlich immer als reinen Text
schreiben. Ich würde Mails auch nicht
HTML formatieren oder sowas.
Weil ich habe beispielsweise mein
Mail-Programm so eingestellt,
dass es Mails als reinen Text anzeigt.
Das hat auch den großen Vorteil,
sollte es mal irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken
geben oder irgendwelches Gedöns, was ausgenutzt
wird in Mails. Wenn du deine Mail
rein als Text anzeigen lässt,
da bist du schon mal von 99% der Sachen da
bist du sicher vor.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also was NIM4 schreibt
für Unternehmer,
je nachdem wie man das viel ausspricht.
Wenn du Layout-Sachen machen willst,
dafür ist Markdown nix.
Aber das wollen die meisten Leute gar nicht.
Die meisten Leute wollen einfach nur irgendwie...
Jetzt ist es bei mir so.
Und das, was ich da sehe, was die meisten Leute
hinklatschen, gehe ich mal davon aus, dass das auch so ist.
Die wollen irgendwie einen Text da hinbringen,
dass man da noch ein bisschen sowas wie
eine Überschrift machen und fertig ist.
Wenn du jetzt die Geburtstagseinladung
für
deine
Diamant-Hochzeit
machen willst, ja,
als Rentner,
und da irgendwie Bildchen schön anordnen möchte
oder sonst was,
und er halt Office installiert hat,
klar soll er das mit Word machen.
Ne, also...
Achso, jetzt weiß ich, was du meinst.
Ne, ne, in Markdown kannst du nicht...
Es gibt relativ wenige Layout-Geschichten.
Also du kannst
weder was rechts zentrieren noch links zentrieren.
Zumindest nicht mit Markdown selbst.
Aber jedes
HTML-Element ist ja gültig
in Markdown. Also du kannst in Markdown auch HTML schreiben.
Du kannst natürlich hier drinnen machen,
also sofern das dieser komische Editor hier
kann, müssen wir mal gucken.
Du kannst natürlich schon sagen, bla bla bla,
center.
Ah, das funktioniert. Und der escaped HTML.
Okay, bei dem funktioniert das nicht.
Aber, ähm...
Du darfst in Markdown
jegliches
HTML schreiben, was du willst.
Also da kannst du natürlich auch zentrieren,
dass das klappt.
Aber es geht bei Markdown, also
die Idee dahinter ist ja, dass du da gar nicht,
dass du einfach schreiben kannst, ohne dir
großartig Gedanken zu machen.
Du schreibst einfach deinen Text
runter, ohne dass du dich drum kümmern musst,
quasi, ähm,
um Formatierungsgeschichten,
dass du dich nicht quasi 3000 mal ablenken lässt
für, ich kann das jetzt noch 3 Pixel weiter
rechts machen, oder sowas.
Sondern dass du einfach deinen Text runter schreibst,
und es am Ende dann trotzdem noch ganz gut ausschaut.
Und ich finde, das sieht auch, das sieht schon
ansprechend aus mit dem passenden
Theme dabei.
Ab jetzt Rechnung in Nordpalt++
schreiben. Wie gesagt, ich schreib meine
Rechnung, wenn ich denn mal welche schreibe,
ähm,
die schreibe ich nur so. Nur,
da ist hier oben ein bisschen bla bla,
bla bla bla bla,
ähm, da kommen zwei Zeilen mit, äh,
um was es geht,
mit irgendeinem Betrag drunter,
dann, dann
meistens auch irgendwie sowas wie,
wir bedanken uns für Ihren Auftrag, oder irgendwie so plötze.
Ne, es ist auch
keine Alternative zu Word.
Wenn du, wenn du quasi den kompletten,
wenn du, also, wenn es dir um den kompletten
Funktionsumfang geht, nicht, natürlich kann Word
mehr. Bloß brauchen 99%
der Leute überhaupt
nicht das, was Word kann, und
in 99% ihrer Dokumente
benutzen sie es auch gar nicht.
Oder,
wenn sie es benutzen, dann vielleicht
einfach nur, weil es
geht. Obwohl sie es eigentlich
gar nicht so wirklich in dem, in
dieser Form haben wollen, oder brauchen.
Und sie vielleicht mit
sowas viel glücklicher werden. Also wie
gesagt, ich hab seit Jahren kein Office
mehr verwendet.
Ich hab mich richtig erschreckt, dass
ich es überhaupt drauf hab.
Präsentation mach ich auch in Markdown.
Präsentation mach ich in Markdown
und als PDF. So.
Und dann machst du PDF als
Fullscreen, jeweils
eine Seite anzeigen, und dann kannst du einfach immer
schön Next drücken.
Und dann ist das wie Powerpoint, bloß, dass ich finde,
dass es sogar noch schicker aussieht.
Du kannst keine Sounds machen, du kannst keine ultra krassen
Animationen machen, aber das brauchst du eh nicht in der Präsentation.
Kannst du mich auf Twitter
anblockieren? Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Wie heißt du denn auf Twitter?
Ich hab mich bisschen rumgeraged, durchgeblockt.
Keine Ahnung, kann der sein?
Moin Salami-Prinz.
So, 0 Uhr 3.
Wann haben wir angefangen?
Ah,
Uptime.
Haha, viereinhalb Stunden.
Null.
Ich hab gesagt, als wir live waren, das machen wir
jetzt schnell und dann ist gut.
Im Prinzip
sitzen wir ja auch schon wieder zwei Stunden rum und labern
und machen nix. Wir sind ja fertig.
Wir sind ja fertig. Wir haben wenigstens
diesmal die Sache fertig gebastelt.
Sigh.
So. Ja, ich hab ja auch am Anfang noch irgendwie sowas
gesagt. Ah, das geht schnell, wieder ein kurzer Stream
oder Episodes.
Aber warum hatte ich heute eigentlich so viele
Zuschauer?
Ich mein, ich hab, ich hab, es ist
nach 0 Uhr und ich hab immer noch
113.
Ich hatte im Durchschnitt irgendwie 150,
teilweise 180, 90
bei, ich hab Wuschel Studio
und bastel ein bisschen rum.
So viel hatte ich glaube ich noch nie.
Lustig.
Null.
Alter.
MonkaS.
So. Ich werde jetzt gleich
pennen gehen.
Und ich guck mir da noch
ein bisschen A Link to the Past Speedruns
an, wenn ich im Bett bin. Ich find, da kann man
sogar bei einschlafen.
Es gibt irgendwie gerade so ein
Speedrun
Turnier, wo sie
A Link to the Past spielen mit
zufällig verteilten Items.
Das ist
mega verwirrend anzugucken.
Und
übelst Resident Sleeper, wenn man's
im Bett guckt.
Aber guck mal, unser Meme Tool funktioniert schon
gut, muss man sagen, oder?
Und ich muss ja sagen,
die beste Funktion ist ja
unbeabsichtigt reingekommen, dass man quasi
0.3D auch noch anders
robotieren kann.
24 Stunden JavaScript ganz bestimmt nicht.
Was? 200 MB?
Auf 200 MB.
Braucht das?
Ja gut, wahrscheinlich
wegen den ganzen Bildern, ne?
Und weil er erstmal
alles mögliche cached.
Hohoho, der braucht RAM!
MonkaS!
Ich clear das ja auch nirgendswo
wieder, ne? Ich mach da Bitmap und gut
Bitmap und
Bitmap und ja.
Das GIF braucht dafür kaum
RAM. Jetzt hat der Garbage
Collector mal ein bisschen Collected zur Abwechslung.
Jetzt geht's wieder hoch.
Ah ja, ist doch okay.
Ich hab genug RAM.
Der ist nicht schlecht.
Ich mein, du hast halt
du hast ja auch gar nicht so großartige Chancen,
ne? Du kannst es hier nicht mal
zwischendrin dir selbst freigeben großartig.
Oder du schmeißt halt von Hand
nen Garbage Collector an.
Wozu auch? Ich bin drauf geschissen, ja.
Und dagegen, dass quasi
das Bild so viel RAM frisst, kann ich nix machen.
Wenn das intern
halt bei der Verwaltung so viel braucht.
Wir könnten ja in ein...
Wir könnten ja in einem der nächsten Streams
Ja, ja, darfst du.
Darfst du den C-Sharp, darfst du
Garbage Collector von Hand triggern.
Ich mein, es wird nicht
empfohlen oder so. Kannste machen.
Kannste, kannste machen.
Bam.
Sollte man aber nicht unbedingt machen.
Sei denn, es gibt nen Grund für
ähm
Wir könnten das gleiche Programm noch mal
in Qt machen das nächste Mal.
Aber ich fürchte
mal, auch wenn
das C++ ist,
das wird gar nicht mal
so viel weniger RAM Auslastung haben.
Weil ich mein,
die Bilder, vor allem
das MonkaS Bild
liegt ja letztendlich
irgendwie als Bitmap im RAM rum.
Mit seinen
5000 mal sonst was
Auflösungen.
Das braucht halt einfach ein bisschen Speicher.
Ja, und wenn wir das in Qt machen,
machen wir das ja in QML, sprich da läuft dann auch noch ein bisschen
JavaScript Geduldens im Hintergrund.
Das wird auch nicht so viel
kleiner sein.
Was, beim Mirror's Edge
Timeline-Kollege hat einen neuen Rekord? Nice.
Hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Warum hat das
so eine hohe Auflösung?
Weil das Bild so eine hohe Auflösung hatte, weil ich runtergeladen hab.
Meinst du, ich hab das verkleinert oder was?
Ne, ne, ne.
Das ist aber so
mit
Hätten wir das in Windows Forms gemacht und dafür dann
wirkliche Transparenz-Effekte gehabt,
hätte das auch noch mal eine ganze Ecke weniger
gebraucht. Aber die Kombination aus
WPF
was sich Bitmaps im Rahmen und so, das braucht halt
ein bisschen was. Kannste nix machen.
Überlegt, hätten
wir das mit Elektron gemacht, ich sag's
euch, das Programm hätte 500 MB
gebraucht.
Und hätte Probleme mit Transparenz im Fenster
ein- und ausblenden gehabt.
So.
Jemand eine Idee, wen wir hosten können?
Wir könnten den Kamikaze hosten,
was macht der denn?
Kamikaze ist es ja.
Oh ne, da spielt's ein
ein komisches
GTA 5 Roleplay Zeug.
Damit kann ich ja überhaupt nichts anfangen.
GTA Roleplay, da kann ich
überhaupt nichts mit anfangen.
Wen können wir denn hosten?
Lass mal Hottest Gaming Grill hosten.
Was haben wir denn da so?
Was, was haben wir denn da so?
Was gibt's denn da so?
Guck mal mal.
Wen hosten wir?
Erstmal einstellen auf
Deutsch.
Das war schon mal, da haben wir schon mal
die Auswahl kleiner.
Symmetra Main. Nein.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Kenn ich alle nicht.
Sagt mir alles gar nix.
Okay, ähm.
Wen haben wir denn da bei?
Kann man hier, hier kann man
natürlich nicht Language einstellen.
Talkshows, wen gibt's
denn da? Mit den meisten
Sachen, weil ich's grad gesehen hab,
mit den meisten Sachen kann ich
programmtechnisch, was
bei den Rocket Beans läuft, irgendwie nix
anfangen. Ich weiß auch
net. Das, das wird
jetzt, nix gegen
die Leute, ja, muss ich auch dazu
sagen. Ich kann
vom Inhalt her irgendwie damit
wenig anfangen. Ist einfach nicht so
mein Geschmack. Das wird übertrieben gelobt
überall.
Hab auch irgendwelche Preise gewonnen und sonst.
Was'n des?
Eeeeh.
Ich hab jetzt grad, das ist Fortnite,
aber es ist nicht Fortnite.
Äh.
Es ist
Random Battle Royale 3.0
oder was ist das?
Der Biberboy ist am Start.
So.
Wir können den Biberboy,
wir können den, ja.
Was, was ist das für,
das sieht ja schon wieder, okay,
was spielt's denn?
Das,
also wenn des nicht Fortnite inspiriert ist,
dann weiß ich auch net.
Oh, so viel Battle Royale Crap.
Ist ja schlimm. Was macht
eigentlich, wo wir grad dabei sind, wie geht's
eigentlich H1Z1
so? Für ein neuer
Battle Royale Ausschiss.
Ja, das trifft's ganz gut.
Was? Loli-chan.
Der Name allein, okay, gucken wir mal.
Da können wir Gamer
Grill hosten.
Wow, ich dachte,
ich dachte grade, ich muss instant
den Tab zumachen, weil ich irgendwie
die Pose falsch,
falsch,
ah, Schock.
Gleich gibt's Bann.
Hat die Pose falsch interpretiert, so im ersten Blick.
Ähm.
Was macht eigentlich H1Z1 so?
Spielt keine Sau mehr, okay, gut zu wissen.
Tossmocker ist,
äh, tryhard7.
Oh nee, ganz schlimm.
Wurde ja letztens gebannt.
Overwatch, äh, Overwatch League hier.
Weil ich, was hab ich, was hab ich,
ich glaub, ich hab Command,
Command Brew,
Command Bruh, Bruh, Emote
verwendet. Toss gleich, gleich mal
halbe Stunde Timeout.
Der YouTube-Stream, der im Hintergrund läuft,
äh, da.
Chill your mind. Beautiful, relaxing
Chill-Step-Mix, 3 Stunden.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, bin ich...
Ist das der Mashed oder so, ist der am Start?
Ah nee,
der ist, der ist ja irgendwo hingeflogen.
Der Lost ist auch nicht am Start.
Ja, wie, pff.
Kennen Sie irgendwie,
okay, wer ist da von meinen Abos?
Wen hab ich denn, wo ich auf dem anderen Bildschirm
komme, wo haben meine Abos, wer ist denn da am Start?
Follow Grubby.
Warcraft 3.
So mit mein Lieblings-Streamer
eigentlich.
Bist leider kein Battlefield-Insider mehr.
Tja.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es nicht schlimm,
ich hab mich eh irgendwie so um so ziemlich alle Sachen
immer gedrückt.
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin, ich bin niemand für
Offline-Gaming-Events.
Ich hab da,
ich hab da meistens überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Nach diesem Reinfall-Event
da in, in Berlin
zu Battlefield,
also zu Battlefield 1,
da haben sie uns ja im Vorfeld erzählt,
ähm, wir kriegen
quasi USB-Sticks mit,
mit, äh,
mit Trailer und Material und allem.
Und sind pünktlich fertig
und alles, also sprich, das hat sich so angehört,
als hat man sogar irgendwie einen Vorteil
dadurch, ja, also sprich,
zumindest keinen Nachteil.
Am Endeffekt waren wir dann später
an einem Notebook, um was machen zu können,
also gerade später im Hotel wieder,
und der USB-Stick, der hat es nicht gegeben, also sprich,
wir hatten nicht mal Material, was wir drunter legen können.
Das heißt, jeder, der daheim gesessen hat,
ähm, vom Livestream zwei Minuten
mitgeschnitten hat und was dazu erzählt hat,
konnte
alles und fast besseres Video machen,
als wir, die da gewesen sind.
Da hab ich auch danach, äh,
danach hat Dings hier, der
der
Mitre, Daniel Mitre,
oder wie er hieß, der damalige Community Manager,
hat dann auch so rumgeschrieben,
danach so, ja,
ähm, irgendwie
war ja alles ganz toll und so, ob wir
Feedback haben, hab ich mir gedacht,
okay, bist du mal nett, schreibst du mal ehrliches Feedback,
hab ich halt geschrieben,
ähm, dass ich das halt irgendwie
das Event schon ganz cool fand,
aber es halt
im Endeffekt,
trotz, dass das Event so cool war, es hatte halt
nur Nachteile für Leute,
die da gewesen sind, wenn's um
Videoproduktion geht.
Und das hat er auch, hat er auch
eingesehen, da wollten
sie mich dann nach, nach, nach, ähm,
weiß gar nicht, wo die sind, irgendwo
in die USA einladen, das hab ich dann
voll krass noch gedodged.
Ich hab da keinen Bock, ich hab erstens
keinen Bock in die USA zu fahren und zweitens bin ich nicht für
Offline-Events
irgendwie, aber zumindest
hab ich den Lost noch, dann
haben wir so irgendwie,
haben wir das noch so hingedreht,
dass der Lost dann für mich hinfahren kann,
dann war die ganze Sache, hatte wenigstens einer was von.
Max wird Cod-Insider.
Nee, der meinte das mit
Einladen wirklich ernst, ne, weil
es ist, es ist so, dass auf diese,
auf diese Feedback-Anfragen die meisten
Leute, ich weiß auch nicht warum,
ähm, da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen
ausrollen, ist scheiß drauf, wir haben jetzt zwar schon halb eins
aber drauf geschaut, ähm, ich hab so
den Eindruck, dass die meisten
Leute,
ähm,
es gibt, es gibt, es gibt da so zwei Sachen,
wenn, wenn du so größere YouTuber
und, und Streamer einlädst. Du hast
einmal die, die finden sich von Haus
aus so unglaublich geil, dass das eigentlich
scheißegal ist, was du erzählst.
Die, die, die finden sich, die sehen
alles wurscht, die finden sich, finden sich wahnsinnig geil.
Oder du lädst welche
ein, die,
die, die bilden sich dann unglaublich was
drauf ein und finden, finden sich dann
dadurch, dass sie eingeladen werden, halt geil
und dementsprechend sagen die halt auch überhaupt
nichts Negatives und nichts, was ihnen
irgendwie daran
nicht gefallen hat oder was man verbessern
konnte, nichts. Die, das sind dann die Leute, die
quasi nach einem Event erstmal
drei Stunden twittern, so nach dem Motto,
ähm, greatest
event of all time und
ja und mega und super und
und alles geil, so. Aber
es, ich krieg,
ich hab das selten irgendwie gesehen, dass
das sinnvoll, da mal einer was
gesagt hat zu.
Also, wenn jemand gefragt wird,
sagt jemand, ja okay, hier
was denkt ihr denn, ähm,
das sagt kaum
einer was sinnvolles.
Und ich glaube, der fand das wirklich nicht schlecht,
dass ich ihm gesagt hab, dass ich's doof fand,
dass ich das quasi für Leute, die Videos produziert
haben und deswegen hingekommen sind, überhaupt nicht gelohnt
hat und man quasi im Nachteil
war gegenüber denjenigen, die daheim
geblieben sind und Stream geguckt haben.
Weil das ist ja, wenn man sich mal überlegt, wenn der
die Events organisiert,
dann ist das für den eine Information,
die ist schon nicht schlecht.
Weil ich mein,
der denkt halt sonst, alles geil,
super, best ever und kriegt von
allen dann noch erzählt, so nach dem Motto,
greatest event of all time und wir sind so
quasi so dankbar, dass wir dabei sein durften
und wow, ist das super. Und in Wirklichkeit
war's kacke.
So, und das muss man, man muss
ja nicht sagen, war alles scheiß, aber
ich glaub, der fand das halt nicht schlecht.
Dass man einfach
gesagt hat, dass man das nicht so toll fand.
Ja, und von denen, die sich so geil
und star-mäßig fühlen, von denen kriegst
du natürlich auch kein ordentliches Feedback.
Man kann generell
mit, ähm, ordentlich
ausgedrücktem Feedback
hab ich zumindest den Eindruck, da
doch noch bei vielen Leuten durchdringen.
Weil die das einfach sonst nicht kriegen.
Man muss immer,
sag mal, es ist bescheuert zu sagen,
so nach dem Motto, boah, ey,
kacke Event, äh, so, lern deinen
Job, boah, du bist so scheiße.
Das hört natürlich keiner gerne, ja,
wenn du, wenn du sagst, okay, das war, an sich war das cool,
es war auch mal nett, dass man die Leute wieder gesehen hat, aber
letztendlich war man, wenn man halt einfach sagt,
was das eigentliche Problem war, nämlich, dass man
im Nachteil war gegenüber einem, der daheim gehockt hat
und Livestream gesessen hat, dann sagt der, okay,
ha, gut zu wissen,
weil genau das wollten wir damit nicht erreichen.
Und dann,
das wird ja nicht schlecht.
Denkst du,
es wird Auswirkungen haben, dass ein Github von Microsoft
gekauft wurde?
Muss ich zeigen.
Ja, weil das ist geschehen wird,
du bist halt real. Dieses Wort real
ist, das ist das overusedeste
auf YouTube
mittlerweile schlechthin, ja.
Alle sind so ganz, ganz real
und dazu ihren Fans
natürlich, ja.
Ich glaube, es ist keiner
wirklich real auf YouTube.
Ich bin im Endeffekt ja auch nicht real.
Sobald du irgendwo dich da vorsetzt,
ja, und weißt, dass dir jetzt
mehrere Leute zuhören,
du wirst dich selbstverständlich anders
benehmen, wie
wenn dir keine
20.000 Leute zuhören.
Ich denke, man sollte mit
allen halt irgendwie relativ normal umgehen.
Wenn einem irgendwas nicht passt, musst
du dir nicht flamen, du sagst dem halt einfach,
was dir nicht gefallen hat
und da hat
eigentlich kaum einer ein Problem mit, vor allem nicht von denen,
die irgendwelche Sachen organisieren.
Die finden das meistens gut.
Klar, es gibt immer Leute, die sind merkwürdig
und wollen es nicht hören, aber pff.
Aber ich finde es genauso bescheuert, was halt auch viele machen,
das ist vor allem früher,
dass die bei allem so extrem
in den Arsch gekrochen sind, immer für jeden Scheiß
und nach dem Motto, oh, hier
kriegst du eine Tastatur und alle, oh mein Gott,
ich krieg eine kostenlose Tastatur, die ich meinen
150.000 Leuten zeigen kann,
boah, ist das geil, ey.
Irgendwie quasi die Tastatur
oder sonst was über
alles loben, als wäre das die grandioseste
Tastatur aller Zeiten.
Quasi nur so aus Dankbarkeit,
weil sie mal jetzt eine
kostenlose Tastatur gekriegt haben
und vor allem
selbst teilweise gar nicht
realisieren, was sie eigentlich da für eine riesen
Gegenleistung erbringen.
Das ist vielen auch gar nicht so klar, vor allem am Anfang nicht.
Die denken sich, oh geil, ich krieg was
kostenlos, Wahnsinn, super,
ähm, aber dass die quasi dort
ein riesen Publikum
von Appel und Ei quasi gekriegt
haben, das dauert eine Weile,
bis sich das bei den meisten Leuten gesetzt hat.
Problem an YouTube heutzutage,
das Durchschnittsalter ist ca.
14, das Angebot ist natürlich daran angepasst.
Naja, das hat sich ja angedeutet, da sich das
dorthin entwickelt und ich glaube,
das Durchschnittsalter
also im Gaming-Segment
ist schon gefallen,
aber es ist gar nicht so extrem.
Ähm, es sind
einfach, also ich, nee, ich glaube
gar nicht mal, dass das Durchschnittsalter so viel,
so viel gesunken ist, ein bisschen, ja,
okay, ähm,
also die Leute sind einfach dümmer.
So, so wie, äh,
ganz, äh, einfach, ich sag's jetzt mal, wie,
also, die Leute sind einfach dümmer
heute auf YouTube.
Aber das ist immer so, umso bald,
umso mainstreamiger was wird,
umso mehr kommen die blöden Leute.
Das ist überall so.
Die Leute sind einfach dümmer heute auf YouTube.
Und auf Twitch werden sie auch immer dümmer.
Wie ist denn dein Durchschnittsalter?
Ich weiß es,
keine Ahnung, weiß ich, ich hab ewig nicht mehr geguckt.
Aber es ist nicht die, es ist
nicht 13 bis 18,
das ist die Gruppe drüber.
Die Leute werden einfach dümmer.
Also auf der Plattform, die Leute waren schon immer,
die waren alle schon gleich dumm, aber die waren halt nicht auf YouTube.
Beziehungsweise nicht auf Twitch.
Auf Twitch geht's noch.
Auf Twitch ist es nicht so schlimm.
Twitch hat es geschafft, dass es quasi noch so
ein eigenes, äh, so irgendwie
so ein eigenes Ökosystem irgendwie ist.
So mit den Chat-Memes,
mit dem Chat und so.
Die Leute
übelst verarscht ja irgendwie im Chat.
Ähm,
YouTube ist was anderes.
Vor allem kriegt halt auch auf YouTube dann
der größte Depp noch erzählt, wie geil er ist,
nur weil er jetzt dieses Video geguckt hat.
Oder er macht dann irgendwie,
da gibt's jetzt ja auch diese,
du wirst nicht glauben, was als nächstes passiert,
wenn du diese 21 Sachen richtig legst,
kannst du FBI-Agent werden.
Diese komischen Videos da.
Da bilden sich Leute dann natürlich auch noch wahnsinnig
was drauf ein. Die gucken sich dann ein Video an
mit irgendwie 21, äh, 21 Bildchen
und liegen dann
bei den meisten Sachen richtig,
weil die Dinger sind ja auch zum größten Teil nicht
irgendwie besonders schwer.
Und, ähm, liegen sie dann richtig
und am Ende denken sie sich, boah, geil, ey.
Boah, ey, ich bin voll schlau.
Ich kenn mich ja, ich bin der Wahnsinn.
Nur weil sie sich irgendein Video angeguckt haben.
Aber es gibt auf YouTube auch
vieles gutes Zeug. Muss man auch sagen.
Es ist, es geht halt ein bisschen unter
in dem Scheiß.
Oder zumindest für mich.
Nennen wir es mal nicht Scheiß.
Nennen wir es mal das, wo ich einfach halt überhaupt nicht
die Zielgruppe für bin.
Oder es mich überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Ja, genau, Informatik.
Genau wie bei den IQ-Tests, wo jeder 150 plus hat.
Ich hab letztens auch so morgens mal wieder einen durchgeklickt.
Da ging's irgendwie, das war irgendein Test so,
kennst du die Hauptstadt von diesen Ländern?
Und das war wirklich so total bescheuert.
So nach dem Motto,
ähm, was ist die Hauptstadt von Deutschland?
Ähm,
Hongkong oder Berlin?
So in der Richtung war das.
Das heißt, das war, das war nicht so
nach dem Motto, was ist die Hauptstadt von Deutschland? München oder Berlin?
Ich mein, klar, als Deutsch,
wir wissen das, hoffe ich,
zumindest die meisten, aber
für Ausländer, also für andere Länder.
Ja, also
wenn jetzt irgendjemand
den Test macht, der halt nicht aus Deutschland kommt
oder von ein bisschen weiter weg, der hat wahrscheinlich seine Probleme.
Der sagt, München kenn ich, Berlin kenn ich,
weiß ich nicht genau. Aber das war halt so
ein Test in Form von, was ist es, München oder
äh, Berlin oder Hongkong?
Und da sagt jeder, es ist Berlin, klar, was sonst?
So, und am Ende kam dann raus bei diesem
IQ-Test irgendwie, was
stand drinne? Äh, sie haben ein IQ
von mindestens 151
und, ähm, sie können ein
irgendwie
wegweisender Wissenschaftler
oder bahnbrechender Künstler werden, oder sowas.
Ich meinte, okay, das haben die
daraus jetzt geschlossen, dass ich quasi 21
mal die Hauptstadt richtig geraten hab.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Außerdem ist es ja auch schon lange Zeit
äh, umstritten, inwieweit
es diesen IQ-Wert
an sich überhaupt gibt, beziehungsweise
ähm, wie man
das überhaupt richtig messen kann.
Ja, mittlerweile sind es ja so weit,
die sagen ja, okay, ähm, nur weil
du in einem Bereich ziemlich gut bist, heißt das
noch lange nicht, dass du in einem anderen Bereich genauso gut bist.
Ähm,
das ist ja plötzlich...
Ja, aber das ist echt
ein Problem. Die Leute sind halt im Durchschnitt
einfach dümmer geworden
und das Alter hat sich gar nicht so sehr geändert, glaube ich.
Da sind halt
viel mehr Deppen da.
Aber klar, umso mainstreamiger
das Ganze wird, ist ganz normal und
das ist halt auch eine Sache, die mir auf den Keks geht,
jetzt allgemein, dadurch, dass die Sachen
immer mainstreamiger werden, werden
auch viele Programme, Dienste,
Services, Funktionen beraubt,
weil man sich denkt, ey, diese Funktion ist zu
komplex für den normalen
Benutzer, der verwirrt den normalen Benutzer,
nur wir bauen sie aus.
Das nervt mich bei vielen Diensten, ja.
Also man sieht es an ganz vielen Ecken und Enden,
dass, wie gesagt, Dienste, Programme, Services, was auch immer,
die werden
total ver...
ver... fällt mir kein Wort zu ein,
veridiotet irgendwie.
Guckt euch mal
Windows 10 Mail an
und guckt euch mal,
keine Ahnung, Outlook Express
von Windows XP an.
Outlook Express war das deutlich umfangreichere
Mail, bessere Mail-Programm.
Das Windows 10 Mail-Programm,
das mag vielleicht ein bisschen schöner aussehen,
aber vom Funktionsumfang her ist es
der allerletzte Scheiß.
Dazu kommt noch, weil es auch gerade einer geschrieben hat
im Chat, dazu kommt noch,
dass man ja noch nicht mal
erwarten kann,
quasi von den Leuten,
also die Dienste erwarten das noch nicht mal mehr,
von den Besuchern, dass sie in der
Lage sind,
die Sachen selbst einzuordnen,
was ihnen gefällt,
beziehungsweise was sie sehen wollen,
sondern, dass der Dienst, oder
der jeweilige Service für die User macht.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt 300
Leute abonniert habe,
gefollowt habe, was auch immer,
liked, ist egal welche Plattform,
und ich will einfach nur sehen,
was die Leute
gepostet haben, in der Reihenfolge,
wie sie das gepostet haben,
wird es auf den meisten Seiten
zunehmend schwieriger, das zu sehen,
beziehungsweise überhaupt nicht mehr möglich.
Windows-Einstellung, genau das,
was wir uns vorher angeguckt haben.
Dieser Craft,
ich meine,
warum gehen eigentlich meine Fenster
nicht mehr,
dieser, dieser,
äh,
ich meine,
ich habe nichts gegen das Design von dem Ding,
er sieht ja so noch irgendwie ganz nett aus,
aber, dass du
kein Keyboard-Layout mehr so einfach einstellen
kannst, warum denn nicht?
Wo ist das Problem?
Ist man
heutzutage schon Power-User,
oder was, weil man sein Keyboard-Layout
ändern will?
Ja, genau, chronologische Timelines,
das ist...
Gut, Twitter hat sich ja da ein bisschen,
das geht ja mittlerweile wieder,
YouTube experimentiert ja auch
mit, ähm, quasi
nicht mehr
Synchronen, irgendwie nicht mehr
Timeline-Abo-Box,
aber an den YouTube-Apps sieht man
das auch wunderbar.
Ich weiß nicht, wer von euch die
Android-TV-YouTube-App
kennt. Die wurde
glaube ich innerhalb der letzten zwei Jahre
drei bis vier Mal komplett umgestrickt.
Und ich habe es bis heute nicht
gecheckt, wie ich bei der neuesten
Version, die gibt es jetzt auch schon wieder eine Weile mit dem
Layout, wie ich bei der neuesten
Version auf der
Android-TV-App
ein Video in meine Playlist, beziehungsweise
in später Ansehen hinzufügen
kann.
Ich will nicht ausschließen, dass das
geht. Ich finde es nett.
Ich finde es einfach nett.
Und ich glaube,
dass es die Funktion einfach nicht gibt, weil sich
irgendeiner gedacht hat, naja,
also, mehr als
fünf Buttons unter diesem Video können
wir ja dem normalen User jetzt nicht zumuten.
Ja, okay, aber wir
haben acht Buttons. Ja, dann lass mal
die Sachen für Playlisten rausschmeißen,
die Sachen für Disliken rausschmeißen
und irgendwie die Sachen für
was auch immer noch, äh,
Qualitätsoptionen. Ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen,
ich weiß nicht, auf welcher
Plattform es war, das könnte, das könnte
sogar die, das könnte sogar die Android,
die, das war die Android TV App.
Du konntest nicht mal Qualitätssettings
bei einem Video einstellen für, in der YouTube
App. Du konntest nicht mal mehr
einstellen, ob du das jetzt
in 480p
oder in 1080p gucken willst.
Das geht nicht. Das ging erst wieder seit der letzten
Version. Da hat sich auch einer gedacht, ah ja, also,
diese technischen, hochkomplizierten
Angaben der Auflösung,
das verwirrt den normalen Benutzer.
Das müssen wir unbedingt rausnehmen, ja.
Und außerdem, mehr als fünf Buttons gehen da eh nicht.
Das ist das, was mich nervt.
Dass quasi das Zeug,
Software, die mal was konnte,
immer bescheuerter gemacht wird, weil,
ja, das halt immer mehr
Leute, die nicht denken können oder
unfähig sind, im Hirn
irgendwie benutzen.
Die Leute werden im Durchschnitt auf diesen Plattformen
nur so Mainstreamen, das wird immer blöder.
Blöde Leute gibt's, aber die sind halt sonst nicht auf den Plattformen.
Früher hattest du auch noch
deutlich mehr,
also, zu Zeiten, als das Internet
halt noch nicht so Mainstream war,
und es halt noch ein bisschen komplizierter
war alles, da hattest du auch
viel, viel,
das hast du richtig gemerkt, ja, auch die Leute,
die das geschrieben haben und alles, die Leute waren
einfach, die hatten einfach mehr im Hirn,
die online waren.
Das ist aber auch ganz logisch, weil diese Plattform
damals
viel mehr technisches Verständnis
erfordert hat,
und dementsprechend halt auch
PC-technisch und
Internet, die Einstiegshürde war halt
einfach höher.
Das heißt, wenn du, wenn du
keine Ahnung hattest, konntest du's einfach nicht
benutzen, dementsprechend gab's die Leute
bist aber vor ihnen verschont gebliebt.
Ah, gut.
Ja, ich hab mir Affinity Designer
gekauft, super Ding.
Der Affinity Designer ist ein schönes Beispiel
für, wie man's richtig machen kann.
Kannst sau viel mit dem Programm
machen,
und es richtet sich trotzdem an
Leute, wie mich,
denen Photoshop zu kompliziert
ist, die eigentlich auch gar
keinen Bock haben, sie erst in Photoshop zu kaufen,
geschweige denn zu lernen,
aber trotzdem relativ simpel was machen wollen,
aber auch, wenn sie mal
mehr machen wollen, und sich damit beschäftigen,
auch noch mehr machen können. Also, das ist
ein echt super Programm.
Du meinst, äh, Sterbehilfe
501, äh, was auch immer,
äh, du meinst den Battlefield 1, oder?
Den Battlelog-Ersatz.
Ja.
Ich war am Anfang kein
Fan von Battlelog, aber
nach einer Weile fand ich Battlelog eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Zumal du halt einfach viel mehr Möglichkeiten
hast, so, äh, Informationen ordentlich
aufzubereiten in nem Browser,
anstatt, dass du das halt selbst basteln musst, alles
in ingame.
Oder im Client, weil du halt auch
Browser reinmachen kannst.
Ja. So, Leute. Es ist jetzt
fast 1 Uhr. Morgen
werde ich wahrscheinlich
kurz vor 20 Uhr am Start sein,
und da gucken wir uns zusammen
den EA E3 Stream
an. Wenn ihr Ideen
habt für irgendwelche
Bullshit-Bingo
Einträge auf der
Karte, schreibt die mir am besten auf Twitter.
Dann bastel
ich was für morgen zusammen.
So. Wir machen Schluss.
Wieder waren wir
online, äh,
4,5 Stunden.
Ne.
Ja, fast. Ja, 4,5 Stunden.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Wir sehen uns dann das nächste Mal.
Macht's gut. Bis denn. Tschüss.
Tschüss.